Since before the Ethan Klein and Hassan
rift started, Destiny was covering the
Ethan Klein and Hassan rift. By which I
mean desperately begging his community
to help him engineer it. Make sure to
stress that it's a current imminent risk
to the life and safety of the children.
You every time I talk, you like start
screaming. You start like screaming and
crying. No, he knows the argument
sucked. He just agrees with the
conclusion. He just hates denims.
>> Um cuz you're not you're just inhuman.
You might be a sociopath. Okay.
>> Okay. I
>> I don't think somebody's tickling her if
that's what you're asking.
>> What planet are you living on? What
[__] planet are you living on, dude?
>> That was my whole [__] point in the
[__] stream that you soed out about
and said I was a grifter.
>> Dude, I'm losing it. I can't take it. So
guys, we have a huge Destiny versus
Peace Go debate to watch. Destiny versus
Peace. Go debating about the Ethan Klein
stuff, Snark stuff, Hutch stuff, all
sorts of stuff. Loads of [__] going on.
A couple clips right now. Uh first to
watch from Destiny stream last night
where he was reviewing PC versus Peace
Go
and he was losing it. I I tuned in for
like maybe 10 minutes just between doing
stuff and yeah, it was like it was
mental. So why don't you go watch a
couple of these clips and just uh see
what he was saying
>> like that.
>> Presumably if you're joking about it
presumably if you're joking about it
after the fact and only after the fact
how do we know there's a causal
connection at all between what occurred
and the
>> I okay I normally I'm like good faith or
not good faith no I am good faith I'm
good faith towards everybody but I don't
say anything personally I actually
really hate the fact personally I'm very
personal that Pisco is making this
gaslight contributing argument. I don't
know if he's getting rotted by the
people in his chat or if he just lost
too many friends and he's like desperate
for either income or audience capture or
what, but this weird gaslighting thing
that occurs where a community of people
can stand around and and tacitly
implicitly support a thing, but if you
can't draw this direct causal connection
between A and B and this whole weird
stain now, well, if you're not
affirmatively attacking the thing, that
doesn't necessarily
>> So all Pisco is saying is that you have
responsibility for the things you do.
You don't have responsibility for the
things you don't do.
that that's all peace position is and
Destiny's losing his mind over it.
>> You mean that you approve it? Is this is
like this is A+ gaslighty weird [__]
behavior. I cannot believe that he's
moved over but well he has to I guess
for whatever tanky [__] he's adhering
to now. This is like reprehensible and
disgusting behavior that now he supports
this and at some point you need to have
like something needs to be turning on
your brain like why am I attracting all
these people that are celebrating this
type of behavior or engaging in this
type of behavior or at least looking
upon this kind of stuff favorably and
encouraging it to kind of be advertised
in their community. It's really
happening. But hey,
>> that's just my opinion, I guess. [__]
me.
>> I can your delusion. Yeah, it's like a
delusion you've constructed.
>> That's the first clip. Then we got this
one, too.
>> Casey Tron is being insincere in her
apology. And Ethan Klein
>> and this I I knew this guy was losing it
and [__] up when I when I heard this
>> knows her to be insincere. You would say
that it's okay for Ethan to lie about
that.
>> What I'm curious about, I just really
want to know cuz I don't spend enough
time in these discords. I just want to
know where Pisco got this argument
because it didn't come from him. This is
either I don't know if Joanna would make
this kind of an argument. Aaron might
just go and his Discord server might I
don't know if Pisco hangs out in all
Pisco is not even saying what he
rethinks right now. He's just saying
what his girlfriend told him say. Like
this guy is spazzing out. He used to
literally he used to absolutely love
this Joanna silly serious the girl
dating peace. He used to think this
woman was so [__] smart. Didn't he
like reformat like 70% of his debate
points because she told him about
Wickenstein? Am I crazy or is that like
not a thing that happened like four
years ago?
Yeah, because dating silly serious.
Yeah, pages. Pretty sure that happened
like a few years ago. And he would like
bang on about how [__] smart this
woman was. So, and now he's like she's
probably just poisoning Pisco's mind.
All right, man.
All right, man. there. There's no world
where this argument originated in
Pisco's brain, though. He's He's not
this stupid. There's He might be dumb
enough to carry water for this argument,
but there's no world where he's so
stupid that he would make this argument
um up. It's just not possible. It can't
that can't just can't be the case.
>> Casey Tron is being
>> cool stuff.
So with those couple clips in mind,
Pisco starts talking to Kfka Esquire,
who is one of the only lawyers left in
DG,
I believe. I believe he's a lawyer.
Um,
and yeah, he went on to argue with Pisco
and then Destiny's going to come in and
defend him because he can't do it on his
own. son was to saying this. You know, I
speculate that the reason why Ethan
Klein has taken this position for
whatever reason is because he just he
hates Palestinians. He has an
anti-Muslim bias or some other
accusation. Basically, the accusation of
me is that I want this woman to be
harassed, this girl to be harassed,
right?
I want this person to be harassed, this
person I've never met, this person who's
not harmed me, who's not wronged me, I
want to protect her, the people who are
attacking her on his view. I yeah I as I
said in our we discussed earlier in the
discord for the discord that I I have
not seen all of the uh I've not seen all
around this I haven't seen I'm not here
to like defend or um
>> you know like comment on that. I'm just
saying like to me it I I can't say that
like it's it makes no sense at all that
he's like having questions about your
association with those people.
>> Okay. So I just brought brought in
Destiny. Destiny, why did you say that?
>> Destiny, you hired me to protect you in
these situations. All right. That's why
you paint that retainer. Come on. my
job. Jesus Christ. Okay. My comment was
a compliment because there is no world
where any of the dog [__] arguments that
you were wheeling out against other
people came from your mind. They had to
have come from other community. I cannot
believe you have cognitively degraded.
>> Which which argument?
>> So this weird binary obsession you have
with culpability when you know that
ethics don't work that way and the law
doesn't work that way. Why would you
pretend that culpability is literally a
binary yes or no?
>> So I I don't think you understood what I
was saying there and I think that you've
misconstrued it. And so it's possible
you just don't understand what I'm
saying.
>> Sure. So I understand what you're
saying. The problem is what you're
saying is not a thing that anybody
believes. He spent half the conversation
trying to distinguish between
>> Destiny understands everything. So
there's no way Destiny could possibly
not understand something Pico was saying
cuz he understands everything. I
understand everything. I understand
everything.
>> Dude, he literally sounds so like such a
[__] child this whole conversation,
bro. It's so funny.
>> Responsibilities and obligations and
separating those things from the harms
that they cause. That was one of the
reasons why Hutch had so much problem
like understanding what you were saying
cuz literally nobody talks about
obligations or responsibilities separate
from the harms they cause. This is why
the more responsibility, the more
obligation you have, it's usually
because as a result of not fulfilling
those obligations or responsibilities,
more harm will come from not fulfilling
those roles or things. And you trying to
pretend that like having a
responsibility and failing to adhere to
that responsibility, you're not culpable
for any of the harms that follow. That's
just an that's an untenable absurd
position. There's no way that you
believe that. I can't I can't believe
that you believe that. I
>> I think the better inference is that you
just don't understand what I'm saying.
And I can clarify it. So you think so
what what I'm understanding you to say
is that you think that my position is
that when I say something like the word
responsibility that I'm somehow
distinguishing it from like ethical
responsibility and that therefore we
cannot like put someone morally at fault
for things where I'm referring to it as
responsibility. But the truth is you
just don't understand what I'm saying. I
do think that people can be held
responsible for reckless and negligent
action. What kind of person do you think
I would be to think that they couldn't
be?
Then how could you possibly argue that
you couldn't be held somewhat ethically
culpable for the behavior that your
community engages in if you are directly
contributing to the things that are
causing them to engage that way
>> because you just didn't understand what
I meant.
>> You stop saying I didn't understand
because nobody spoke to you realize
nobody you I heard Joanna talk to on
stream that nobody understands what
you're saying. So don't don't pretend
that everybody's getting it except for
me. Nobody understands what you're
saying. Yeah, it plenty of people on the
sound what Pisco saying.
No, no one say Pisco. Literally, no one
could possibly understand it, dude.
Anyone that's got like a you know, like
reading age above 12,
you know, may maybe it requires you to
have like finished high school to like
fully follow the conversation. Maybe
that's why Hutch was struggling so much.
Maybe it requires you to be like at
least like in some way mentally capable
of,
you know,
doing anything other than music degree.
Maybe it requires that. Maybe it
requires that. Or at least maybe you
have to be able to pass a music degree
if
>> Okay. You're having seven hour
conversations with friends on podcasts
who don't understand what you're saying.
So please stop pretending that. Okay.
>> Okay. So So let's like hash it out and
make sure that you agree, right? um with
what I'm saying and whether or not after
I've explained um what I've said whether
or not you agree with it. So I
understand ethical culpability to be
equal to moral faults. Another word for
that is responsibility. Okay. And and
and I Okay. And I think that you are
only ethically culpable for the ethical
wrongs you do. You in fact do. Okay. So
you are not ethically culpable for
ethical transgressions that you do not
in fact the hatred towards music
degrees. I know like two people maybe I
think two people who did music degrees
and they're both just working
hospitality.
>> You agree with that, right? So far,
>> no, there is a there's a transitive
thing that happens that you're
completely missing. Let's say that
somebody creates a trap in the middle of
a room and I tell somebody knowing
there's a trap there, walk.
>> Oh, hang on. I think you just hold on
one second. So, is my Twitch stream up
right now? Uh, just because you're
banned, right? I just got to make sure
it's offline.
>> I'm pretty sure they rewrote the rules
for Hassan like 12 times, so you're
probably
>> I just I just undid the Twitch.
>> You send somebody to walk down a hallway
knowing there's a trap in the middle of
the room and they fall into the trap.
>> You're trying to do this weird game of
saying, "Well, you didn't actually place
the trap and make them fall into it."
So, what you would be morally culpable
of is giving them bad advice knowing
that they might fall into the trap, but
you wouldn't be responsible for them
actually falling into the trap itself.
>> So, so
>> that's your position. Yes. So no, it's I
mean it's not my position in the way
that you've described it right there. So
my position is that one's ethical fault
that their state of mind is integral to
the kind of ethical uh um you know
transgression that we're talking about.
So for example, you have an ethical
obligation to refrain from intentionally
and maliciously causing the death of
your child. You'd agree with that,
right?
>> Sure. There's there's no ethical
obligation to be free from you know
ending your child's life in every
respect right I mean there could be some
situations in which your child is an
initial aggressor against you right and
where you would be justified to end your
child's life in other words one's moral
fault
>> is directly related in our heads and the
transgression to a state of mind right
and when I say you you know you don't
have ethical fault
>> oh lit I didn't have a chance to read
any news before I started today
dude this is huge. Thank [__] K's got
me back. K's got me back. He made that
dumb statement yesterday. K's got me
back. Launching a formal investigation
into foreign election interference.
Let's go. Let's go. That's huge. That's
huge.
>> For intentionally calling CPS, it means
only that. That you don't have ethical
culpability,
>> but you would have an ethical fault for
luring other people or encouraging other
people or baiting other people into
doing it.
>> Yeah. So, you would be ethically
culpable. as I was trying to lay out to
Hutch for reckless.
>> Hold on. To be clear, tell me if I
mistate you, you very very cleverly and
bizarrely.
>> Damn Ruskies. Damn Yanks. Bro, I I'm not
even thinking about Russian election
interference at this point. You crazy
>> around that by saying that the only
obligation you had was to make sure that
you were um behaving in such a way that
made it so that you weren't getting
banned by Twitch or otherwise coming
under harm of the Twitch terms of
service. basically any ethical
obligation. You spent like 3 hours
arguing this. You can pretend that I
didn't understand or didn't understand.
Nobody understood this. But yeah, I I I
understand you're a really bad
communicator.
>> We can just do it one by one. We can
just Well, cuz I don't know if you're
going to I don't I don't know if you're
going to rewrite the whole thing. So,
let's just stick on the examples that
you gave.
>> Wait, wait, wait. No, because you just
made a claim that I was I was being
shifty and clever. You were. But wait,
wait, wait. Yes. Well, I I just want to
take cuz you just said something that
like I was limiting the amount of
exposure in the case of you know
increasing risk to only um you know
consequences related to Twitch but that
didn't happen Stephen that was the first
thing I mentioned and then after that I
said and also
>> if you want we can find well if you want
we can find the exact clip. Yeah. Okay.
>> Oh my god dude. Literally it just keeps
getting better. What am I seeing? My
Twitter timeline's going crazy. The UK
is set to rejoin the Arasmus scheme.
Dude, they said they weren't They said
they probably weren't going to do this
and it was going to be a new youth
mobility scheme. They're just going back
to Arasmus. That's Let's go. That's
huge. That's huge. That's huge.
That's huge.
This is massive.
Huge changes. Just total W care.
said something along the lines of um are
you saying it was something like is
there no reason not to or why shouldn't
you moderate your community or something
like that or what is the purpose of
moderating your community and your
response was something along the lines
of like well as long as the action isn't
too burdensome you should do whatever
you need to in order to um basically
make it so you don't come under to
action from the platform and then you
very cleverly snuck in now the bad
actions down the road might tie into
this but it but you were do you were
doing a huge work there to separate any
bad actions that resulted from your lack
of moderation to the um we can find the
cause if we want it's not the case I
think it's because you read into for
example and we can use this one the bad
empanada situation when they ask me
don't you agree so this is what Hutch
says right Hutch says you agree bad
empanada is a micious actor and I said I
know he has a reputation for uh being a
malicious actor and I've seen him act in
conformity with it so my answer is yes
and when you heard that me say that in
real time just reacting honestly you
took that negative negatively. You took
a negative inference against the way I
phrase that.
>> Hold on. Wait, wait, wait. Repeat what
you just So, wait. Let me just
understand. You think that bad empanada
is somebody that engages in bad
behavior?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. I could be wrong and maybe I
missed it. I don't know if I heard you
say that yesterday. I feel like I heard
you say 15 times, I know that bad
epinata has a reputation for engaging in
bad behavior. I feel like I heard you
say that 10 or 15 times. I don't know if
I've ever heard.
>> He was He was totally clear. He says he
knows he has that reputation. He has
seen some evidence to support it. He
does not know the full details, but he
is accepting that that is that seems to
be the case. It seems to be that bad
empanada acts that way. But he's not
going to make statements that he hasn't
100% looked into. Why would he do that?
If peace go isn't confident that he
knows what bad empanada has done, why
would he make firm statements about the
type of conduct bad empanada engages in?
Why would he do that? That's so stupid.
Yeah, but he's the bad guy. But he's the
bad guy.
Pisco is saying I don't say he's got
this reputation. I've seen some stuff.
I've seen like him saying Blown the
Box's dad was involved in Sar. I've seen
bits and pieces here. I've heard things.
I haven't looked into it all, but yeah,
I'm willing to accept this. It's like
totally reasonable to do that.
This is This is Destiny. You could be uh
forgiven for thinking it's stale from
the voice, but it's not. It's Destiny.
actually directly state, yes, bad
empanada engages in behavior like
doxying and other things that's made him
not welcome on Hassan stream or whatever
else when he's not being a convenient
weapon for him.
>> If if it's the case that I did do that,
if I said in summon in substance, I've
heard he I I know that he has reputation
for malicious action. I've seen him do
stuff which I would consider to be
malicious and therefore my answer is
yes. If my answer was that, would you
owe me an apology?
>> No.
>> No. But you said that the reason that
this happened is because I've been
talking to Aaron and she's been telling
me that there's an equivalence between
that empanada and you and that's why I
said that. Like what under what
circumstances would you like ever take
accountability for the kind of reckless
and false statements you're making about
me, including this bad bit?
>> It doesn't seem like you you apologize
under any circumstances.
>> You have zero. So you have z that's the
you're the funniest person in the world
to ever utter that comment. Um number
one. Number two, I mean, you yourself
have said that apparently we have no
moral obligations or moral or ethical
obligations for anything that comes from
our community engaging in harm or
whatever. So, whatever I say about you,
as long as I'm not getting moderated
against, it should be fine world. Okay.
Number two, number three, for you to be
so careful when Hutch was talking to you
and for any human, okay, when you say,
"Is it possible or Ethan could have two
motivations for this behavior, right?"
And Hutch goes, "Well, yeah, it's
possible that he's motivated by two
things." And you're like, "Well, hold
on, sir. When you say that it's
logically possible, meaning that no
contradiction is entailed by him
inhabiting two positions, that doesn't
necessarily mean that you personally
believe that he has two positions, for
you to be so careful to to like hardcore
come down on every single word that
Hutch chooses and then for you to slime
around with, well, I understand that
Banana has a reputation for doing these
things. He he he while later on like not
being familiar with any of the
underlying clips or videos or anything
from this issue you've talked about for
like a year isn't correct.
>> So, let's let's just steal one thing at
a time. It was
He's saying Fisco has been talking about
the Ethan Klein stuff for a year. No, he
hasn't. No, he has not. He spoke about
the When was Hassan's Global Entry
thing? Hassan's Global Entry pass was
revoked in like January or like after
January, I think like February or March
or something. And then the the trip he
took was in like May, June, maybe even
July. That was when he first started
talking about Hassan stuff
significantly. Then the lawsuits were
filed slightly after that. Whenever that
happened, it was the lawsuits were
slightly after. He's been speaking about
that. So for about six months, he's been
speaking about Ethan related stuff. He's
not a big on the [__] you know,
extended to S beef. He doesn't know all
the details of everything bad in Pernard
and Dennis did and Casey Tron didn't all
this stuff the whole lead up. He just
knows about the lawsuits because that's
what he's interested in is the global
entry and the lawsuits. Obviously,
how can you not know literally every
single thing bad's ever done? Dude, what
the [__] are you on about, bro? You're
like a total spaz.
So, the notion that uh first off, I'm
It's something wrong with me clarifying
what Hutch means by can someone have
multiple motives. The reason I do that
is because I have had experience.
>> That's not my complaint. No. No. What is
my complaint? you saying that I'm unfort
terribly mentally disabled with person
in chat. His global entry was revoked
about 10 months ago.
Now the trip where he found out his
global entry was revoked was not for
several months after.
And that drama has nothing to do with
Ethan Klein or bad empanada. It is
simply his son and the government. Now
peace involved in Ethan Klein stuff with
the lawsuits which was even later than
that. So it was not a year ago at all.
It was a few months ago.
So nice one. You absolute [__]
pedophile.
>> Level of sophistication and granularity
when it comes to Hutch's language that I
don't apply to my own. That's your
complaint, isn't it? Okay. I'm trying to
I'm trying to undermine that, right? And
the way I would undermine that is by
because this is a what you're doing is
an attack on my character, isn't it?
You're saying I'm being slimy. Correct.
>> Yeah. Because the arguments are
The reason why it's relevant that I
bring up um my good purpose and why I
would bring up and have particular
language with one thing and not the
other is specifically to defend your
character attack. And so you would agree
it's relevant for me to bring up the
justification for me being particular my
language in the example you brought up.
Right. That's relevant.
>> You keep you keep I don't know if you're
aware of you're doing
>> you think so. You think so.
>> I'm not attacking you for being
particular with your language. I'm
attacking you for being
yes. So, so, so one way in which I could
uh attack your criticism of me, namely
that I'm being hypocritical, is to
justify both my language initially and
to justify my language with respect to
Adam Banana, right? That would be a way
to address the hypocrisy. How else would
I address it, Stephen?
>> Well, the difference was between the
Sure. The difference would be your your
framing of every single thing you say
and every single thing he says in the
beginning of the conversation when
you're setting up the the whole meta
conversation for you to be so careful
with your language there. and then in
the last entire half of the conversation
to be mixing up words and throwing
random things around and and doing
whatever else and not giving any
charitability or any understanding to
Hutch's side of the conversation. I I
don't I don't think that the same um I
don't think that the same skeptical lens
>> Dude, what does he mean not giving any
charity to Hutch's side in the
conversation? Hutch was barely
presenting a side in the conversation.
He was just going, "Yeah, but can't you
understand that Ethan would be so upset
and pulling [__] [__] faces the
whole time?" That's all he did. The
whole four hours. There wasn't like a
strong substantive argument from Hutch
>> was applied in both houses.
>> How would I go about starting to prove
that you're wrong? What would it take
for me? What kinds of things would I
need to show to in the context of that
conversation or is this an unfalsifiable
assertion that you're making that no
amount of
>> We would have to rewatch the we would
have to rewatch the conversation and go
and go through some of the examples.
Well, should I be addressly stating that
Hut had a positive claim that he needed
to um justify to you in an argument or
whatever? That wasn't true. You came in
with a positive claim and you didn't
have any of the justifications for your
claim and you were saying that he was
lacking evidence to to prove his.
>> So, so can we is it okay for me to
examine what you just brought up? Right.
Is the claim about burdens? Okay. So,
you just said um you claimed that Hutch
had um a specific burden in the nature
of the con of the conversation, but how
can that be given the fact that you're
the one walking in with a positive
claim? Right. That's what you just said.
>> Correct.
>> Okay. But just because I walk in with a
positive claim and I have a burden with
respect to what I'm proving doesn't mean
that Hutch if to the extent that he
makes a positive claim doesn't have a
burden for what he's saying. Right.
>> You agree with that?
>> Kind of.
>> No. That is obviously true.
>> Just because the other person is making
a positive claim without substantiation
does not mean that you can make a
positive claim without substantiation,
right? You you would need both would
have a burden of proof for their
positive claim to to stand, right?
Obviously, any positive claim requires a
burden of proof. questionable about that
if you don't mind me asking.
>> The questionable thing is if you were to
walk into the middle of an argument
between two other people where you
weren't caught up on any of the
discussion and then you were to try to
interject and have a conversation
>> but Hutch doesn't have the info either.
You can literally give give Hutch a week
to go study Ethan Klein drama. Say
Hutch, I'm giving you 10 grand. Your
whole week is paid for. Just take the
whole week off. Okay, Hutch, I'm giving
you 10 grand. Take the whole week off.
Study Ethan Klein drama intently.
He would come back to the conversation
just as [__]
He would come back still going. Okay.
Yeah, sure. I understand that Denim's
Denim's whole chat wasn't spamming um
call CPS. I understand it was only uh 3%
of her chat that was saying call CPS in
a in a 5minute period.
I understand that Denim's never actually
made a positive claim about Ethan's
kids. cuz I understand she never
actually said they were going to die,
but don't you think that Ethan would
feel really bad seeing that stream? That
would be it. After after you gave him 10
grand, you give him a year to study
this. 10 give him 100 grand. You give
him a year to study this. You're like,
"Hutch, I want you to become
an Ethan Klein scholar. I want you to
know everything about this. It would not
change. Nothing would change because the
issue isn't a matter of information
between Pisco and Hutch. It's that Hutch
is biased. He is engaging in motivated
reasoning
and he is not actually attempting to
argue
with the other person. And then we if
you were to act indignant or if you were
to say that the other person is burdened
by the necessity to show proof for his
claims when he's apparently wasn't even
ready to have he didn't realize like how
unfamiliar you were with all the
underlying material that you've
apparently been talking about for a
year. I just find that to be incredibly
bad. That's an insane burden to place
on. You've literally been talking about
Ethan Klein versus Badam Panala for a
whole year.
>> Reproduce every single clip at that
point of the conversation was something
I'm sure he thought that you'd seen at
that point. So some of these clips had
been central to this debate that had
been happening for almost a year.
>> I I view that as a kind of explosion of
the claim descent. So I understand that
broadly you think I'm I'm being unfair
and I'm demanding a kind of level of
evidence that I myself am not providing.
But I'm just focusing specifically on
this this one point. I mean there's
nothing inconsistent with both of us
having evidentiary burdens that we have
to satisfy. isn't
>> like this is literally pure emotion from
Destiny. It's like I'm really upset
about this debate you just had.
>> Like okay, can you focus on the claim
that you've made and and prove the claim
you've made
>> with a claim? Does it mean and I have
the burden to show it? Doesn't mean that
he also doesn't, right? I mean, you
agree with that. So, I don't understand
why this kind of
>> Not necessarily. I mean, if you come in
with a positive claim and he's playing
the negation, the burden would be on you
initially like you were saying.
>> He's literally just trying to zoom back
out to like general statements so he can
just keep like waxing about his [__]
emotions about this debate. is so
[__] annoying for her.
>> Thought that he was the one with the
positive claim. The burden would be on
you initially to present proof of your
claim.
>> So, so I it is my claim, right? It's my
claim for various things. One, that
Ethan is lying uh about a couple
different things. It's my burden that
he's not actually, you know, motivated
by a particular rationale. And in that
part of the conversation, I know exactly
why we were talking about what we were
talking about, which is essentially uh
what this will ground down into is is
doing this kind of uh lawsuit against
these kinds of people justified. And
what most people say is it's a you know
it's justified because of their culpable
conduct because they've done something
that for which they deserve this. And so
we were at the point where I was saying
I was asking why do they deserve it? And
Hutch was saying well they deserve it
because of a reason and given that it
was his claim, right? he is trying to
justify in that moment the um why it was
is morally correct to do this lawsuit
against them in that context. I think it
makes perfect sense to say that it's his
burden to show that claim and I don't
think there's anything wrong and I want
you
>> guys on neutral if you guys had met on
neutral ground to arrange a conversation
whatever then sure but for him having
had discussed this for so long and then
for you to come in presenting the claim
that you don't believe any of this was
justified and then with with basically
from what I saw no proof of your own you
start demanding him to provide the
negation of your completely
unsubstantiated view. I don't know. I
just think it was a it was a really
aggressive and shitty way to to frame
that to a person who didn't seem like
they were trying to play gotchas at all.
On the contrary, you were doing it to
him the entire conversation.
>> It it's my claim that I don't have a
reason to believe that these um that
these lawsuits are justified and I've
been very
>> about the lawsuits being justified. It
was I think it was just basically on
like what had Denim said or what had
Casey Tron said or whatever that that
before build up the Coabilly
>> argument. So, so one is I I am familiar
with a lot of their statements and the
ones that people bring up to me and
anyone it's it's so trivial to to show
this is because so many people in my
open calls in which again this is more
evidence to suggest I'm not bad faith
and just taking a position because just
entire community has been celebrating
the unrestricted harassment of the rose
girl. One evidence that that's not the
case is the fact that I'm open to having
people of all types come and produce
evidence to me and I've
>> wait what was that? What was that? and
anyone it's so trivial to to show this
is because any of this was justified
>> in that context I think it makes perfect
sense to say that it's his burden to
show that claim and I don't think
there's anything wrong and I want you
>> guys on neutral if you guys had met on
neutral ground to arrange a conversation
whatever then sure but for him having
had discussed this for so long and then
for you to come in presenting the claim
that you don't believe any of this was
justified and then with with basically
from what I saw no proof of your own.
You start demanding him to provide the
negation of your completely
unsubstantiated view. I don't know. I
just think it was a it was a really
aggressive and shitty way to to frame
that to a person who didn't seem like
they were trying to play gotchas at all.
On the contrary, you were doing it to
him the entire conversation.
>> It it's my claim that I don't have a
reason to believe that these um that
these lawsuits are justified. And I've
been very open. Is Hutch a child? Yeah.
Basically, Hutch is like so [__]
that he has to be treated like a child.
Yes.
>> Justified. It was I think it was just
basically on like what had denim said or
what had Casey Tron said or whatever
that before build up the cobility
argument.
>> So so one is I I am familiar with a lot
of their statements and the ones that
people bring up to me and anyone it's so
trivial to to show this is because so
many people in my open calls in which
again this is more evidence to suggest
I'm not bad faith and just taking a
position because just entire community
has been celebrating the unrestricted
harassment of the rose girl. One
evidence that that's not the case is the
fact that I'm open to having people of
all types come and produce evidence to
me and I've had conversations about
these particular statements. And um
oftentimes I'll let the statements play
out and I'm familiar with them. I have
seen that clip of Denims before. I've
seen the clip of the Giardia before. Um
now I'm not going to claim to know all
of their streams, which is what Hutch
was asking for, which I think was um not
justified.
>> Asking for you to be familiar with all
of their streams?
>> No. No. with with their content
generally in in like a
>> all of their content. By the way, you
saying that right now you said that
multiple times I've seen all of
by by all I mean a substantial
significant portion of their streams.
That's what I mean in this context.
>> Okay. Even that's not true, right? Mark
doesn't expect you to be familiar with a
significant portion of their streams,
right? These people stream for thousands
of hours, right?
>> So he he was claiming
>> acknowledge that
>> they stream for thousands of hours. I I
acknowledge they stream for thousand
hours.
>> Do you think that Okay. You acknowledged
Hutchie wasn't asking you for you to be
familiar with the majority of their
stream, 51% plus or even 10% of all the
hours they've streamed, right?
>> That I be generally familiar with how
their streams are run,
>> I think, is what he's pointing out. Do
you disagree with that characterization?
>> That can be an okay characterization.
Generally familiar with can be
generalized from a small subset of
content though, not having seen most of
their videos. Again, I'm only I'm only
harping on this because you were so
careful qualifying his language earlier
when it played to your favor that for
you to throw on, oh, I have to know most
of their content is an absurd statement
compared to I need to be generally
familiar with how they engage with their
content. You
>> you're you're alleging that um it is
possible to gain a representative sample
of how one runs their content based on a
a small segment of their streams. That's
right.
>> It can be. Yeah.
>> Okay. And so, uh, when Hutch asked that
question, I think what he was implying
is, I did not have sufficient
familiarity with their content for the
scope of my claims, which I think is
preposterous. I think that the scope of
my claims
>> Well, it it seemed like you had almost
no like understanding of their content
whatsoever when he was asking questions
like virtue of what is that. Is that
clear?
>> So, when you saying things like, "Well,
I don't know if they ever read their
chat."
>> No, I No.
>> It seems like you've never seen any of
their content ever. making a statement.
You didn't seem to offer up any positive
claims about like this is what I think
it's like you asking for him to justify
every single statement he made.
>> Hang on. Hang on. Just slow down. All
right. I think that merely showing that
something appeared to come back to in a
stream in the chat
>> isn't sufficient for us to conclude that
there's been a failure to moderate. And
you would agree with that. I'm sure that
there are times in people's streams in
which I would agree with that matter.
That wasn't the subject. That wasn't the
subject of the conversation. The subject
is if you do a stream that is centered
on a topic and messages are showing up
that seem to run in parallel with what
the video is saying, with what you're
implying, with what the rest of your
community is saying, that for you to
retreat to this thing of like, well,
isn't it possible that maybe they missed
that one message is like saying maybe
it's possible somebody missed the
swastika when they were walking to to
Hitler's bedroom. Like this is such an
absurd statement given the context of
what was being talked about. It's not
like there was a single chat message
that went by that Denims didn't catch.
She was watching a hit piece video on
Ethan, reading comments literally about
calling CPS and everything else and
giggling and laughing along with it and
talking about the deadly dangerousness
of the disease. I
>> if some I I don't think it's absurd at
all as you try to characterize just then
and I want to be able to finish this.
>> Okay, wait. So, wait, I just want to be
I just want to hold on. I just want to
put a pin in this then. Do you think
that Denims was aware that people in her
chat more likely than not were were
calling for uh CPS calls and saying
stuff akin to this?
>> Okay, then you then why even have the
conversation? What have you been talking
about for a year if if you're not even
sure of this? So, so
>> you had a seven-hour conversation with
us yesterday. I I I just want to be
clear, you're certain. What is your
level of certainty that she saw the
messages that you claimed that she saw?
>> 95 plus%. There could be some brain
disease. There could be some other thing
going on or whatever, but
>> Okay. And that's because the the chats
in fact showed up, right? That's why you
believe it.
>> No, there's a ton of stuff we can we can
look at her her reaction afterwards to
to all of the calls and everything else
and the giggling and the celebrating and
the joking about everything else. But
but but you would agree that's not what
is being talked about. What we're
talking about here is a failure to
moderate, right? That's not contingent
on her reaction to the bad empanada
video, is it?
>> No, but her reaction to the bad empanada
video can definitely give us insight
into whether or not we feel like she
might have seen the message. For
instance, if that CPS call comes out and
her reaction, I don't know why you're
asking me this. You know the answer to
this. If the reaction to that message
comes out and she's like, Jesus, guys,
what the [__] Well, like this isn't
cool in my community. We don't do [__]
like this. And I was like,
>> wait, so so I just want to say assuming
she saw it, right? assuming she actually
saw it. But her reaction to the bad
empanada video, I just want you to make
sure you answer it.
>> Wait, wait, wait. I've let you ask your
question whatsoever. Any of these
messages in any awareness of them at
all?
>> No, you asked that question and what did
I answer? Do you remember what I
answered?
>> The reaction to the messages themselves
moderate.
>> No, you asked the question. Do you think
that she saw those messages? You asked
it. Do you remember what I answered
>> that we don't that you said you don't
know? I don't know. But you say you do
know, right?
>> Probabilistic guess.
>> And the reason and in virtue of what can
you make that probabilistic insight?
>> Because streamers generally watch their
chat because chat will generally respond
to messages in stream because streamers
usually have other moderators in their
chat.
>> So So the only thing that I'm bringing
up here and the reason why I'm bringing
that up is because yes, streamers watch
their chat. I watch my chat. Hutch
watches my chat. I know from experience
and I'm sure you know from experience
that if there are if a small amount of
people as compared to a big amount of
people as oppo compared to a moderate
amount of people uh you know making a
certain comment that will bear or
whether we're looking at chat that will
bear on whether or not we ought to have
culpability for a failure to moderate
you would agree with that right some get
>> not necessarily no it depends on the
comment of course not
>> so so there's a situation in which let's
say one
>> I just don't
so what is the uh what is the
obligation? What is the obligation? Do
you have to discourage it? Is
discouraging always even a good thing?
Do you like if it's just like it's not
that many people who are actually saying
call CPS, it's like a few people. The
very small percentage of the messages
that we in chat
does it make like
why bring attention to it if it's just a
couple of people? If it's like one or
two people, why bring attention to it? I
can maybe understand deleting the
messages or timing the people out or
maybe even banning
But the idea you would discourage it
like I don't think you would draw
attention to it if it's only a couple
people that's like just it it doesn't
make any sense to you.
>> Person in DGG says something crazy crazy
crazy crazy crazy crazy. the more the
worst things
>> I do [__] like someone makes a [__]
insane joke I'll do that as a joke right
I'll go like oh that person chat that's
that's insane terrible thing to say and
you shouldn't say stuff like
you know that's cuz obviously if it's
just one person saying something just
time them out you don't have to bring
attention to it
>> possibly right in DGG and no one catches
it that changing the level of intensity
of the message is going to bear on
whether or not there's a failure to
moderate
>> correct because I think that depending
on the community that you've cultivated
and depending on the moderators you
have, I think people in chat would be
responsive in a predictable manner to
that message. Yes. If somebody in chat
typed out a lengthy thing of this, I'm
going to drive down and kill uh you
know, Kfka Esquire, I've got I'm going
to drive down, I'm going to murder him
in chat, and they type out a whole thing
in chat and nobody says or responds
anything. I don't believe that that
would happen. It's that's beyond me.
>> So, so Kfka, I mean, I'll I'll appeal to
you. Is that convincing to you? So
because some uh you know individuals say
some bad things in the chat absent a
showing that this person
>> some individual saying a bad thing of
it's about cultivating a community to be
receptive to these messages watching a
video that is parallel to these messages
reading chat comments that seem to align
with these messages and then having the
messages show up in chat. You're making
it seem like it was a mysterious case of
this message was a one-time thing that
popped out of nowhere. Obviously I would
be sympathetic to that um because
because the intent aspect from the both
the community and the streamer are
completely absent there. something
you've completely never spoke about at
all almost to Hutch in that
conversation. Um, but when the intent
seems to be there, at least heavily
implied from the creator, and when the
receptiveness is there from the
community, and then the messages start
to pop up, you can't act like that's a
happy accident. Who knew? Lol. Oops.
Especially given the response to those
messages afterwards,
>> which was to condemn it, right?
>> One second. This
>> condemned the CPS calls.
>> Did Did Denim say that she didn't agree
with the CPS calls?
>> I feel like this was after a lot of
pushing.
>> But do you know? No, no,
>> I
>> She said on the stream after it
happened.
>> I don't I didn't follow this or talk
about this obsessively for a year. So,
no. I I probably saw this clip like
seven months ago. You want to go and
find the clip to see what her
>> resp Oh, so you're saying Destiny,
you're saying you don't have
>> a general understanding of the topic.
You have a general But you have been
covering this for far longer than Pisco
for far more hours,
don't you? Haven't you? Haven't you the
whole time? Haven't you've been you've
been covering this literally since
before it started.
Since before the Ethan Klein and Hassan
rift started, Destiny was covering the
Ethan Klein and Hassan rift. By which I
mean desperately begging his community
to help him engineer it.
Anyone that was there remembers? Anyone
that was watching the content remembers
what he used to watch Leftovers. Anytime
there was a disagreement, he would be
watching it. He would be spazzing out
saying how insane Hassan is. Oh, he's
saying all this crazy stuff and Ethan
just can't quite pick up on it. Ethan's
just like a normy and oh, he's being
taken for a ride by Hassan. He literally
would say he said this for years. It
went on about this. The whole time
leftovers was on. It started falling out
over October 7th and he went even
harder. his whole community moved in.
We all watched it. We all watched it.
But now all of a sudden, even though
Destiny has been obsessively covering
this for like three or four years, he
doesn't have the info. He doesn't have
the info. A that's a shame,
>> Ken. I I just think that when there's a
failure to moderate and someone is
making claims that she absolutely saw it
and had a bad response to it, I think
the burden is on them. And just saying,
"Well, streamers generally look at their
chats." Um, that's I don't think that's
going to do it. I mean, I'm sure
>> claim is that I responded to trans
allegations chat. Why do you keep saying
that? I was in the chat.
>> Plus, that the messages were really
depraved. I think you in order to say
that there's like some uh
irresponsibility here. You're going to
have to look at the number of messages,
any evidence that she actually saw the
messages, any message, any evidence that
someone, you know, DM'd it to her.
That's the kind of stuff to show that
claim, not just that it existed. No.
>> No. You don't even believe this. This is
why I'm saying your arguments are
coming. You're not I know you're not
this stupid. What? Let's let's back
that. You would need every single one of
these like discrete percentage figures
on like what was the messages per hour
and how what was the eye tracking on the
screen per hour and what was the blah
blah blah. If I was watching a video on
stream that talked about how to kill
black people and while I was watching
this video I was laughing along like,
"Oh man, you could kill black people
that way." And then some people in chat
started typing up like, "Oh man, I'm
going to go kill a black person. There's
this black person near me that I should
kill." And then 5 days later a black
person near me ends up getting killed.
There's no way that a year later you'd
be like, "Well, do we really know that
Destiny saw that particular message in
chat?" Like, what were the messages per
hour? Like, we know that sometimes he
doesn't catch every single message. You
say, "Well, you're you're clearly
cultivating a community of people that
are receptive to the message. You're
watching a video that is echoing the
message and you're laughing along and
giggling at the message."
>> But let's just break it down. I mean, so
if if there's an unhinged individual in
your chat and um they say something
totally unhinged and the community just
kind of like disregards him, they don't
no one brings it to your attention. And
it and you know it turns out uh later on
um let's not introduce for the moment
and we can add it later that you're um
you know that you're cultivating the
community go after these people whatever
you want to say but just that just that
by itself you don't think that we would
say well hang on you can't blame Destiny
for this you can't blame Destiny for
this they didn't see the
when it was and and when it was brought
to let me wait Stephen can I can I
please finish
ask you question my question let's go
piece by piece right I agree that if it
was one crazy message. You wouldn't hold
a person accountable for that. For sure.
>> So, so we're talking about here.
>> No, no. And what I would say is,
>> hang on a second. Right to bear arms
didn't see that. And as soon as it was
brought to uh Steven's attention, they
banned the person, right? These are the
arguments that you had all the time with
people who would come.
>> So glad. So glad Pisco is bringing this
stuff up. Very true. These standards
seem to have changed, don't they? These
standards seem to have changed very
quickly according to what you need them
to be.
>> Be like, "Oh my god, look at this. This
comment that was right there. It was so
mean. and it was so horrible and and you
didn't do anything about it and you just
let it happen and you and this is the
exact same arguments that I you were
like well listen I hold my community to
high standard and when it's brought to
my attention we take action that's what
you would always say and I would say
okay that's reasonable right if someone
is doing something and they like there's
a lot of [__] that happens
>> the same thing over yeah this isn't this
situation though so so the analogy I'm
guessing is because of um the fact that
they're cultivating like snarkers or
people who um do a certain thing right
who are have a certain malicious
attitude is that
Um, I would say the probably the larger
aspect here is the fact that that Denims
was watching a video that was bas
>> total cope lie. Literally about to say a
total cope [__] [__] Total lie.
His standards about the communities.
>> Que man isn't le pipeline. Que man is
the patient zero in the UK that's
affecting all the UK twinks to trans
them like a trans vampire unrelated to
him being. Some of you people have
fixations on like trans [__] and gay
[__] I'm going to be real, okay? Some
of you have just like fixations on trans
and gay [__] Thank you for the money.
But I seriously think like keep it to
yourself. Keep it to yourself. We get
it. You like can't stop thinking about
the idea of like women with dicks and
guys cutting their dicks off and it's
like a huge psychosexual thing where
you're just like always [__] thinking
about it. We're watching something
totally unrelated right now.
Okay. So, stop thinking about [__]
guys [__] and and you know getting
[__] on your dick or whatever the [__]
gay people be doing
and just talk about the [__] topic.
I'm begging. Thank you for the $3.
Hugely appreciated. Eating people and
such.
But that is a great time to remind you
guys. I was going to do a chill in a
moment, guys. 354 people have 41 likes
on stream. Some of those 300 or so
people, please move a customs up and
clicking it, pressing a thumbs up on the
mobile device. That would be huge
appreciated. If you want to take your
support one step further, you can donate
directly through a stream on this link
in the pin chat message. You can buy a
membership to the channel. Gift
membership channel, gift a whole bunch
of members without the chat. Buy a super
chat or highlight your message reality
and buy a super sticker. Wish a YouTube
inventory gift. They'll be hard in chat.
They'll describe it to you. You can go
to discord.gg/g GG/greamman
Twitter.com/greamman.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Okay.
>> Fact that they're cultivating like
snarkers or people.
>> Yeah. I was saying um
Destiny Standard is about the
communities. It's not about the bad
empanada video. It's not about the bad
empanada video at all. He's about to say
it's about the bad empanada video. It's
not cuz he applies the same [__] to me
and Jay Stok and everyone else. It is
absolutely the standard that he is
coming up with is this idea of like oh
there are snark you're around snarkers
that's his standard
>> um do a certain thing right or have a
certain malicious attitude is that right
>> um I would say the probably the larger
aspect here is the fact that that Denims
was watching a video that was basically
calling for or getting as close to
calling for this thing as possible. Chat
was vibing with the video. Denims was
vibing with the video and then people in
chat started to do the next logical
thing of talking about CPS or CBS calls.
>> So these things are Are you saying that
there's a that there's a lack of
connection there from A to B to C to D?
No, I mean I don't think there's a lack
of connection in the same way I don't
think there's a lack of connection
between the Republicans when they argue
about what I what you already know what
I'm going to say that there's you know
there is a clear connection between the
people in terms of the same kind of
connection you know calling people
fascists saying that they're going to
destroy the country saying and we make
this argument for Trump all the time all
the time when we're talking about
>> hold on calling people fascist how does
that how does that relate to anything
we're talking about here
>> so let me give you an example right so
you just said it's not hard to see a
>> No No, no, no. Use the example that you
just gave. Call me how calling people
I'm telling you. You asked how is this
analogous, didn't you?
>> Okay. Sure.
>> So, so when I say when I'm building out
what you kind of said, I'm trying to say
this is the basics of what Stephen said
and how does it apply to the thing I'm
about to bring up? And so when you say
no, no, no, no, no, no. It's kind of
seems like you think I'm dodging it, but
I'm just directly answering it. And so I
think it would be a lot easier if you
just let me go through it. So you said
basically um they don't have to
explicitly say it. You said you had a
5-hour talk with Rob Nor and you had a
six-hour talk with Hutch. I don't think
you're in any position to say any
conversation led by you is made easy.
But go ahead.
>> Well, I mean, I don't know.
>> He is Pisco is making it easy. Okay.
Pisco is making it easy. It's just Pisco
is someone who will cut through and will
focus on the disagreement.
And people don't like that. People hate
when you do that. But most people just
want to bloate and talk around the issue
and try to sound smart, try to sound
like they've got a take on on the issue
because they're a content creator and
they just want to produce a piece of
content where they get to talk about
that their ideas
and they hate when you want to focus on
the issue.
>> The chat this convo being reviewed is
still ongoing.
>> Yeah, I'm I'm aware. Thank you for the
499 gravity general. Thank you.
>> What that shows you have long
conversations with people all the time.
How does that show that like a
particular thing like
you covered basically no ground? I'm
just saying it's funny for you to imply
that I'm the one that is slowing down
the conversation. You yap a ton and it
takes you forever to get to the point.
I'm not saying I'm not saying that I'm
always I'm always like the most [__]
for I'm just like let me [__] get to
it. So you went and said something like
>> I didn't say that you were always sure.
You just
>> Jesus Christ. Oh my god. He literally
can't stop spazzing out.
>> That's what I said. But that's okay. Go
ahead.
>> Okay. So you said when you lay it out A
to B to C to D, you don't have to
explicitly say it for someone to get the
picture, right? That's kind of what you
were saying just then that the mere fact
that you know Denims is laughing along
to it seemingly very receptive to the
argument being made by Bad Empanada that
you know we don't have to be able to
show that she like explicitly said go do
this to have that kind of argument A to
B to C to D. Right?
was your framework kind of I'm trying to
talk about the
>> fact I understand you're play you're
going to play games around the explicit
word but yeah go ahead
>> wait do you think I just want to appeal
to if you're going to keep accusing me
of bad faith kafa do you think anything
I'm doing right now is improper or you
think I'm being playing weasel games I'm
trying to address what Stephen said I'm
listening yeah
>> no but like it's it's tiresome when
you're accusing me of bad faith in the
middle of these
>> you're not at the bad faith part yet
maybe you won't be maybe I was wrong
prove me wrong I want to be wrong go
ahead so when the Republicans come up
and say to you Stephen
>> you live in plausible deniability
You call all of our people fascists. You
say that they are scum of the earth. You
say that they are
>> removed from scum.
>> Y
>> and that uh you refuse in front of us to
condemn violence. And so even you might
make some self- serving statements here
and there, but you do A to B to C to D.
And so why shouldn't we hold you to the
bad things that happen afterwards? Talk
to me about the danalogy there.
>> Because one, I don't watch videos of
people talking about how to kill
conservatives. Number one. Number two, I
have no reason to believe that any
killer or murderous person,
>> that's the distinction. You don't watch
videos about how to kill conservative.
Dude, what is he [__] talking about?
That's a distinction.
Dude, Denims didn't watch videos about
how to call CPS.
Denim just watched a video about Ethan
Klein and stuff Ethan Klein had
disclosed and done on his podcast and in
his videos
>> ever come from my community. Number
three, calling somebody or scum of the
earth or whatever. One of the things
that I say all the time everybody listen
>> it's not it's not gooning his rotted his
brain. It's nothing like that. It's not
even ad rollers Friday. He is just a
miserable self-erving [__] loser.
Pathetic wretch these days. There is no,
you know, there used to be a point where
he was when he had everything, when
things were easy, he had the luxury of
like being able to like engage with
different arguments and ideas that might
lead him to change his position or look
stupid if he got it wrong.
Now he is in such a corner and feels
like such a [__] cornered rat
that everything is just survival. It is
all just like what do I have to say to
make myself sound cool and [__] [__]
this person over. It's all just it's
that every conversation it's totally
unbearable to listen to. There's nothing
interesting about it anymore. It is just
like cow [__]
Know you have the right to think that
about other people and you don't have
the right to kill them for it. Okay,
freedom of speech. You can have
absolutely abhorent views in this
country. Okay. And number four, you can
say that I refuse to condemn violence in
particular circumstances. There are
hundreds or thousands of clips out there
of me saying literally right after the
Charlie Girk thing, there is a [__]
30 secondond clip of me saying the guy
that shot him should hang for it. You
should never kill people in this
country. I have an unambiguous position
on political violence. You might think
differently because of a clip or two
that you've seen, but obvious
parts of my community. But I'm just
saying that but the funny thing is that
if you change any one of these things
around
>> Wait,
but Pisco, you know that's a lie. No,
this is [__] Pisco knows that's a
lie. Destiny does not have an
unambiguous position on political
violence. Simply remember the Trump
assassination attempt when Pisco and
Destiny debated. Then that debate ends
with Pisco basically saying,
"Do you think someone should Trump
basically I can't remember the exact
question or the exact phrasing and
Destiny's like I'm not answering that.
I'm not answering that to that's how it
ends."
and imply that one people wouldn't be
far more critical of me or two that I
wouldn't change my own behavior. If I
had a chat and we were joking constantly
about like, man, I if I was going to
kill like a conservative, I wonder what
weapon we would use. I bet you could do
it with a singleshot rifle. I bet you
could do it from the roof. If I were to
talk [__] like that in my chat and then
Charlie Kirk is assassinated, what do
you think my response would be? To
giggle and laugh about it or do you
think that what about the killing
>> to laugh to make jokes about the people
being killed?
>> Yeah.
>> Would that be a response? I don't know.
Would it be?
>> No. If I if if I had a chat room and we
were talking about the optimal way to
assassinate or murder a conservative and
they get killed in that exact manner,
>> is that what they were doing in damn
chat? They were talking about the
optimal way to call CPS.
>> Hang on. If you're joking specifically
about it and then afterwards you make
another joke about it.
>> We're not like not not necessarily
joking, but like saying like, "Yeah, I
think if you wanted to kill a
conservative, this would be the best
rifle to use. These would be the best
conditions, the best place." And then a
week later, a conservative gets murdered
using that like more or less pretty much
what we're talking about in chat. So
when the plans are jokes or not jokes,
the first set of plans that you're
talking about, the first set of
>> I don't know if it would matter if
everybody in chat was kind of like, you
know, yeah, you could. I think you
could. And was like looking up [__]
like, oh, you know, from this day, you
know, this range, I think, you know,
>> I I I feel like um we there are a lot of
like edgy jokes that are being made that
are made about even killing
conservatives that I'm that DG engages
in. And I think that they're all taken
in in u in that sense and I don't think
that people think that they're serious.
But basically what I'm suggesting
there's two things. Well, you didn't
even answer my question. But no, because
you said that question I didn't finish.
I just want to address.
>> Do you not think that I would like
severely change my behavior or make a
statement or would there be me?
>> You would condemn it. Right. Right. You
would No. I I I
NO, NO, NO, NO, NO. You would condemn
it. No, I would change my behavior.
>> You would stop calling Kirk a fascist?
>> No.
>> What would you do? What would you do?
Sorry. I'm trying to understand good at
triggering the fact you're not stupid,
bro. Did I just tell you? Did I just
tell you? Imagine if we were calling
Charlie Kirk a fascist and then he got
killed. Was that the example that I gave
you?
>> If you're saying that he should be
killed or if you're saying that the
conservative should be killed, you would
stop doing that, right? Is that what
you're saying?
>> If I and chat were talking about the
optimal ways to murder conservatives and
then some conservative were to get
killed a week later using more or less
what we talked about, I wouldn't just
come out and say, "I condemn the
shooting." Cuz if I were to come out and
say that you should you should roast the
[__] we condemn the [__] You guys
literally [__] plotting it in chat.
No, it would be a severe course
correction in my community.
>> They would be like, "Holy [__] like
somebody just got killed exact [__]
thing."
>> You you would stop doing what?
>> You would definitely not make any more
of those jokes. That's crazy. I don't
know if that killer came from my
community or if I'm contributing to that
like that. It would matter whether or
not they came to your comm came from
your community that you would is isn't
the risk isn't the whole argument here.
I would like to say
>> I would like to finish. So regardless of
whether they came from your community
Hutch's whole thing is it doesn't matter
if we know whose community it comes
from. That's Hutch's argument.
>> Hutch was incorrect. No, Hutch first
Hutch doesn't even believe that if he
said it he was misspeaking because you
were mind [__] him
right.
>> Hutch actually has no responsibility for
his own actions or words. If he gets
anything wrong or makes a bad argument,
it's because Pisco made him do it, it's
because Pisco made him make a bad bad
argument.
>> Doesn't matter. So So I want to be I
want to be clear. Doesn't matter. It
doesn't matter. So So it wouldn't matter
in your case either. So are you going to
call on your uh people to stop making
jokes about assassination?
>> Hello.
>> Is I'm going to ask I think for the
third time was the example that I gave
was making jokes about a thing.
Yeah. So I that's what I'm
understanding. Maybe if I'm not hearing
well, maybe I have a a block in my head.
>> Okay. Let's say in chat we're discussing
between three different rifles that we
think could kill somebody in a single
shot. The appropriate
>> This is what
training would be required before we
could take the shot and kill.
>> This is analogous. This is analogous.
>> That's neat. Real quick,
>> you remember those chat logs where D's
chat is like, "Hey guys, here's a number
for California CPS. Guys, make sure when
you call you talk about how there's [__]
all over the floor. Guys, remember you
need to make sure you you make sure make
sure to stress that it's a current
imminent risk to the life and safety of
the children. Make sure you're saying
that's what the chat message said,
right? Oh, wait. No, they they didn't
say anything like that, did they? This
is [__] [__]
We just ask a quick question. I'm going
to try to cut through. Sorry, everybody
interrupted. Destiny, are you saying
like just to use a term that might be
helpful, there's a like an element or a
feeling of conspiracy that exists in the
chat, right? When they're discussing
about a crime as if it's a real
>> No, I don't want to use Pisco doesn't
believe in conspiracy crimes or any of
that. So, there are no crimes like that
for the Pos world. So,
I definitely believe in literally the
most [__] dishonest, spur out,
obvious [__] misrepresentation of
position. Obviously, if you are involved
in the conspiracy, you are culpable for
the conspiracy, right? Obviously, if you
are
commissioning an act, yes, you are
culpable. Yes. Cuz you have shown
intentionality, a causal role.
Like, it's
Yes. Now, in Denim's, you can't show any
of that in Denim's case, can you? You
can't show that. That's why there's not
the culpability for the action, you
[__] idiot.
Go for being negligent with the chat.
Conspiracy all that.
>> Wait, I definitely believe in
conspiracy.
>> No, no, no, no. We're we're not talking
about any of that.
>> You don't think I believe in conspiracy?
>> I'm saying that if somebody in chat if
if all of us were collectively engaged
in this discussion on the optimal way to
assassinate somebody and everybody seems
to be talking along. You can call if you
want to call it a joke, that's fine. But
everybody's talking and then somebody
ends up dying a week later because of
the same type of killing. So, so it's a
situation in which they're talking in an
ambiguously serious sense. It's not so
serious that anyone can say that it's
like genuine plans, right? And because
you didn't want to accept what Kafka was
saying there about conspiracy, but it's
not so obviously joking that it couldn't
be fairly characterizable as a joke. Is
that right? It's ambiguous.
>> Sure.
>> Okay. And so what you're suggesting is
um those kinds of comments, not fully
jokes, but not fully um explicit
planning, serious planning. Wouldn't you
change your behavior in the community
going forward?
>> Mad weirdo is such a loser. He believes
in conspiracies and all these grand
minations in streaming, but not in
politics or government.
>> Yeah. You just don't understand, you
know, and in there's just not the
incentives in politics, you know. Online
it's different.
>> That's a question. Yeah. I think that
you would change the behavior going
forward. I I think the problem there is
the disanalogy is with what you're
talking about with with the
>> the analogy. Yeah. So, so the disanalogy
is um in the in the context in which um
Denims was watching that clip, it was
it's not talking about government
action. It's not her agreeing to do
anything and and kind of like the
preparatory Wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. Can I finish what I'm saying
before you like spaz out?
>> Yeah, sorry. Go ahead.
>> Like, you agree she's not like agreeing
to contemplated government action,
right?
>> She's not agreeing about the best way to
to do the infringement on Ethan, right?
She's not talking about the best way to
plan a bad or malicious act against
Ethan. You agree with everything I just
laid out so far?
>> Not not really.
>> Which which part of what I just said did
you not agree with about characterizing
DM?
>> It's the thing. It is the thing that is
logically entailed by or would follow
I'm sorry. Careful. Not logically
follow. It is the thing that would
consequentially follow from the behavior
they're describing. If I were to make a
plan to get a bullet right in front of
somebody's head as quickly as possible
from 100 yards away, that would be a
plan to kill somebody. Even if that's
not the actual last thing that I'm
planning. Yeah. Right. To say that Hodge
asked this question. I'm curious. Do you
still stand by this? If you genuinely
believe that somebody's kids are being
sick are sick because of severe neglect
from the parents such that they're
crawling around in dog [__] Do you not
think that that is an adequate grounds
by which to notify CPS?
>> So I don't think you understood what I
was saying there. I think that
>> Can you answer that question? I I will.
>> Would that be adequate grounds to call
CPS? I think it would be adequate
grounds for a person who believes that
negligence is is materially harming a
child and they're uh that that's
happening that they would be that they I
think I'm justifying that that that
would be justified. What I was saying
there which I think that you did not
understand is that is not itself a
justification by which I mean you know
someone could get from that reasonably
or unreasonably a particular
justification and they could argue that
it's justified but it's not itself a
justification. So the analogy that I
want to do to demonstrate the difference
between Is it not something I Okay, so a
justifi a justification I understand
that to be and may maybe this is just my
failure to communicate is saying
something like this you should do this
because xyz this in other words it's
someone making an argument to a
particular conclusion or prescription
it's someone adopting a certain reasons
right in virtue of what is this okay in
virtue of this justification
>> so you should call CPS if you think that
somebody are being neglected they're
getting sick
>> what I mean to say the the what you
didn't understand there is I was making
a distinction between reasons that
someone might have that apprehension
versus they themselves doing it right
and so the example I provide is you
agree wouldn't you that a lot of people
maybe even millions of people right upon
hearing the fact and I believe that you
think these are all facts that Trump is
a fascist that he's trying to destroy
this country that he is uh materially
hurting and the cause of misery and
death across the entire world and that
he could absolutely be the cause for the
the destruction of our society as we
know that do you think that that is a
justification to enact violence against
Trump?
>> No.
>> No. Right. Even though you those are all
true things and even though there are
millions of people who could come to
that conclusion,
>> the difference is the difference is that
you don't know what I'm going to say.
>> Well, well, you just agreed that it
wouldn't that you're you're
acknowledging the difference between
reasons. Yeah. Yeah. Because the
different well the difference is is
because when I before I said this is the
thing that is consequently entailed by
the reason is is because there are a
plethora of ways to address uh a
difference even a severe difference in
political opinion. There are very very
very few ways to address severe child
neglect.
>> Yes.
>> If you want to make this analogous then
you have to say you need to give me what
are the other things that people could
have done with that information.
>> Yeah. So I'm not saying that an
individual themselves um is would not be
justified in under my view not to call
CPS there. I just want to be very clear
about that in in the in in the scenario
as presented where there is but it's not
just them getting sick and roll
that's like so dishonest
here. It's not just about a difference
in political opinion in the Trump case.
You are building up such that there is
no alternative. You're saying he's
stealing your country. You can't trust
the institutions anymore. or it's all
been subverted. The Supreme Court's been
taken over.
It's not just a difference of opinion at
that point. You're saying your country
and rights are being taken from you and
there is nothing you can do
democratically. That's the point, right?
Neglect part of that that it's important
because B you're a father, right? You
understand that things happen that are
like that's what's so horrible about the
the the notion that CPS is justified in
this context, which I've always said
it's not justified, is because
>> the thing that was watching and talking
about was explicitly no because you're
trying to make something that's not. It
was explicitly about neglect.
>> So I I agree.
>> If you can't follow Piska's arguments at
this point, I think you're just
self-porting like a mental disability.
Like
>> this is this is not complicated.
>> That
>> Wait, do you agree? Hold on. Let's let's
do very basics. Do you agree that the
video was about neglect? Dallas was
watching a video about neglect
>> among other things, but which neglect is
a central part of it? Yes. It's not only
about neglect. You'd agree that. Do you
have a problem with me qualifying that?
Uh, I don't know where the qualification
wait. I just want I just want to be
clear and and I just want to make sure
that um we have total agreement by CFKA
as well. When I just qualified there,
there's nothing wrong with me saying
that there's other purposes of the
video, right? There's nothing wrong with
that.
>> No, there's not.
>> Okay. It's not weasly for me to say
that. Okay, cool.
>> So, so the so it's about neglect, right?
So if you are telling your audience and
you're watching something especially
well maybe even well not even especially
actually this would be an element of the
wrong it's a necessary part of it if you
if it was built on a lie okay so you
have a thing built on according to Ethan
at least a lie that somebody is
neglecting
and it's such a
>> but it's not built on a lie it wasn't
built on a lie where was the lie dude
they showed videos and yes the videos
people took away like
extrapolations that couldn't actually be
justified with full information. Like if
you had full full information, you
understood Jardia, you understood what
was going on with Ethan, you like, I
don't know, a bit more about Ethan's
personal life. Yeah, maybe you wouldn't
come away with that impression, but it
was not built on a lie. Ethan claimed he
had Jardia. Ethan claimed his whole
family had Jardia. Ethan claimed you're
going to get from eating [__] It wasn't
built on lies. It was built on Ethan's
statements. fair point that the children
are now becoming sick multiple times.
>> Yeah.
>> And Denim's just applying she she has
this epistemic justification to make all
of these things even worse. Oh, diseases
that adults and children get are really
bad for children. Oh, this must be why
they're sick all the time or whatever,
right? How are you not what is to a
reasonable person listening? What
options do we have before us that would
be moral to pursue?
>> Yeah. So, I I'm not saying that it
>> Can you answer that question and then
you can be up
>> that
>> What options do they have to pursue?
Yeah. So the the the general audience,
>> sure. What options are there? There's do
nothing or
>> they could do nothing, which is the case
for a lot of you agree that there's a a
great deal of moral wrongs that people
are that are shown in videos. And the
vast vast vast vast vast majority um you
know, they're not directly saying that
call for audience action, right?
>> So for example, no. No, no, you don't
need this. Yes, of course. Obviously
agree with this. Yeah, but that's not my
question. My question is is what could a
person do? They could do nothing or
>> yeah they they could do nothing. That
would be the vast majority of cases.
They could, you know, bring it to
Ethan's attention if they care to do
that. Uh they could leave it to, you
know, people who are closer to the
family. Uh if you actually um if you I
think are deluded enough to think that
this is deserving of a CPS call, which I
do think it is diluted.
>> Why would that be delusional?
>> It I think it's delusional on Ethan's
own video. Do you not think it's
delusional on E on what they were doing
on on what you heard from Ethan? What
Ethan said? what you heard from. We're
not talking really about what we heard
or bad empanada really. We're talking
about what we heard from. Yeah. So, you
don't think that somebody could listen
to bad's video and think, "Man, I think
involved here."
>> I think that people could possibly think
that. Yeah, they could definitely think
that.
>> Okay. You you understand that? Do you
think Denims understood that?
>> So, I think that Denims could understand
that other people could think that. Yes.
>> Okay. And was Denims doing anything to
counteract that thought or was she
furthering that thought?
>> Yeah. So, I think that she was in some
ways adopting a lot of what by laughing
and by being koi about it. Do you
disagree with that characterization?
She didn't explicitly endorse it, right?
>> Stronger. Well, the fact that she
started to talk about the
>> It's like they literally they have to
load it as much as possible. Just she
was being koi about it. She was being
koi. That is a perfect description of
Denim's attitude in that in that
segment. She was playing koi. She was
like, "Oh my god, I can't I can't
believe Ethan's like this. He's so
gross." It was like It wasn't saying
anything explicit. It was just going,
I'm dying. Isn't Isn't this guy so
[__] crazy? Isn't this guy so [__]
gross? Doesn't guy live like [__]
Doesn't this guy live in such a [__]
you know, [__] filled house?
In like a jokey way. In like a
with a smug look on her face. It's Koi
has happened that are the same between
adults and children. It's really bad for
the children. Doesn't seem like she was
being koi or joking. It seems like she
was like
>> she No, she was adopting that, right?
She was adopting it.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Okay. Yeah. So, but she but she didn't
go out and say but she was adopting the
characterization of the harm, right? Not
adopting the the response that you're
proposing here, right?
>> Correct. But my argument the response so
I'm going to do an analogy here which is
the vaccine analogy.
>> Why can't we just talk about the thing?
Because I want to remove our intuitions
about Denims and her malfeasants here
and I want to take a a different case to
see if our our reasoning holds up. Do
you have a problem with that?
>> You don't have a problem with that?
Yeah. No. So, suppose that you have a
crazy antivax family and they go on
YouTube and they say, you know, I love
my baby daughter. I love my son. We
didn't give them any vaccine. We didn't
give them this, this, and that. And I
know that there's a raging case of
measles going on here in Arkansas,
whatever. Um, but I know that with the
grace of God, they're going to be okay.
And I'm actually send them to school and
I don't care about anything. Uh, but but
I know they're going to be safe. I know
it. and uh a liberal streamer, let's say
yourself, uh watches that and you
directly say this is so irresponsible.
They are placing the life of their
children at risk. These kids could quite
easily die and there is no reason to do
it based on a delusion. These parents
are completely neglectful. They're so
irresponsible. What are they doing? And
then later on some people call CPS and
uh commentators come to you and they
say, "What the [__] Stephen? You did
this." Are you culpable for that CPS
call in the moral sense?
>> Not only would Not only would I be
culpable, I would probably brag about
it. If that was a person's actual
position that they felt like not
vaccinating their kids was child abuse
and they were saying things like that to
the audience and then CPS was called, do
you think the person would be like, "Oh
my god, I can't believe you guys called
CPS." No. The person would probably say,
"Good, they deserve to [__] lose
their kids." What are you talking about?
>> You don't You don't take You don't take
the view that CPS is justified to call
on everyone who is part of an antivax
family.
>> No, because you don't have a legal
obligation to vaccinate your children.
And lack of vaccinating your children
doesn't imply negligence in this case.
>> Cuz you don't have a legal obligation.
Is this okay?
Yes. If you're talking about should you
call CPS, yes, you should not call CPS
for things that they do not have
jurisdiction over. But that's not really
the point that's being made here, is it?
That's not really the point that's being
made here, is it?
That it's more a moral point that's
being that's really we're arguing about
is that is a total copout. That is a
total copout.
>> It's in the United States of America
getting sick because we're crawling
around.
>> We're not talking about legal. Wait,
we're not talking about the legal
standard here.
>> Yes. Thank you, Peace Guy. Oh my extent.
>> I think has into it. The legal standard
has baked into it a whole lot of ethical
assumptions and implications. Yes. If
for instance we there are some laws that
that if somebody is following the law to
some extent, we would probably assume
like, okay, well, this person's probably
trying to to especially we're talking
about CPS, which is a [__] government
body. They're not there to enforce
ethics or they don't enforce the law,
right? If you were to send a kid to
school every single day in in in filthy
[__] clothes or naked,
>> the argument Yes. But you're the
argument you're having right now isn't
like, "Oh, well, what can you call CPS
on? What is legally permissible to call
CPS on?" The argument you're having is
like is there a harm to the children
happening? You know what should you take
an extreme remedy to or take an extreme
intervention such as calling CPS to
prevent this kind of harm? Is that
logically entailed by the arguments
being made by the content creator in
this hypothetical? That's that's what's
being argued right now. It's not being
argued like
the the the jurisdiction of CPS over
different different family matters.
That's not what's being argued. Whatever
else, right? Well, I don't know if it's
not ethical or not, but like maybe it's
against you say, "Well, there's probably
something wrong here. There's probably
something not good here." The disease
that Dennis is talking about
specifically was a disease of
negligence, right? And not vaccinating
your children does not necessarily mean
you're being negligent. You might have a
disability
in the sense that we're talking about
>> I do I do but I don't. But Steve Pierce
isn't here to
>> Doesn't he find this embarrassing that
his opinions and takes are totally
malleable to his personal grievances?
It's depressing me. you're probably not
embarrassed uh by much when there's
a sort of stuff about destiny online
that there is
>> to address that type of I don't know if
I'd call it a moral failing or a
disagreement on epidemiology or whatever
that's not what the CPS tool is not used
for that but if I were telling my
audience this is neglect this is
basically child neglect I think they
should lose their kids I don't think
like if I was driving that narrative
that [__] hard and and somebody did
call CPS like what do you think my
response be like oh he I can't believe
you guys did that no I I I'm not here to
speak to what you're probably about it.
>> I'm not here to speak.
>> Is Queman culpable for Willie Mack
reporting Destiny's CP to the cops?
Well, I'm pretty sure I'm responsible
for like every bad thing that ever
happens to Destiny's life at this point
based on the way he talks. So,
>> what your your response would be, but I
just think that like even though I
>> because why? Because I answer the
analogy and you didn't like the fact
that my response would follow that and
it makes your heart. Why would you say
you're not here to say your response
would be after asking me what my
response would be?
>> No, no, no. with with respect to if you
were um you know shown back uh what what
happened to that that child and or you
know what happened in that situation.
Um, but what I'm what I'm trying to talk
about is specifically the situation in
which there's a you know a vax this
antivax family. You're saying that you
would you would feel culpable for the
call that took place that you don't know
about that you didn't uh adopt that you
didn't want to happen and someone did it
right someone did do the CPS call now
you would recognize
>> if I would feel some level of cul of
course if my audience is doing things
powered by things that I'm saying even
if I'm not aware of
change my behavior
>> and and even if you don't want it
>> even if you explicitly don't want it
>> I make that
no you didn't say wait a second you
didn't SAY IT NOBODY OPERATES IN THE
REAL real world that way. You don't have
to say a thing directly.
>> I understand. No, I I understand. But in
the moment, you you it is your belief
and intent that you don't want someone
to call CPS in the hypothetical I'm
presenting, which I assume is mapped on
to what you just said, and you didn't
say it at the time. So, there's no
there's no expression of any kind of
government interaction. You you just
talked about the health risks there. And
then someone does it. It's something
that you didn't want to happen. And then
afterwards, you say, "Hey, this is not
okay." Do you feel that in that moment
in in the situation which you didn't
want CPS to be called in this vaccine
case, but someone took your genuine
correct true statements different than
this situation where I think it's it's
not true, but your genuine correct true
statements about the VA case and called
CPS that you would be culpable for it
because you just pointed out the health
ris right
>> because the No, no, no, no, It's not
right because the thing I told you
earlier that you're missing the the
reason why this is disanalgus is because
a lack of vaccination doesn't
necessarily imply neglect.
>> We might have epidemiological
differences.
>> I know we disagree. Wait, I know we
disagree on that. I know we disagree on
that. But someone hears you say that.
They don't have the kind of view that
you do. Someone from your audience hears
you say that. They don't put two and two
together that the the vaccine position
doesn't raise a cognizable claim for the
CPS or whatever.
>> There's going to be there's going to be
there's hold on. There's going to be
some level of of knowing or some level
of intentionality or some level where
we're going to say, "Well, could a
person have known that?" If I'm talking
to my channel, I'm like, "I saw this
dude outside yesterday who looked just
like [__] Agent Smith. I swear to
God." And then somebody walks out and
starts murdering people's like, "Fuck, I
think I do live in the Matrix." Am I
culpable for that? Probably not. I don't
think that there are many people that
think that antivaxing is a legitimate
reason to call child protective
services. If we were to pull the entire
US, my guess is that number would come
up at less than 10%. But for the amount
of people, if you were to pull them, if
children are getting sick because
they're crawling around in dog [__] all
day, do you think that CPS should be
notified? That number would probably be
over 50 60 70%. Do you acknowledge the
difference between those two things?
>> I I acknowledge that you probably find a
a bigger percentage of people who would
say that CPS should be called in one
scenario versus another. I totally
acknowledge.
>> When we say bigger, we're talking like
one or two orders of magnitude bigger.
>> I I I don't know what the basis is for
you to say that. I mean, I don't know. I
I'm telling you have no nothing in your
Wait you think that like it might be
like five to seven% difference or it
might be like
difference I just told you I don't know
you said two orders of magnitude I
understand order of magnitude to be like
100 times a thousand times more that's
what I understand it not to be like 25
more
>> like five like half a percent of people
like okay well they're not vac
you think if you and I just want to make
sure kafka you understand this so you
think that if you pulled America um when
we're talking hear about an order of
magnitude that there would be uh you
know something approaching you know 10
times more people in America
um the the poop situation that we're
talking about that's child neglect and
it would be an order of magnitude less
who would say not vaccinating your kids
>> to 80% or 7 to 70% or 6 to 60% yes I
think it would be about that significant
not more
>> I don't have that intuition I I think
that if you ask like every Democrat or I
don't know like 80% of Democrats they'd
probably say that it's neglect to not
give your your kids vaccinations I do
agree, like I said before, that I think
it would be more.
>> Are we talking about neglect?
>> I thought that's what you were just
talking about. Neglect, right?
>> We're talking about neglect rising to
the level of having to notify CPS. Not
neglect as in like you've been
neglectful. You're using this in a very
casual sense. Now, the thing that I said
earlier,
>> you're accusing me of deceit this whole
time. I'm totally hang on a second. You
tried to whether or not the order of
water. No. Okay. There's no war games.
>> Wait. If somebody if somebody if
somebody sees that children are crawling
around in [__] versus somebody else says
that family doesn't get their co shots
>> do you think that there would be a
significant we'll just say significant a
significantly larger percentage of
people they would think okay
>> I just I don't have the intuition for
the orders of magnitude I'm just okay
and it would be a fair assumption that
most people would probably know that
right that like if I tell somebody that
these kids are crawling around in [__]
all day
>> I think that would be most people's
intuitions
>> yeah okay so if Denims is watching that
we know that that's going to be most
people's intuition itions that
>> we look at the chat typing stuff about
CBS and then we see a response to the
call. Why would we know?
>> So let me ask so so let me ask you a
question. If people's impressions are
that um a baby is eating poop um from
you know a a dog animal or something and
they contracted a disease on those facts
alone like if you were to ask Americans
hey um you're given the situation in
which someone reports or is it tells you
that um that they know that a baby
contracted a disease at a household for
eating poop um and that gardia or
whatever they got giardia. How many
Americans do you think are going to say
CBS is justified on those facts? It's
probably going to be some amount even
though we all agree it's not justified
on those facts. You understand?
>> Yeah, but we're not talking about like a
one time this happened one time and
somebody got sick now.
>> Yeah. No,
>> we're talking about somebody saying if
you want we could even we could we could
we could flip it. Let's say that a kid
shows up one time at school and his
clothes are a little bit dirty and then
somebody calls CPS and the police show
up and you know they find out this kid
is being severely neglected or whatever
else. You know, people would probably
look at the person called CS like
whatever. I guess you got lucky. I mean,
yeah, you know, good catch or whatever.
You know, that would be it. Let's say
that a kid shows up and he's been sick,
you know, all year long and you find
out, you know, the kid is like, oh,
well, the dogs poop everywhere in the
house and we get sick all the time.
Let's say that you call CPS. Then what
would people's response be? They'd say,
"Yeah, you should have. Good job. Nice."
They give you credit for it. THEY SAY,
"GOOD JOB. YOU SHOULD HAVE CALLED CPS.
YOU DID THE RIGHT THING. GOOD.
CONGRATULATIONS." YES.
>> I I understand. Right. Right. So, I
understand that that that people would
see a difference between those two
scenarios. What I'm trying to tell you
is the mere the fact that someone would
think that what Ethan was doing is
neglectful doesn't per se make them
unreasonable. And I want you to
acknowledge that even though they're
wrong, you both you and I both agree
they're dead wrong. But the fact that
someone thinks that it's neglectful,
that that opinion doesn't mean that
they're in bad faith, right? They're
just they're just not thinking clearly,
right? Doesn't mean that they're bad
faith. You agree or no?
>> Well, I I don't know if I would call it
neglect. I think we would be at like the
level of gross negligence or
recklessness if you're a content creator
putting videos out on the internet for
people to consume. No,
>> that's not the point. He's literally
like not even following, dude. He's not
even following. He said
he's saying it's not a
necessarily it does not having the
belief that Ethan is neglectful does not
necessarily entail that the person who
holds that opinion is bad faith. That's
what he's saying. Then he's like, "Oh, I
think Denim is being neglectful." What
the [__] are you talking about, man?
That's not a response to the point being
made. How about you stop [__] looking
at porn or whatever you're doing right
now on your other monitor. Focus on the
conversation.
I'm sorry. Maybe I'm not. What I'm
saying is if someone takes the view that
what Ethan did was neglect, that that
isn't per se a bad faith opinion, right?
Someone could interpret the statements
given.
>> I don't necessarily disagree with that.
I don't I would almost fight you on the
points when you guys were talking to
when you were talking to Hutch, you guys
were saying the CPS caller was the one
who had more culpability. I don't even
know if that's true necessarily. If you
listen to the things that these [__]
crazy people say constantly and you're
like Jesus [__] and you're a mom or dad
or whatever you're like [__] man I'm
gonna make a call to CPS
necessarily being in the wrong compared
to like Denims or
>> I want to explain what I was saying
right I basically was saying that I it's
plausible to me that Denim's uh violated
her ethical obligation to refrain from
um you know failure to moderate and to
refrain from
>> when you say plausible you mean that it
is logically possible that she the
prerequisite condition such No, that
there's a good that that there's a good
chance there's a good but by by
plausible here I mean I I mean to say
it's a it's a case that I think
Merritt's looking at and on balance I
think is reasonable that she didn't push
back enough on um what bad empanada was
doing. I conceded that during the
discussion but I missed it. Um that
>> why why are we phrasing it say she
didn't push back enough?
>> Why the problem with phrasing Wait,
what's the problem with phrasing it that
way? It sound like because if if a
person murders somebody and the other
person was holding them down the entire
time, you wouldn't say, "Well, the guy
holding them down wasn't pushing back
enough on his friend murdering the guy,
she was assisting here with the claims
of negligence. She wasn't just like
mutually
I'm trying to distinguish." Okay, you
are so paranoid. The only distinction
I'm trying to make here, wait, wait, let
me
>> No, no, no. The reason why I fight on
this characterization is because when
you start with the thing, if she didn't
push back enough, it sounds like we're
starting at zero and we're arguing to
how much should she have pushed back.
But I'm not starting it. She should she
just did nothing. I'm starting it. She
was culpable in
>> FOR EVEN WATCHING FOR EVEN WATCHING IT.
RIGHT. That's what you're trying to say
for watching. No, that's not what I'm
trying to say. For even SHE WASN'T JUST
WATCHING IT. She was watching it and
agreeing with it and supporting it and
laughing along with it. Her whole chat
was going along with it.
>> So, first of all, I'm I I I think that
we should calm down for a second. All
right. And just let's chill. Right. So
what I'm saying there is trying to
distinguish maybe I should include also
the kind of adoption or the implicit
adoption that we're talking about here
where she's nodding along and being like
oh that's crazy chat. Yeah it's very
dangerous. Okay so but all I was trying
to distinguish what I said
>> is like dude it feels like so many
debates with Destiny right now are just
people talking to him like a [__]
child.
It's just like hey can you like talk to
me like we're both adults?
You like every time I talk you like
start screaming. You start like
screaming and crying every time I talk
and it makes it difficult to progress.
You know, it's like every conversation
now. It's so [__] Said failure to
push back is a situation in which one is
merely watching it um and then
critiquing it. Right? That's all I'm
trying to do. And when I say you're
paranoid, what I'm saying is you think
that what I'm doing here is some kind of
coverted attempt to help denims. That's
that's really what you thought I just
did there, right?
You thought that, right? Okay. So all
I'm trying to do, I'm telling you in
real time, I'm trying to distinguish a
situation in which somebody is just
watching what they're uh like a bad and
not a video for the purpose of breaking
it down and for the purpose of
criticizing it and someone who is not
doing that. Someone who is not pushing
back.
>> You would want to do that. Notice now in
order to make that work, you're using
someone. You're using someone. You're
using general nouns or pronouns,
whatever, right? Someone denims, denims,
denims, denims, denims, denim,
>> talking about denims. Then we wouldn't,
if you want to talk in more
generalities, we can talk in more
generalities.
>> You know what it feels like to me? It it
feels like when the lefties are like you
didn't say it's genocide hard enough.
You you like they're reading into like
the the fact you know my language here
where I'm trying to be precise as
possible. I'm trying to address
everything you're saying. They're saying
because
>> but you're not the reason why I'm acting
like this is because people when I look
at people like Hutch and Josiah talk to
you. These are like the most almost
naive levels of good faith and you get
into the most like debate perverted
mindset possible where you're crucifying
these [__] on the most
technical. It absolutely is. these the
ends of these conversations are [__]
crazy and these people's minds are
getting [__] destroyed as you're
trying to run circles in the most
perverted manner possible such that
you're making statements as crazy as
Hutch is asking like if somebody thinks
that uh like your children you know are
being threatened or they're going to die
or whatever is that a good reason to
call CPS you're like well no not
necessarily
Jesus Christ like it's insane
>> when you when you say like that yeah we
we definitely can when you say it like
that it it sounds like what you're not
understanding or you don't believe me
when I said this difference between you
someone no one is understanding besides
>> okay so do you understand a difference
between stating facts from which one
could justify an action and stating a
justification for an action you
understand those are different things
there
>> and I was referring to one versus the
other
>> in a very yeah but you shouldn't be a
strict
>> but do you believe me do you believe me
when I said that I was referring to
justification as opposed to the set of
facts that from which one could
reasonably justify do you believe me
right now that I'm autistic enough to to
make that distinction. You really don't
believe that. So, so what was I doing
there?
>> Because here's this is the test that I
use. Okay. When you play fast and loose
with language when it benefits you and
then when you become quote unquote ah
I'm autistic when it benefits you then
no I feel like at that point the
selective skepticism makes it hard to
believe that you're applying this in
fast and loose with language is like he
said Hutch expects me to have watched
all of Denim's streams. No, actually
Hers expect you to watch all of Denim
streams. Hers expects you to watch a
substantial amount of denim streams
enough to gain a general understanding
of how she reacts to content on any
given day.
That's that's like the example. That's
the example we're giving.
>> Everyone who everyone who talks to me
understands I do this. You talk I I
talked to Rob Noir for like four hours
about how the term jurisdiction and
territorial jurisdiction that a ruling
on territorial jurisdiction and venue
isn't necessarily a ruling on
jurisdiction. For you to sit here and
say that I am not not only capable of
doing that but specifically known for
this kind of [__] is so laughable.
>> Look at the example that you just used.
The example that you're using is a
legally defined term debate with Rob No,
who's also one of the most debate
perverted people possible. Why would you
use that compar? Wait, you wait, you can
say not just that, but that's the
example that you went to. WHY WOULD YOU
GO TO THAT EXAMPLE? YOU'RE DEMONSTRATING
EXACTLY WHAT I'M SAYING. NO, I everyone
knows that I have a character for being
particular about my words, trying to
clarify in like the most specific way
possible and that sometimes, you know, I
I'll be, you know, clear about the men's
raw versus
take you like three hours to get to
understand that what Hutch was talking
about was degrees of culpability. When
he said it like four times, you trying
to make it a binary thing of like you're
either culpable or you're not culpable.
>> So, I I I don't I don't think that
you're understanding. I obviously agree
in things such as separate is it working
with I don't think you're understanding
>> I I really don't wait I'm about to I'm
about to specify what you're saying I'M
ABOUT TO SPECIFY YOU UNDERSTAND
you understand what you're saying out
the time do do you think that I truly
don't understand a notion of partial
responsibility that I don't understand
joint and several liability that these
concepts are foreign to me is that what
you think
>> no that I don't I don't which is why at
the beginning of this conversation I
said you must have bitten this argument
from somebody else cuz when you I wanted
to determ you started talking about
proximate cause or or or but for things
and you're like well you know you can
see that you know at the end of the
chain that once the chain of causality
is broken what a [__] thing to ever
say about anything in the legal world
you don't say that
>> wait a second so I mean you can I'm just
going to take an example uh someone who
h I'm not going to use that example
>> let's just do the den let's just do the
den
I just want to be I just want to be
clear I understand partial
responsibility I totally do in fact I
was the one who introduced the notion uh
when I said do you believe that Denims
has significant responsibility for the
call for for the milit
and be done with it?
>> Thank you for the don huge appreciated
and no
as much as that is funny to do. Um it's
actually good that peace goes unpicking
all this. Let me uh I'm just I'm just
going to reset my goal. Sorry,
I'm distracted.
Huge appreciate. Thank you for the don.
Okay, but still a quick chill as well
and set up a chat goal. Guys, 420 people
here right now, 68 likes on stream, some
of the 360 or so people. And please move
the cursor to the thumbs up and clicking
it or pressing the thumbs up on the
mobile device. That' be appreciated.
If you want to take your support one
step further, you can donate directly
through a stream elements link in the
pin chat message. You can also buy a
membership to the channel, gift
membership the channel, gift a whole
bunch of memberships randomly throughout
the chat. Buy a super chat which I
highlight your message and read on TTS
or buy a super sticker which a YouTube
image or gift that we in chat and I'll
describe it to you. You can go to
disco.gg/quman twitter.com/quman or
red.com/quman.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you. I'm
posting a super chat goal in the chat.
Huge. I introduced you what about 5%.
So, it's clear even in just taking that
conversation without this pretend story
about me stealing um some kind of
information or whatever. It's clear that
I understand the notion of partial
responsibility. No one can watch that
video in which we're talking about
percentages in which I'm trying to hold
Hutch to, you know, some level of
significance. He says, "What do you mean
by significant here? I mean 5%." And um
that that someone could come away
recently thinking, "I don't understand."
>> I think so. I think so. I think I think
anybody that would watch that would go
why is it taking this piece of guy so
long to just talk about gradients of
culpability here cuz that's what I was
screaming for like 2 hours like how are
they talking about this for SO LONG TO
NOT go into scales of culpability here
it's insane to me
>> but you but you agree I in that
conversation demonstrate that I
recognize that concept I'm using it fair
>> once you've been pushed into having to
address it directly which makes you feel
bad
>> f so so this is what I'm trying maybe I
can clarify this maybe this will be
helpful so because I see culpability as
inextricably tied to a given mental
state. I don't really um conceptualize
moral fault with relates with uh
relating to particular results without a
mental state. You understand?
>> Why is it okay? Hold on. I agree with
you 100%. But then why is it earlier
that you were talking about the
percentage chance of somebody doing
something bad in the chat as being the
the the defining characteristic on
whether or not you did a bad rather than
what you just announced, something I
totally agree with. It does depend on
the mental state, which is why the
reaction That event itself is what's so
important because it helps you it gives
you insight into the mental state of the
person that was spreading the [__]
in the first place.
>> I will explain Stephen. I will explain.
So because the reason I kept asking and
and maybe you thought this was bad faith
too. I asked Hutch well it's possible it
came from your community right and he
was like yes and everyone gets
exasperated like oh come on Pisco you're
trying to say it's the exact same thing
when Hutch watches a video and and
>> very intelligent engagement that Pisco
is portraying there by the way. That's
like what how really intelligent people
engage with debates is they when when
someone says to ask a question such as
isn't there a chance that the really
intelligent yo you're really say you're
really saying you're really
that's how really intelligent people
engage
Also thank you for the $2 satious with
the hey you super sticker of the pear
character with with sunglasses turning
around and waving thank totally
missing the point and maybe listen guys
that could absolutely be my own
communication deficiencies. I am totally
willing to accept that. But the
difference is we ascribe culpability
when it comes to non-intentional states.
Uh I'm here using the model penal code
and I understand that's a legal concept
but I believe it will also imply to our
ethical concepts and I don't think
you'll fight me on it. This notion of
recklessness and negligence, right? Um
you don't call someone negligent just
because they introduce an a trivial
risk, right? You don't introduce, you
don't call someone culpable for being
negligent or reckless because they are
like, you know, sending um their kid
over to do grocery shopping, right?
Because we consider that a low amount of
risk. And so you just asked me why wait,
let me finish my idea.
>> No, you don't agree with Hold on. No,
because you don't agree with what you
just said.
>> Okay. Yeah, I do.
>> It has nothing to do with the percentage
chance of risk. It has to do with the
intentionality and the responsibility
that you have in terms of sending
somebody into a into a certain
direction.
>> Wait, wait, wait. It's not relevant
here.
>> It does. Yeah, it is. It is. I'll tell
you why. And I do believe this and and I
and I hope that we can agree on that.
>> Sure. Give me an example. Sure.
>> So, someone is reckless when they
consciously disregard not any risk,
right? A substantial and unjustifiable
risk, right? You don't call someone
reckless, correct? So the state of mind
is intrinsically linked to a certain
quantum of degree of risk. Okay. So no
one would say for example
>> no it's no no one. No it's absolutely
not. It's not. What did you say? The key
word there is is
>> thank you Jim for the 199 super sticker
says yum. Thank you Jim. Thank you.
>> is known or justifiable. You have to
have a mind state about the rate. If a
if a father tells a child, can you go to
the store and pick up some thing and
there are murderers in the store that
are killing everybody and the dad
doesn't know and there's a 100% chance
that the child dies he walks in there.
That's not neg that's not well maybe
negental.
That would be like intentional, right?
>> Not if they didn't know though. Not if
they didn't know.
>> Oh yeah.
>> 100% chance of death if they didn't
know. The known part is what it talks
about negligence or the responsibilities
and the obligations you have
>> right but the knowledge pertains to a
certain level of risk right the
knowledge itself the mental state of the
apprehension is based on a certain
significance of the risk I'll give you
an example right so so that we can just
agree on this um if someone sends them
to uh uh the supermarket not knowing
that there are murderers all over there
like the one you just gave they are not
consciously disregarding a substantial
and unjust justifiable risk. You would
agree with that, right? Correct. So,
you're not and however um if they know
that
>> on this just on this just on what we
just said there, this is why the chat
groaned because funnily enough, I
actually think Hudg's for whatever
[__] Hutch's intuitions I think were
spot on in all of this. And I think a
lot of the groaning you were get was was
>> dude like you hear that he literally
pretended that Pitco was going insane
the whole debate, right? But you hear it
there. Listen to it again.
This is why the chat groaned because
funnily enough I actually think Hutch's
for whatever [__] Hutch's intuitions
I think Hutches for whatever [__]
Hutch's int intuitions were basically
totally right or whatever he says
he's admitting there he is admitting
there Hutch did terribly
Hutch did terribly so the whole time you
watch his reaction which you know I
watch maybe 30 minutes of the whole time
you see his reaction, he's sitting there
pretending that Pisco is going totally
insane. Pis just like, "What if Psy is
go to Oh, just totally." No, he knows
the argument sucked. He just agrees with
the conclusion. He just hates denims.
Think we're spot on in all of this. And
I think a lot of the groaning you were
get was was intuiting a lot of good
stuff as well. What you just said is the
knowledge of the risk. When you say,
"Well, when Denims is engaged in some
behavior watching a video," and then
somebody calls CPS, and it feels like
the intent of her, the entire community,
the video she's watching is to push that
type of behavior, and then you say to
Hutch, "Well, isn't there a chance that
somebody from your community could
engage in that behavior?" Do you really
think that when Hutch is reviewing a
thing critically, do you think that if
you would, thank you for 20 Canadian,
someone somewhere, huge appreciate.
Thanks so much. for all the sleep you
losing keeping up with this not for rent
cause that's free in day 17 kn's head
>> hugely appreciated thanks so much put a
gun to his head and say hut I want you
to answer this right the [__] now do you
think that you're helping or hurting
this situation my guess is is probably I
think I'm helping I'm trying to
spotlight a thing that I think is
important and you know there might be a
crazy person that the wrong way but for
the most part I'm doing things to reduce
the amount of harm here
>> I just want to be clear that would
definitely be true of the reckless
mindset but there's also this other
level and again this is a legal concept
but I think it also fits in our
intuitions is negligence. And negligence
isn't just when you consciously
disregard a substantially unjust
justifiable risk. Negligence is when you
should when you should wait. Let me just
finish. Where you Yeah, I agree. Hutch
is not negligent. Okay. I don't think
that close to it
parallel is crazy. That's why people are
groaning.
>> No, because you guys don't understand. I
don't raise that point to suggest that
Hutch is negligent. The point I'm
raising when I say uh Hutch is mere
increase of risk is not enough to imply
a culpable mindset. The risk you need to
show is sign.
>> What is this guy's problem, man? What is
this guy's [__] problem?
We're going to break down the simple
concept to Destiny Pisco who of course
not give a set of bad character. He
doesn't have all the facts to do so. I
literally told Queman to say this, dude,
>> of of some degree of significance and um
we're going to treat you differently
based on whether you consciously
disregard that risk.
>> Question that you're smarter. You know
that nobody knows nobody believes this.
I would never this would be a thing that
>> Yo, thank you for the five gifted out
boss.
>> Yo, thank you so much. Thank you. Huge
appreciate our boss. Thank you for the
five gifted. that you would just
illustrate a quick example with the one
that I just said. Let's say you said
your kid to the store there's murders
and you didn't know about it.
>> No, you didn't. You danced around two
hours.
I brought I brought that example up.
>> Wait a second. I brought that example up
into it. You got pushed to it.
>> Listen. So So I'm just I'm just tell you
guys can disbelieve me if you want. You
can take Steven's view that I'm doing
this because I'm trying to appeal to the
Jilk community to improve the harassment
on Rose. That's Stephen's opinion. Or
you can take my view of it which is I
was trying to find new ways to explain
the same concept. The same concept which
is that our intuitions about culpability
don't relate to the result nakedly. Our
intuitions about responsibility relate
to results plus mental states. And so
when I said and and everyone goofed on
me and we I have a bunch of replies
saying like what? You don't think that
the [__] father that's being sent
over there would be responsible for the
death of their child? When they did
that, right? They're just not
understanding the point. The point isn't
that the father is not responsible or
culpable. Here I'm using, by the way,
when I say responsible, it's not weasel.
I just use those words interchangeably.
Responsibility, morally at fault,
justified, or or sorry, uh uh culpable.
Those are all words that I use
interchangeably. It's not evidence of me
doing a lower standard for people. I'm
just trying to reexlain the same
concept.
>> Sure, that's fine. Most people
intuitively at that point though would
feel like the father is somewhat at
fault because they would view that as
being at least negligent of not
protecting your child from going to a
bad part of time where they're going to
get killed.
>> My my my point is and you don't even
disagree with this. They're
>> you agree that most people would view
the father as being somewhat
>> culpable in some sense. Culpable in some
sense and yes no but that I was saying
that that's what's so frustrating is
because people
>> No. Yeah. But but you might say that
well you could argue you were saying
that you were but you're what you're
saying is well he's guilty of this thing
of negligence but that's completely
divorced from the resulting bad action.
He didn't murder his daughter. He didn't
rape the daughter. Yes, you did say
that. Okay. But the second thing too is
imagine the father not only sent his
daughter to a bad part of town. Imagine
he got into a group chat and started
telling a bunch of his shady friends.
>> Yeah. Now it starts to seem more
intentional. Right. Now it starts to
seem more intentional. Yes.
>> I agree. imagine if his daughter getting
raped and he laughs about it in his
group chat with all his friends voice is
almost as good as your mama JF voice
>> retouch okay thank you for the 333 thank
you huge appreciate the mama JF
then why isn't the one impression that I
can just do like absolutely perfectly
it's [__] man
>> seem more intentional doesn't it
>> so what is disalgus here between what
denims did and what the dad would do in
that circumstance
>> what I was trying to So first of all
let's make sure that we agree wait no no
Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. I I I want
to I am going to appeal. So, I know
exactly what you asked. You asked, "What
is this analogist between the added
circumstances to the hypothetical that
make them different than the denim?"
Everyone locked that in. We know that,
right? We know that. What I want to do
though is make sure that we agree so far
in the framework. You might not believe
I had this framework and I want to get
clarity on that, but I just want to make
sure we agree with the framework. So,
you agree, right, that one is not
culpable in the sense of moral
culpability to a result nakedly, right?
They're not nakedly. Just because you
cause the death of your child, you're
not culpable.
>> It depends on it depends on the
mentality. It would depend on the
foreseeability
and foreseeability plays into a role of
like what a culpable mental state would
look like. If something is very
foreseeable and you don't cognize it,
but you should, right? That would be a
negligent mindset, all that other stuff.
And so, um, one is not culpable for the
intentional version of culpability that
I'm trying to say and versus the
negligent one. So, that's all I'm
playing out here. And I don't hear you
to disagree with that. And that is what
I intended to say whether it came across
the right way. What I wasn't trying to
do was say that communities don't have
responsibility for their uh community.
What I wasn't trying to say is that
there's no duty to moderate. Was I what
I wasn't trying to do was [__]
protect just for [__] Rose
harassment. We're not talking thing,
right? The thing that's your that's your
speculation. That's your open
speculation.
>> I believe Yeah. That's Yeah, of course.
Of course.
>> SO, SO YOU BELIEVE I want to increase
harassment on this person I don't know
who has never harmed me
>> on basis cover on the communities why
the [__] in virtue of what in my CHAT I
TALKED TO counterpoints he's in your
community
>> but you don't give me that grace on that
do you don't give me the grace that oh
>> counterpoints will still talk to you
counterpoints won't cut people out of
his life or cut people out of his
communities like
>> is that what this is about people who
>> No that's not what this is about this is
about the I'm still waiting for you to
give the example in denims I don't know
why you're going into No, no, no, no.
The the point is the reason I'm
addressing this at all is because you
openly speculated that the reason why
this was, you know, it's maybe a little
bit of words to to put out that the
reason was because of a nefarious intent
to increase harassment or protect a
community who is known to be harassing a
young woman who's never harmed me.
>> And that is that is [__] up, man. You
can't you can't [__]
>> What's wrong with me when you say it's
[__] up? If somebody were to reach out
and harassed you as a result of that,
would I be in some sense culpable for
that harassment?
>> Well, in the sense of recklessness, but
I wouldn't. But, but if I TRIED WAIT,
HANG ON, HANG ON, HANG ON, WAIT. WAIT,
WAIT, WAIT. NO, NO. I did not. WAIT. I
DID NOT. WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
DESTINY, my sense of recklessness.
Unless you're saying, Destiny, you
intend for that to happen.
Or or is that what you're saying? Is
that what you're saying? Or are you
saying you're more culpable than
reckless because you intend for that to
happen? Is that is that what you're
saying, Destiny? That almost sounds like
what you're saying there.
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait. Destiny, Destiny. So, as a result
of that, I might say that you're like
negligent or reckless or whatever if you
say that. But hang on a second. There
have been people from your community
that have messaged me with uh, you know,
suggestions that are not true in in a
similar vein. Do you accept culpability
for that? No, you don't. Right.
>> That people might message you that
people say mean things. Sure. Yeah. I
say anything about your screen. Yeah, I
of course I accept.
>> But you didn't do it. No, no, but not
the unhinged stuff, right? You take you
take credit for what you actually say,
not what you increase the risk of
>> saying. You have to define unhinged. If
somebody messages you like, I [__]
hate you, piece of [__] then fine.
Yeah, I guess if somebody messages you
like, I'm going to kill you. Well, geez,
that's kind of [__] up. I don't think
just stuff like um you know, attacking
my credibility in the sense of like my
credentials, uh saying that essentially
I'm I'm defrauding people um not you
know, holding myself to be on uh to have
never been admitted to practice. Those
are things that come from people who are
parts of your community. Now, I've seen
you uh defend
>> WTF. The streamer looks like an abusive
footy player from Liverpool now instead
of what his hair did to his appearance
weeks ago.
>> Thank you for the download. Huge
appreciate. Thank you.
>> Me on that score and I would never hold
you culpable for it. And I'm applying a
consistent lens
>> because there's a because there's a
clear
because I but but but why do I even do
that? because I do see people make those
kinds of attacks and when I see it
because I don't want people to make
those types of attacks and then there's
other stupid arguments make they can
attack you. I counteract it and that
that shows the intent of me when I make
my criticism of you. I'm not here to
criticize you for saying you're a fake
lawyer whatever else and you can see
what you just pointed to an oh look I
guess he doesn't want these but but
here's here's the thing. So, so Denims
did did clarify afterwards, right? Now,
that was after the after she said what
she said in uh and or she watched that
video and people brought it to her
attention and criticized her for it. She
said that she never called CPS and that
it wasn't justified. That's what I
understood that she said. That's from
what I recall that she said. And so, I'm
asking on what terms are those different
>> after Wait, was this after she she know
she saw that CBS was called or was this
after a significant public backlash?
>> It was in the first time she addressed
it. I'm not sure if I mean those are
coinciding, right? Like maybe the
backlash is when she sees it. Maybe the
backlash is when she matters. No, no,
no, no. I've said I'm not sure about
Tell me how you can determine that she's
being sincere.
>> Well, how? Hang on a second. But then
what else?
>> You can't 100% determine obviously you
can't 100% know someone's state of mind,
but you're making a reasonable inference
based on how she handled it before and
now she hand it afterwards and going,
"Okay, well, I think that given the way
she's handled it, she probably didn't
intend for CPS to be called.
She's doomed to be insincere because if
it happens to be that she sees it when
it coincides when it's a public thing.
Therefore, she can never be sincere
about the apology or you will never take
>> your statement about statements made of
mediation or settlements. Didn't you say
Casey Tron's whole statement must be
insincere because it came at the end of
settlement or
>> No, that's no. The reason why Casey
Tron's statement is INSINCERE IS BECAUSE
IT'S OBVIOUSLY INSINCERE. It's obviously
insincere given everything we know about
Casey Tron's character given what she
was apologizing for. Do you actually
dispute that? Do you think that she was
being genuine there that she apologizes
to uh you know Ethan's employees she
apologizes to Asold?
>> We can't if we if we're going to say
that necessarily every statement made at
the end of mediation is insincere then
there's no possibility you can say that
well denim
>> not necessarily but certainly in this
case
>> the end of massive public backlash
that's sincere.
>> No that's ridiculous. What I mean to say
is like it's in the nature of what Casey
Trron is saying um that it it strains
creduli given our priors about the
>> obviously it's just it's not about like
all litigation or any mediation
resulting in a statement being
insincere. It's obviously the case here
that this was not sincere. Casey Tron
does not believe those things about
copyright. Casey Tron does not believe
those things about Asmold. Casey Tron
does not give a [__] that she did
anything to Ethan Klein. Casey Trron
doesn't give a [__] didn't help her. She
was back in son's chair. So the whole
thing is just total [__] Obviously
she's like you can just look at it. See,
does she believe these things? Do they
go up with her actions? No. Obviously
insincere. It was at the um end of
coercion. So that why would we for a
moment entertain the idea that this was
a sincere statement
where it doesn't line up with any her
actions and does line up with coercion.
It just doesn't. It makes no sense
>> given our priors about um you know what
someone could reasonably expect an
apology for that she actually meant um
aspects of her apology there that's what
I think is I think you agree with that
>> and what is in the nature of denims and
the snarker communities and all the
people surrounding her where is the
evidence of her advocating that similar
type situations
>> what do you mean evidence of her
advocating for similar types of
situations
>> where's the course of conduct of denims
that would uh you know justify us taking
this kind of negative inference on on
her apology that that we would think or
sorry not apology her stating that that
was never intended that she doesn't
think it's justified. What
>> show me the piece of paper where Hitler
wrote that we need to kill all the Jews.
>> No, I didn't say that. You're you're
making it sound ridiculous when you're
like I'm I'm
>> being
the kind of things that shows that she
has a history of this stuff where she
actually wants uh these kinds of reports
to be filed. She actually wants you to
go out and uh
>> watching the videos on stream. She's
laughing along with it. She's giggling
after CPS gets called and her chatters
are all having a [__] goof about it.
>> No, but but that's that's merging with
the thing itself. That's merging with
the conduct itself. You're saying the
conduct is so obvious that she's calling
for CPS there or that um that she should
know that that's a call for CPS that you
that that is itself the evidence also
that she's being insincere regarding um
her statement that
>> did you see the did you see any of the
Discord chat leaks um of the Tyler
Robinson's Discord group? I saw some of
them.
>> From what I saw, I would be it I would
be shocked if that group was a radical
crazy group because it seemed like when
he dropped the message in there, people
were like, "Wait, really? Holy [__] Oh
my god, this is terrible." Or whatever.
That was all I saw. I don't know if
there was more released, but from that
Discord group, that's all I saw. If I
would have seen him say that same
message, if you would have seen him drop
that same message and everybody's like,
"OH MY GOD, BRO. HEAD SHOT. GOOD JOB.
[__] A++, DUDE. I'm dropping on
Tomato Town next." Right. You would What
would you think? Would you think that
there much higher chance that
>> Yeah, we'd apply more culpability. Where
did they celebrate the CPS?
>> Is that okay? Hold on. You asked me that
question. If I if we watch some clips
and I demonstrate that, is your opinion
how what percentage is your opinion
going to shift on this subject
>> that if they celebrate CPS actively
after the fact,
>> that will definitely that will
definitely color my opinion. And um your
so like give you an example of what it
would be and then I'll tell you how I
think it would affect my opinion. That's
me being good faith, right? Agreed. I'm
giving you advance what my reaction will
be before I see it. Right.
>> Yeah.
>> Okay. So what so so give me the example
thing and I'll tell you how I think
it'll affect my opinion.
>> Okay, I'll be back in five minutes.
Yeah.
>> Cool.
>> Oh my god.
>> Okay. Well, we're skipping ahead.
>> People who are harassing
would
very good reason other people. It's
fine,
right? Please don't
>> I have overwhelmingly and to my
credibility's detriment defended you and
>> oh wait do I want to say does Kfka
mention me or something
>> take a stance you're saying I should
actually take a role there
>> anymore I don't think you have ill will
towards destiny you want to take a
distance from all that stuff that's fine
>> to members who are definitely
>> Rose you think that
>> you that you're doing all this to
protect uh
>> if I would have seen him say that same
message if you would have seen him drop
that same message and everybody's like
oh MY GOD COME ON, BRO. HEAD SHOT. GOOD
JOB. [__] A++, DUDE. Drop a tomato
down next. Right. What do you think?
Would you think higher chance?
>> Yeah, we play more. Where did they
celebrate the CPS?
>> Okay, hold on. You asked me that
question. If I if we watch some clips
and I demonstrate that is your opinion.
What percent is your opinion going to
show on this if they celebrate CPS
actively after the fact that will
definitely that will definitely call my
opinion and let's like give an example
of what it would be and then I'll tell
you how I think my face, right? Agreed.
I'm giving you an example yet, right?
Cool. Is that what you think? That's
what we suggested.
>> I haven't seen evidence of that, but
it's also seen. Why aren't you convinced
by that? I wonder
>> I I mean again I think again this comes
back to more of a fact issue. I'm not
really super familiar with all this.
That's why I was going to come here and
discuss with you about it.
>> Yeah, we've been talking about for like
an hour plus
>> sure but I mean like I think it's I
think it's a thing where there's a
whether you intend to or not I think
that there can definitely be cover for
that community.
>> Wait what do you mean I'm covering for
them on with respect to harassment of
Rose? You think that I would I'm the
kind of person that you know that would
want to do that to cover these people
who are harassing a young woman? Why
would I have
>> I don't I'm not saying it possess that
intent. I'm saying that there's I think
that the juice community definitely has
the ability to um I think they're a lot
of what you do. They're trying to find
you as an ally. They're I mean currently
fighting with people in your discord
right now. They very much have an
interest in bringing you to their side
to some degree whether you know I think
that the relationship with this point
makes it easy for them to try a lot of
your stuff.
>> Yeah. But I can just be myself and like
like I'm also I interact with
counterpoints. I'm on good terms with
not so aerodite. I'm on good terms with
you. I talk to members who are script
community and so in what sense um is it
that I've fallen into the black hole and
of
>> you're also on good tering?
>> I don't say that she's snarking but you
maintain relationship with people that
are not that that has issues with.
That's
also relationship with people that he is
good friends with.
>> Sure.
>> Say that's what it's about. You're
you're friends with people Destiny
doesn't like. You're friends with Desi
doesn't like, dude. Literally, they live
their whole lives just wishing they
could [__] women with another guy's
dick. That's like the whole content
appeal to them. It's like friends with
people through someone else,
relationships with women through someone
else. That's like their whole life. It's
their whole life.
community's issues with Destiny surround
this lawsuit that arguably probably
wouldn't be at where it's at without
straight rav involvement. I mean, she is
that she
>> holy crap. I mean, but I mean that's
true of anyone who's like potentially
involved the fact pattern there and I
don't want to get into actually talking
about the merit for reasons I've already
stated and and that is out of respect
for the process and out of respect
frankly for for what I was doing at the
time um in the sense of uh we're doing
New York and like so there's a bunch of
reason why I don't talk about that
you got baited on X into fighting no
because what they say but it's not just
it's just very funny that um when people
accuse me of being hypocritical in terms
of my coverage I mean it's not a
hypocrisy there's a reason why I'm not
covering something and the reason
relates to something that is convincing
it's convincing right it makes sense why
you wouldn't cover something right you
agree that
>> I'm not I'm not giving you thing you
want to stand away you want to pick up
you want to take a distance from all
that stuff that's fine But there are
parts of your community and and your
engagement online that are bleeding into
it that are trying that people try to
pull you to it. I'm saying that he
should Chinese wall everything.
>> Should I bust from my community?
>> I think that there are a lot of very
reasons to do that is that he has the
intent. Yes. He has the intent to try to
use you your content and your community
to his ends and not only I think harming
destiny which anymore. I don't think you
have the will of destiny. I don't
believe that about you and I think that
you you are whether you should your
inactivity. Yeah. I think you should
inactivity and that brings up a lot for
people and whenever and and I don't know
about this whole I shouldn't ban I
shouldn't I shouldn't ban counterpoints
or I should ban counterpoints
>> I don't I don't see counterpoints acting
in a way that's trying to harm other
people online right that's my thing I
think you're saying you're saying I
should take a stance you're saying I
should take a stance in these issues
that I said that I want to take a stand
on you're saying I should actually take
a role there and I should go in there
and um actually make the decision in
that sense and wait into those issues
and make those banning rational even
though like we don't want to talk about
that [__] we don't want that drama stuff
it's something else and it's open to
people who follow our rules why would I
go look at their off server conduct and
ban them or you think I should you think
I should because because why
>> WP because WP your intent to try to
culture language and use it to harm
Destiny. I think it's I think it's fine
for you.
The other the other day the other week I
did a reaction of uh Soy and Destiny's
conversations with these two
conservative lawyers in which I almost
uniformly praised their performance and
said they did a wonderful job the other
time like when they people were going
after Steven for um trying to vote for
last election.
>> Dude, are you are you serious about that
[__] So So you think are you
scared that I'm going to because I state
my genuine view on stuff, right? I state
my genuine views on these lawsuits
because some community that's bad could
take it a certain way. I'm sure that
like all the people who are fans of
denims and Assangeans, they love that
I'm I'm talking about this case in the
way that I am. But that's incidental to
why I'm doing it, right? It's not
related to why I'M DOING THAT. WHY I'M
doing it is because it's my opinion,
right? Why I'm doing it is because of
all the reasons that I want to talk
about it. Not because I want to [__]
um please Denims, please. People seem to
think that I do, right? Is that your
impression? I have a tanky. I want this
is just for me.
>> It's literally just Destiny can run his
community however he wants. And if
you've ever been associated with Destiny
in any way, you have to run it the exact
same way. That's the rules. That's the
rules. That's it.
They don't they literally don't see the
orbiters and you know there's good
reason for this in some ways. They don't
see the orbiters as their own content
creators. They don't in any way. They're
just other extensions of Destiny.
They're just like Destiny's friends. And
then in that way they're their friends.
So they have to make sure that their
friends are staying in line. Okay? Their
friends aren't leaving them. And that's
it. That's like the whole [__]
mindset. It's just like this desperate
um cultish parasocial
obsession with uh just like being a
control freak, just being a like
manipulative control freak because
that's what they've learned.
>> They have overwhelmingly and to my
credibility detriment defended you in
the DG community. And I will tell you
this though, I I I understand where
you're coming from this, but you are a
person with a legal degree. You're a
person with some level of credibility on
the internet and you're a person who
really was not a huge part of this [__]
in the past. And then now after you're
falling out with destiny, we see you
engaging in it. We see you coming
engaging. Wait, wait. Engage. Engaging
in what? Wait,
engaging in what?
>> In the discussion around this drama
stuff that you're not drama stuff. So,
so I'm not talking about drama stuff
related to Destiny.
>> You're talking about drama. No, I didn't
say Destiny drama. I don't remember you
ever prior to the January of this year
getting in the middle of online drama
stuff and things like this and having
massive culture drama.
>> All right. So, let's just go through
tables and then we'll see if you agree.
Do you remember when President Sunday
went arite?
>> I I do remember that.
>> Do you remember what I did there?
>> I do. I remember you had a really great
showing against him. It was specific to
debate with him and I said that you had
you came in there Wait, wait, wait.
Well, hang on a second. Do you guys
remember how many posts when I do Sunday
posts where people would keep, you know,
trying to debate me and trying to say I
was wrong about stuff, defending Kyla,
and I kept defending, kept defending,
and kept defending, kept defending, and
went on Sunday stream and spent seven
hours. Doesn't this sound exactly what I
tend to do when I get push back,
significant push back on issue that I
like into um that I don't just have this
like neutral approach that I never
address things related to streamers?
>> Reminder though, Pisco did totally rat
[__] me in a conversation about this on
J stream once. He did totally rat [__]
me and he lied about the specific
wording or maybe not lied but
misrepresented the specific wording of
this letter that Aerodite had talking
about this. It wasn't quite what he said
and it basically implied that you had to
have held the job to be able to claim
the title. It implied that you had to
have held the job at some point to claim
the title and as far as we were aware at
that point she hadn't actually held that
job with the title. So listen, I agree
Pisco was mostly right in his points get
Sunday, but I do remember specifically
he tried to point he tried to use this
to totally shut down the argument and be
like, "No, this is absolutely true." And
the moment we looked at the letter, it
was not true. He totally rat [__] It
was [__] annoying. But anyway, but
it's okay. We love Pisco. We love Pisco.
I mean, what you just was completely
right. This is totally in keeping with
my personality, right?
>> No. In what way is it not in with what
way is it? In what way is it not keeping
with personality?
>> I'm over it. Oh, come on. So now you're
conding me a piece of [__]
>> Wait, now you're conding me. You're
saying that I You're saying that I only
defended Kyla because she was my friend.
>> I think that I think that you would have
defended her in any case to the extent
that you did. No, I think Wait. You
think You think I would have You would
think I would have defended Kyla even if
I thought she was wrong and she
committed credential fraud. If I thought
she credential fraud, I would defended
her. If I didn't know her, I wouldn't
Sorry. It helped me out there. So I
wouldn't have waited into it unless I
didn't know her. So once I provide you
an example where again that's not true
and I talk about something which happens
to come up where like I make I make a
tweet about it that is to someone I
don't know. I'll give you an example
right now. So the Tik Tok fugitive.
Remember the Tik Tok fugitive?
>> I don't. I'm sorry.
>> Okay. So, in case you don't remember, um
there was this Tik Tok fugitive guy and
I happened to um I see I think had him
on stream or something and uh and we
talked about whatever and I went again
that's another area where it's it's not
strictly speaking things um that you
represented as a constitutional
political issue. It's more about this
guy's like interactions with uh the
legal system and whether or not the
original jurisdictions had the power to
make the determinations that his kids
whatever and now he's hiding on some one
of those islands. That was another
example. I'm just reminding you I don't
know this guy personally. I don't have a
vested interest to go after this person.
But notwithstanding that I went into
deep dive. I did a bunch of research
into the filings um about you know
related to the the jurisdictional issue
for for the family law thing that we
just spoke about. That's another example
of again a more drama related thing that
I spent a lot of time on to the point of
like you pushing to have those
conversations. I need way more though of
different views I've experiencing
in my character. None of this is
inconsistent with what my my motus
operandi is.
>> I I I mean I respectfully disagree. I
understand that your perspective is
different from outside observer watching
you do these things. I remember what you
going through the stuff. I think that
you have very strong opinion when it
comes to legal stuff. I think very good
takes. I really enjoy hearing it. I
think you are very good at defending
those and really sticking to those. I
think though in these situations when we
are looking at them I do think there's a
very interesting legal question as to
the H3 lawsuit. I do not think one
exists. So it's really hard for me to
understand where you are. I will tell
you I will tell you I will I will
absolutely tell you my initial interest
in the case. But I I do want to say it
is in keeping with my character and what
I tend to do is uh to like comment
occasionally on things that come before
me um and and then again get into these
rao and get into these arguments. In
fact, it's not just that. It's like in
my whole interactions with Steven
weren't just like you know prior to
January's here weren't just glazing
Steven almost old all the time. It was
disagreements. It was a rare occurrence
that I went on strictly to agree with
him and the more recent stuff when we
were when we were just doing things that
we agreed on but almost everyone who
knows me in my time here is I love
having these debates. I love having
these arguments. It has never been the
case that I've like uh you know done the
kind of facts you're talking about here
or that I diverge wildly on on HB law on
HB law specifically. I can tell you
exactly why I did this because I know
exactly why I did this. My I was about
to go home. It was either a wedding or
it was some other it might have been
like bachelor party, whatever. I mean, I
got the text. I was about to go home and
uh the lawsuit had just dropped and my
editor messaged me and was like, "Hey,
this might be interesting to talk
about." And I'm like, "Oh, a copyright
case." A copyright case from Ethan,
right? My last knowledge of Ethan's
copyright cases was the bold guy one.
One which I followed, one which I read
the briefing, one which I read the
opinion and I went into um on because he
let's experiment with this more like pop
cultury type legal think.
>> No, actually you're doing it to be
you're doing it to be best friends with
Hassan. You're doing it to be best
friends with Hassan. You're doing it to
be able to get invited to the Hassan
Poker Nights. It's okay. I'll see you
there. Pisco, we know. Well, you know,
>> that sound like crazy to you that that
happened so far as I've related it.
>> No, wait. So, so because it seems to be
that we're credibility motivated to to
do this because I'm Christine or
something or that I'm doing it for some
>> improv. Okay. So, we'll keep going. My
editor tells me, "Why don't you react
this? I want you. Let's try a different
what's going on." And that's what I do.
I react to it in real time. And my going
into it, I am sympathetic to Ethan
because I know that he has this track
record uh uh for the for the copyright
stuff. And in the course of doing that
reaction, I I'm like, "Wait, this
doesn't make sense." Immediately, I'm
like, "This rational doesn't make sense.
You can watch me react in real time to
it." All right. You can watch me in real
time. The video is up. It's one of my
most hated videos. like all my other
very well regarded but I came to Simon
started with you I remember
>> so so and what do you think is more
likely why I started reacting to people
reacting to the argument what I said
there is it because I I have a vendetta
against Ethan client before I said or do
you think it's because people kept
bringing it up saying you're wrong
you're wrong you're wrong you're wrong
and the fact that I'm responding to
people saying you're wrong you're wrong
you're wrong you're wrong isn't that
exactly what my personality is like
isn't that exactly what I do all the
time and I bring people in to
specifically have the conversations it's
just not credible that the reason I'm
doing this is to ingratiate myself if I
was trying to grift what I would do is
read the [__] room and and pander and
pander and pander. That's what I would
do.
>> And it causes No, no, but what's what's
the divergence? What's the divergence?
>> What here? Wait, wait, wait. Real quick.
Here.
>> Okay.
Two two guys. Okay.
>> This guy first. Okay.
>> Two brothers.
>> Let's I sent you a first thing. Just
send the first link to Pisco. Okay.
We'll just Let's just watch this one.
Okay. This is nine months ago.
>> Okay. So, um, Kafka, you're going to
message me to me.
>> Train this record. One second. Get a
exhibit
sticker on this. Um, okay.
>> Okay. I just sent it to the piece.
>> Okay. Does this happen here? Here, my
question is going to be as I'm putting
the clip up for the audience. Is this
clip before or after CPS is called?
Because the claim is that they
celebrated CPS being called. Okay.
>> Well, the title of this clip is Denim's
claims is complaining about CPS for
sympathy.
>> Okay. and thought about doing worse to
people. So after the CPS Okay, got it
there. Hopefully I'm back for
>> here to be like this is I think it's
>> important part
>> embarrassing for Ela here to be like
this is so traumatic for the kids.
You're trying to traumatize the
children. It's like dog you literally
the vast majority of people are like
vast are not remembering anything that
happened to them at three. It's just
sympathy, right? It's just she's just
pulling like the IDF classic card of
like please my life is so difficult
please everyone that is against us
[__] awful lie where literally lie
where everyone's dealing with the real
awful experiences
did worse to Palestinian kids in the IDF
I mean I'm sure she's thought about
doing terrible things to people when she
was in the IDF I can't comment on what
she
>> Okay I think that that is her
downplaying the significance of CPS call
Okay. I don't think that's her
celebrating the CPS call. Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. Can we
just Why can't we agree on that clip?
>> So, so far this holistically. Okay. No,
no, wait. Cuz we're talking I'm still
talking about the clip. Let me finish
talking about the clip. Okay.
>> These are messages from her chat while
that clip was playing.
>> Is this a fair representation of them?
Wait, no. So, so I I wanted Is this a
selection of messages over like a
10-minute period, and you're you're
picking out?
>> This is a selection of messages that I
just clipped out from the chat.
Catholica, you can send him the picture
if you want so he can read along. I just
did in the 60sec clip. Okay.
>> AAB includes CPS, but I get the point.
You're not swatting them.
>> If you even have a family YouTube
channel, you got to have CPS come and
make sure they're safe.
>> AAB includes CPS, but you're not
swatting them. That's a totally
reasonable message for a lefty. They're
saying you shouldn't use the state
against people. You should not use state
violent, state force against people.
However, this isn't like some
applications of State Force. This isn't
like a dynamic entry from a SWAT team
where their assault rifles pointed in
your face, cuz it's not. It is massively
different. There's no risk to your life
when CPS show up.
>> It's just a conversation with a social
worker. It's crazy that the Zionism
supporters don't appreciate having
random searches of their homes, being
falsely accused, being questioned, etc.
>> Okay,
>> CBS are not cops. They are not
brutalizing children. They are literally
just asking people questions. Like,
there are so many cases of What? Wait,
why is there a disagreement with this
>> with like seven adopted children just
kept in the worst conditions and CPS
doesn't give a [__]
>> I don't know why they were there. I have
no proof who called. All I know is CPS
checked on kids. So, I'm not going to
immediately jump to this is the worst
thing that's ever happened to a family
ever. Their kids were on the show. I
personally think that any house that has
a child that gets guardia should get a
quick visit. If not from CPS, then from
some health inspector. If the yard work,
>> that's not justifying the calling
though. that they're saying, "Yeah,
there should be vizards." And yeah, that
is the case. That's basically already
the law. The way the law is set up is if
you're a mandatory reporter, you have to
report to health authorities. If there's
a case of Giardia, if you see kids with
Jardia, you have to report it to health
authorities in California. So, it's
already basically like that's a totally
reasonable position to take to be
honest. These are like not these like
not crazy messages.
>> Concern. It's up to the doctor, not
people online. Yes. Wait, what's the
problem with that? Wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. What?
Are making a judgment call on this? I
don't know why they were there. I have
no proof who called. All I know is CPS
checked on kids. So, I'm not going to
immediately jump to this is the worst
thing that's ever happened to a family
ever. Their kids were on the show. I
personally think that any house that has
a child that gets giardia should get a
quick visit. If not from CPS, then from
some health inspector. If the guardia
were a concern, it's up to the doctor,
not people online. I work at a school
and when you have to call CPS doesn't
always mean that those children are
being taken away or taken out of the
home. CBS can also offer other services
and other help to assist the parents. It
has to be a case of abuse, like severe
abuse, to have the child removed from
the home. I think the real point is that
CPS got called because of what they said
on their show. Uh Ela also raided home.
So,
>> okay, this is all just true.
Dude, why are chatters like 140 IQ?
What's going on? What the [__] going
on?
>> If they have nothing to hide, it
wouldn't be a problem, right? You're
making some assumptions. Sometimes they
might be a step parent and the child
might be safer with other bio parents.
It's very situational. But maybe CPS
where you are is worse than here.
>> CPS also doesn't just take kids away.
They can order that they clean their
house, order parenting classes, and if
the situation is really bad, they'll put
the kids where they blah blah blah.
There's like 10 more.
>> Yeah.
>> When you are watching the chat, when
you're listening to her response for
this,
>> I think it's downplaying the significant
CBS call. Agreed.
And
>> yeah, I'm kind of It's downplaying it.
relatively from how comparatively
to how Ethan are portraying it. Yes,
they are downplaying it.
But there actually wasn't a whole lot
there that was particular particularly
objectionable. I'm going to be real.
Like most of those messages were saying
totally reasonable things. It should be
up to a doctor, not people online. I
think health professionals should visit
if there's an outbreak of Jardia. CPS
isn't swatting. your life's not at risk.
It's a conversation with a social
worker.
These these are all totally accurate
statements that accurately portray the
severity of CPS versus other forms of
harassment. So, yes, it is downplaying
it in the sense that they are saying it
has less significance than Ethan and Ela
are saying it has, but none of that's
wrong.
Sort of. Yeah. Giving cover for it.
>> Do you think it's fairly characterizable
as celebration? Sure.
>> I don't maybe I'm crazy, right? So I
>> when we say when we say celebrate, we
don't mean birthday party. We mean like
basically endorse.
>> Well, I I don't do Do you view this as
endorsement?
>> Or do you think that it's not as a big
of a deal? So for example, I could I
could imagine
>> I think that those two things are one
and the same and you know that. I do not
think that downplaying and saying it's
not as big of a deal is the same as
>> so so Destiny when you had that massive
argument about how stealththing is like
not that bad
>> and that it's a good that it happened.
Do you think that those are the same
thing?
>> Okay, let me clarify that it was an
acceptable outcome of events.
>> Again, I think that that's again
reintroducing the same problem. I agree
that this is downplay. I disagree with a
lot of the [__] that you just uh pointed
out. I just
>> a wife goes to a friend with two black
guys and says that her husband beats the
[__] out of her and the friend says,
"Well, you are kind of annoying
sometimes."
>> Yeah. I mean,
>> it's not really he didn't kill you. Do
you would you say that that is kind of
like
>> that is covered to or
>> that is downplaying that is that is that
is potentially saying that it's not a
big deal that it happened. It's saying
that you know it's it's more
>> it's a big deal. It's just not a big of
a deal as Ethan either portraying it. I
think that's a totally reasonable
position. They are overplaying it. they
are being manipulative.
>> Um, you know, acceptable. I I will
definitely grant that. But I'm not what
I understand the claim to be is that
they celebrated it. That is to say, they
said that this was a good thing that
happened. It's possible that this is I
mean, I agree a lot of this stuff is
really bad.
>> Wait, wait, wait, hold on. I I have to
take a step back and I got to morph my
mind because you're so you're so out of
um
>> Wait, what about that is is bad from
you.
>> Um because you're not you're just
inhuman. You might be a sociopath. Okay.
>> Okay.
>> If somebody engaged in some behavior and
wait, hold on. Where's that thinking
monk clip? Somebody [__] find this.
I think um
when Charlie Kirk got assassinated, I
watched this on stream. I was like
pretty
there were some messages in chat. They
were like kind of like, "Wow, he has a
fashion blah blah blah." Okay. Um
>> wait, we're not Okay. Compare Compare
her response to CFCO. Send peace go
this. Okay.
>> What is what is your takeaway from my
feeling about
>> people murdering Charlie Kirk or people
supporting it on my chat.
>> Okay. This is uh the statement from
Destiny. I'm going to put it up on
screen. One second.
>> Now, also keep in mind
>> actually
nobody's criticized me. This wasn't
weeks later, months later, whatever.
There's no lawsuit. Okay. I know. But
but is is like the question whether
you're a better person than Denim's?
>> No, the question is is why is my
response what it is versus what Denim's
response is?
>> It might be because um there a couple
conclusions. A that um you have
different appreciations of the of the
harm. B is because you're a better
person than denims perhaps. Clos it
could be a bunch of different reasons
that you think that uh you're holding
yourself to highest standard.
>> There's literally no [__] way, dude.
There's literally no [__] way they're
posting this picture thinking it's
actually Doobie. There's literally no
[__] way they are posting the picture
from that stupid clip. Someone send me
the stupid [__] clip. Someone send me
this stupid [__] clip. I'm I'm
begging.
Someone send me these stupid [__]
clips of Dooby pulling up this this
video feed. Who's got these? I need
these. There's like one where he does it
with Mr. Oh, one with Fuentes. Where?
Where's the clip?
Die, you're black.
Search DV214
face reveal
from Sausage Lore says Nick and Destiny
the Hispanic tag team duo. Let's go.
Wow, that's that's pretty neat.
>> This one coming in from M.
>> Huh?
>> I said, "Yeah, we're bffs." is pretty
cool.
>> This one from Minecraft player says,
"Shout out to women." And
>> who's this black guy?
>> Huh?
>> Who's this black guy that just jumped
on?
>> Oh, wait. Die, you're black.
>> Sorry, I didn't I didn't realize that
the thing gone off.
>> I didn't know you were black.
Not that there's anything wrong with
that. I love blacks. But
>> learn something new every day. D, thanks
very much for your super sticker. I
didn't see your question.
>> How do you talk? You talk like an old
man.
>> Shut up, [__]
know why that informs our uh intuitions
about whether this constitutes
celebration and if you agree that it
doesn't constitute celebration you can
just change it to be downplaying and
then we can see what entails from that.
I just don't understand why we have to
you know buy into the celebration if if
you don't think it's justified.
>> Um hold on the wait pass this one along.
>> Do you want me to put this video up? I
was about to play it.
>> No you don't have to. I am a better
person here. That's we're fine. We all
got that. Here, send this one here and
give me your take away from this and
these will be the only two we do for
now. I'm trying to find a hundred of
these, but this is two months after the
last clip.
>> So, this is two months after. So, this
is after the CPS call has been placed,
right?
>> The last one was after the CPS call,
>> right? Yeah, this one is also that,
right?
>> Thank you, Jimly, for the
>> two months after I can't even [__]
read it, man.
>> After that,
>> I don't know why are you being such like
I'm just clarifying that this for the
audience. Do you think that I'm doing
something wrong there? I'm I'm just
saying that this is after this call was
9 months ago. It's a thanks n months ago
when this was seven months ago. So it's
still after the CPS call. Yes.
>> Yeah. There's a lot of [__] idiots in
chat and I'm me just saying guys this is
after. I'm just saying that and you're
like taking offense.
>> I do agree there are a lot of idiots in
your chat right now. I do agree with
that. Go ahead.
>> Wanted to show this to you guys.
>> Hello. Is this um child protective
services? Yes. Yes. Uh thank you. I'd
like to report a a case of um endemic
dog [__] infestation in a house. This
house um as far as I know it contains
children and it also contains um two
Zionists and as we all know Zionists are
baby killers. So I think this is a very
dangerous situation for the children
given the dog [__] and the Zionist.
Oh, you'll send over a SWAT team
immediately. Seal team six. Oh man,
those are the guys who called Assam Bin
Laden. Yeah, I I really think this is
important enough. You should send those
guys over there. Keep those kids safe.
Honestly,
great service. 10 out of 10. Highly
recommended. Thanks. Anyway,
>> this guy's a evil, evil, evil, evil,
scary man. Okay. Terrible guy. I just
about his
actions,
but this video is quite funny. I'm just
laughing at the funny.
>> How dare you make jokes about CPS? How
dare you make jokes about Seal Team Six?
How dare you make jokes about Zionism?
How dare you make jokes about dog [__]
Honestly, I condemn I
>> Okay,
what is our conclusion from this woman?
>> How would you describe How would you
describe Bad Appata's behavior? What is
he doing?
>> I think that he is ridiculing and reing
in um making horrible jokes and
absolutely just he he absolutely
justifies.
>> Can we say celebrate? Sure. Could we say
celebrate is akin toing and Okay. I I
think bad empanada is Yeah, I think I
think bad empanata justifies
>> it along with it. So, how what do we
feel like Denims is doing?
>> I think she's I think she's absolutely
downplaying it and I think that she is
one waitation.
Why is she downplaying it by playing a
celebration?
>> I understand it. You tell me this is a
totally wild read. She is interpreting
this as a joke and she is basically
self-aware about the claim that people
are making that she is trying to call
CPS and she thinks that that is
ridiculous. I don't hear her um
suggesting and I think listen I don't
agree with the joke here. I think this
is [__] [__] I think it's dog
[__] Um I think that what um bad is
doing is ridiculous. I think that that
Denim's kind of downplaying it as well
uh is horrible. But
>> do you agree?
>> Wait wait wait. I just want to make sure
what I just said. That's not
unreasonable what I just said, right?
She's self-aware about this whole thing
and she's calling attention to it.
>> It could maybe that could be a
reasonable
>> No, that wasn't really a funny Denim's
moment. That was very low effort. That
was very lame.
>> Denim does have occasional funny
moments. That was not particularly
funny. You agree that she should have
like um some kind of like statemandated
caretaker. Probably should lose the
right to vote. Shouldn't be allowed to
live or exist on her own. If she's this
in at the very least should never be in
a public speaking position. if she is
this unaware of her impact on because
this is somebody who could encourage
rape, murder, whatever, if she's this
[__] [__] Can you agree with
that? If you're gonna tell me that she's
watching somebody who's clearly
celebrating, you say, you said it
yourself, very obviously reing in the
misery that's been caused and joking
about the CPS call and everything else,
and she's sitting here watching it and
giggling along in conjunction with I
showed you all those messages in her
chat just from a 60-second clip. And you
very cleverly, I know because you've
heard people make the claim that Ethan
did said that this came from a 10-minute
compilation somewhere else, but that
just came. Hang on a second. Wait, wait,
wait, wait, wait a second. Wait, wait,
wait. I'm not gonna I just want to pause
>> later. I just want to pause. Whenever
you do one of those comments, I think
that we should address it. So, you just
said the fact that I bring up the
10-minute thing and the and the and the
different window there that that was
somehow wrong to do. Why is that wrong
to do for me to bring that up?
>> I just know I know where you got the
criticism from because I saw that same
criticism come from the snarker
communities.
>> Yeah. Like in my Discord. Is that is
that something that's wrong that I
discord now? Yeah.
>> Okay. But if that's the case, why would
it be wrong that factual information uh
to the extent that it's brought to my
attention in my Discord that I click on
it and review it? What's wrong with
that?
>> When did I say there was anything wrong
with
>> it? No, I'm asking because the
implication you agree to not implying
that I said there was something wrong
with that just I told you where it came
from. Where's that implication coming
from?
>> Because you say and I know where you got
that 10 minutes and you're going to
claim that you didn't make a snive.
>> What's wrong with me factually
pretending a statement that I knew you
where you got it from?
>> No, because you understand.
>> You see how implication is so important
to you? Yeah, I do understand Pisco.
Yeah. You see what implication is so
important to you now, but it's not what
other people are doing. You see the
difference?
>> You're acting like I'm blind to it.
>> No, you're acting like everybody else is
blinded. You're acting like nobody's any
idea what's going on and only you can
see all but you're very intuitive. You
very much understand what other people
are making implications, but you pretend
they don't exist anywhere else. It's
very frustrating to deal with.
>> So chill. So you take what Denim just
did there. Is that an endorsement for
further CPS calls?
>> I would say given this given the
behavior of her chat, the communities
around her and the person she's watching
and supports. Yes. that right what we
just saw there when she's like uh making
light of CPS so you you would take that
as so not only was she previously doing
it um she is currently or to to whatever
extent this you know to date of this
thing actively encouraging and
intentionally maliciously uh more CPS
calls
>> I don't know if I would pile on so many
adjectives there to try to give you an
easier argument but I would say that
you're encouraging the beginning
>> intentionally
>> I I don't think somebody's tickling her
if that's what you're asking No, in
intentionally
>> I don't know what level of intent you
need like she can see the [__]
future.
>> No, because I don't know if you want the
reason I bring this up chance that
somebody in the audience bring this up.
IF SOMEBODY DOES A BAD, let me make a
basic statement. If somebody does a bad
and you laugh and giggle at it and say,
"Yeah, you got them." Are you
encouraging future behavior like that?
Yes or no?
>> Wait, encouraging by which you mean
intentionally?
>> I'm going to restate it and say the
exact same thing again. Somebody does a
bad and you giggle it. You giggle along.
You laugh at it. Are you encouraging
that type of behavior again? Yes or no?
You don't know what it means to
encourage behavior. I want you to say
that. I want you to say, "I don't know
what you mean when you No.
>> No. No. I don't know what you mean. I
don't know what you mean. I don't I
don't know what you mean." Okay. Then
answer to the best of your abilities.
Why can't you just define what you're
saying?
>> See, this is a problem.
>> He's refusing to define what he means
because he doesn't want Pisco to be able
to actually untangle whatever point he's
making. He's just trying to brute force
through a concession. Literally the
total opposite of what Pisco does. Pisco
will sit there and literally let you
define your terms. He'll define his
terms. And then once you're all defined,
once you've agreed on everything, it's
okay. Yes or no? Destiny is literally
just trying to fudge things and force
through some language trick. It's so
shameful. So low IQ.
>> You mean if you if what you mean by
encourage No. If what you mean by
understand the English language I'm
asking you to answer you would answer if
somebody were to ask you are you
encouraging a bad along with it when it
happens I understand I'm asking do you
encourage it yes or no is that
encouraging the behavior
>> I understand encouragement when when
someone asked me if someone is
encouraging
>> I don't know this is not responsive to
what I'm saying get a drink time to this
to figure it out you think I'm going to
break and then you come back figure out
how you answer the question
>> if what you mean by encourage is
intentionally encourage I think the
answer is no by it's not necessitated
that one who giggles along wrong to some
reprehensible statements is
intentionally encouraging the underlying
acts. No, I don't think that that's um
entailed. No, if that's your question.
>> If somebody does it bad and you laugh
and giggle along, are you encouraging
that behavior?
>> If what you mean by encourage is
intentional encouragement, if that's
what you mean,
>> I mean it in the plain understanding of
the sense of the word.
>> Yeah. But so someone could understand
encourage just mean be causally linked
to some other harm and they could just
be like is it is it
>> no nobody I challenge you submit to me
who understands encouragement means that
you have to conspire with them
>> just defy just lay out the terms what is
so hard about this it's just spazzing
out
>> the future bad act show one person or
one example where somebody believes that
>> so so I didn't say conspire right so
conspire is something
>> no but as you said you said have be
causally linked what do you mean
causally linked
>> so by by causally linked I
Kafka, do you understand what I'm
saying?
>> So I can I think you're missing gent
is still under the delusion that he
thinks Destiny is still his friend and
that's why he's so soft on him.
>> Pisco has essentially totally separated
from Destiny and that's what's causing
Destiny so much upset. Pisco isn't like
outwardly aggressive and he supports him
in political stuff all the time.
But Pisco has not spoken to him as far
as I as far as I can tell from the
public stuff was happening and basically
separated off the New York stuff and
wasn't happy with how stuff went down
because he was so bought in and ready to
you know go full speed ahead on the New
York stuff.
Um but Destiny Destiny's decisions let
him down and [__] him over. And so
Pisco I think has basically disconnected
basically done the mature disconnect. I
don't agree with what you've done. and I
think your actions are bad and I think
it would be bad to my career.
Uh so I'm I'm disconnecting. I'm leaving
this stepping away and it's just sent
Destiny insane over the last few months
because he's still because Pisces
friends with Aaron and is critical of
Destiny's perspectives. It's just clear
that he's not like you know on the team
quote unquote
>> ridiculous qualifiers to this thing.
>> I'm just making sure
>> when somebody does it bad and you laugh
and giggle along are you not encouraging
the same behavior? So if by encourage
you mean intentionally encourage go
conscious object to get them to do it
the answer is no. Right? But if what you
mean is there's a high risk and there's
a potential risk significant risk that
it happened I think the answer is yes.
You understand that? Is there anything
wrong with what I just said?
>> If there is a high risk of it happening
would it be fair to say that a third
party observer could observe and say
person A is encouraging the behavior of
person B? Is it fair for someone
watching to come to that conclusion?
>> Yes.
>> Uh just on the fact that they're
giggling along now.
>> Even though you just said that you might
even unintentionally be furthering that
behavior, it wouldn't be fair for a
third party to observe the situation and
go they would have to differentiate
between the intentional and
unintentional encouragement. You're just
asking the same thing, which is to say,
is it enough to know that someone
giggles along with someone saying
something that they're intentionally
trying to further that thing? And I'm
what I'm telling you is no. It's not
enough to know that just based on that
intentional, you're the one that really
wants to add this word in here. I don't
think intentionally it matters.
>> But wait, WHY WHY CAN'T it Why is it
Wait, wait. I just want to be clear. Why
is it wrong for me to sus out what you
mean? I'm just trying to make sure that
we understand each other and you're
somehow suggesting that's a wrong thing
for me to be like, well, I can answer
your question depending on the mental
state that you're trying to imply. You
want to keep things ambiguous and vague
and I just
>> adjectives that are that are totally
beyond the point.
>> Like it's like, oh my god, like my
husband punched me yesterday. Somebody's
like, did he punch you violently,
aggressively? Like what do you what the
[__] The quality is meaningless for one
and not the other. It could be true for
one and not the other.
>> Sure.
>> Common parenting thing. Child four years
old. uh punches another kid and the
parent laughs along. They're like, "Oh,
he hits them. Haha, but you shouldn't do
that." Haha. Even though the parent in
that case, they don't want them to hit
it. And they say, you know, "Don't hit
the other kid." They're encouraging the
behavior by laughing and giggling along
with it. That's how kids work. When you
laugh and giggle along, they do the
behavior.
>> And and what you mean there is also what
you mean,
>> that's the same way how Yeah.
>> What you mean there is that their
actions, regardless of their specific
intent, might cause it to happen again.
Right. That's what you mean. Correct.
Yeah. Yeah. But that's so there's
nothing wrong with me cashing out what
we're talking about, right? Like there's
nothing wrong and or like sweeping for
me to just say, let's just be clear
about what we're talking about.
>> No, no, no, no. We're not being clear.
You just played another game. You just
said regardless of the intent. If you
want to put the intent analysis aside,
we can do that. But you're not doing
that. You're trying to Your initial
claim was that she didn't intend to do
it. Yeah. Okay, that's fine. But you're
saying that well, maybe she didn't
intend it. No, you said she didn't
intend it. And maybe it was
encouragement regardless of that. I
think we can do the intentional
separately, but we can separate it. She
is encouraging us even if she's not
being intentional about it.
>> So, like I just want to be incredibly
calm when I say if by encourage you mean
intentionally encourage. I'm just making
it clear to what extent I agree with
your claim and to what extent I don't. I
agree that this could have the effect of
encouraging this kind of behavior. I
don't agree that this necessitates that
she wants this to occur more. You
understand that difference? That's
great. And the only reason I'm bringing
up this distinction, the only Wait,
wait, I I want you to acknowledge that
it's GOOD FAITH. NO, BUT I WANT YOU
FAITH. I'LL I'll pretend you're good
faith. I'll say you're good faith.
You're good faith. Okay. Wait, you're
saying Okay. No, no. I won't even Oh,
sorry. I will remove that cuz I just
>> You literally can't have a conversation.
He cannot have a conversation like a
[__] human being. It's so unbearable,
bro. It's literally just spazzing out,
dude. Every time all of these, Pisco is
literally so chill and you could just
walk through it with him, but they just
won't.
>> Right. I said, "Oh, pretend you're going
to Okay. No, I will take what you're
saying at face value. Okay.
>> So then my question will be okay so
let's say that we have her encouraging
it and it might be intentional might be
unintentional. Maybe she's misreading
the situation. Maybe okay she is in an
awkward state and she's laughing about a
thing to try to play off right. Maybe
okay and I'll grant you that that is
possible and I don't mean possible and
it's logically possible and no
contradiction.
Yeah it's a decent chance it's possible.
There's okay. Yeah I'll say that. Okay.
What could we look to to try to
ascertain her state of mind prior to and
after the CPS call? What would we look
to? Because in my opinion, I think I've
provided maybe not compelling evidence
in your world, but at least some
evidence that seems like she's kind of
supportive of it happening.
>> Maybe not compelling evidence in your
world, but I mean some evidence like she
smiled on a stream one time.
>> Nice man.
>> Evidence to the contrary to say that
actually she really wants she really
doesn't support that type of behavior.
Yeah. No, I think that you could if she
were a better person perhaps or if she
were um you know trying to give off that
impression, I think that she would be
condemning it in a more serious tone.
She wouldn't be this flippant. I
basically think that what you've put
here shows that she thinks it's kind of
no big deal. It's not really a big deal
that um to the extent that it's a big
deal. It's okay to joke about it. Um
it's okay to continue to put the the bad
empanada stuff even though he justifies
it. And so she basically is I think wi
with what she's doing here and not being
clear about where she stands on the CPS
call and it being bad. I think she she
is being reckless. Um I do think that
>> that's culpable. That's that's a level
of culpability. The thing is negligence.
But hang on a second. But but hang on a
second. I always understand. You
understand? I always granted this right.
We're back at the same position started
that. Let's go. Let's go.
>> She said she was not culpable for the
behavior. She said there was almost no
culpability. If she was culpable, she
was only culpable in the video
on Twitch.
>> There there's a video of me going
through this and declaring in what sense
I think that they're culpable in which
sense they think that they're not. So
when you say this is the first time that
you've ever come to the determination
that these people have acted um in some
culpable sense is just wrong. And in
fact, I said so on the very uh video
that you reviewed. And so when you're
saying that we just came to this
realization, it just is not true. There
are not only one example of me saying
this.
>> Then I'm so curious then then what was
your then I missed it then I I didn't
understand anything. What is your huge
disagreement then with Hutch? If Hutch
was saying that she has some culpability
for this call, the CPS call and you're
saying I agree there is some culpability
there. What was the big disagreement?
>> Yes. So the big disagreement is people
are trying to conflate one's uh
responsibility with respect to their
intentional and malicious mindsets with
those who are merely reckless. And you
would agree that we put so much more
negative uh implication on someone who's
intentional malicious. You know this
>> snark because he thinks it's some kind
of sandwich or spinning meat like gyros
or something because he's very fat and
so on.
>> Thank you Jimberly. Thank you. That's a
very rude dono. I would like to point
out Jimboy is an ex Destiny.gg
Discord regulator.
Um, that's that's their term for mod. I
would just like to point out. So, he
didn't learn this from me. That's all
I'm saying. He didn't learn this from
me. Thank you for the donor, though.
>> Stephen, you know this, right? An actor
who is intentional and CFKA. I'm
appealing to Kfka here. Kfka is the
reckless standard closer to
maliciousness or to uh totally neutral.
I
>> I don't even know.
>> I could have a bad maybe a bad little
reading. My understanding is you have
nothing no intent at all. You know,
you're not even man's nothing. Then you
have things like uh like um uh
negligence. I don't know if gross
negligence is the next cate. But once
you start to hit reckless, I think
you're a lot closer to like intentional.
Like this is reckless is a standard of
like you should have known better. Yeah,
she should know better.
>> Yeah, that's
>> so for you to say that people are making
this grave error of conflating
recklessness
with she with she was doing this.
>> Yeah, there is a difference between re
recklessness
and malice. Yes.
>> Intentionally, maliciously.
>> You understand that? Wait, wait, wait.
These two things are very close to each
other.
>> So, so, so I I'll just give you an
example, right? So, someone is driving
down the street, incredibly recklessly
driving, all right? and they hit and
unfortunately kill a pedestrian.
Someone else is taking a car and
intentionally as part of a terrorist
act. Let's remove that out of it. We
we'll just keep it so no one can add
anything. All right. Someone is driving
and they try to kill that very same
pedestrian with their car on purpose as
between those two. Don't you put so much
more culpability on the person who is
trying to kill the person as compared to
the person who should have known better?
>> Absolutely.
>> Yeah. So that's my point. That was my
point. All right. And what you took from
that was Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait,
wait, wait. Let me finish. What you took
from that was the reason I'm setting
forth this standard is to protect
Jstalk.
>> Okay.
>> Um, I still agree with that. Um, what I
said
>> wait how how virtue
of what?
>> I like the car because I like the car
example. Okay.
>> Yeah.
>> Let's say that we we saw this happen.
Okay. Let's say that after the person.
>> See, it's funny because I know what
point in the conversation that was
because I remember watching it and
going, "See, I don't think Pisco is
doing this intentionally, but he's
basically having the Destiny antifan
argument with Hutch right now."
>> So, it's so funny that Destiny's like
spazzing the [__] out when he watches it
going like, "I can't believe this. He's
trying to fend J."
Okay, there are there are two worlds
right now where there's a reckless
driver and he hits a person. In one
world, he gets out of the car. He sees
the person
>> and he's like,
>> "Your last name changes when you were on
Destiny's Discord, plus screenshots of
you arguing."
>> I was never a big Destiny Discord user.
Nice try.
>> Turn back now.
>> Thank you for the $51,
you know, runs to a neighbor, whatever
else. In the other world, he backs up
over the guy, runs him over again, and
drives home. Would we move the needle at
all from reckless in the latter to
>> Let me give you what you want. Yeah. So
So let me give you what you want. There
are some facts that you could offer to a
person that what they did was so
depraved and so likely to in the context
of let's say homicide to cause u you
know the harm that it did that it
reaches a degree we're going to we're
going to just call that like uh some
kind of constructive intent a
constructive malice in other words. And
this is called depraved heart murder in
the context of homicide. you know,
you're spraying the [__] assault
rifle in the parking lot. Now, no one
can prove that you intended to kill the
four people that got shot in the head.
And actually, when we go to look at it,
right, it turns out, you know, we know,
we have a mind reader and we know that
you actually didn't want to kill
anybody, but your conduct was so
depraved, was so reckless, was so likely
to cause the result that it did, that we
are going to sort of have that kind of
constructive malice, constructive
intent. I'm not above that. But that's
why we were arguing on the quantum of
evidence that this is like all else
equal that those kinds of comments. No,
because then you have to actually
empirical
comments have the tendency like all else
equal. If you had seen this clip and uh
you know at the time you saw it, would
you be able to predict would you be able
to predict right now?
>> Would you wait? So like let's let's say
that uh I know this might be
>> when you say would you be able to
predict you're you're talking degrees of
probability that people will follow what
happens. I know right now that things
related to the phone are a a big a big
bad in terms of people like swatting
people for instance right now if I start
trying to you know talk on stream about
I think this guy might be killing his
girlfriend and you guys knowing
up for this or base true um or you guys
know the same things right. Could you
say that like well this is almost like a
frame art version of this type of thing.
If you're a streamer, you know these
things are happening. You're watching a
CPS video on stream. You're watching all
this and then when we review the the
response to that and it's one of giggly,
laughing, playing memes and jokes about
it. What are you supposed to think?
>> So are you trying so So yeah. So I'll
ask you, are you are you trying to hurt
esports Batman?
>> Uh emotionally and psychologically, yes.
No, no, no. In the way that you just
suggested,
>> in the sense you're saying obviously
[__]
>> I'd have to think back to how much gear
he actually lost in Rust to actually
know the answer.
>> No, come on. I mean, let's be serious.
>> Pathetic. Pivot. No, I'm not here for
you to defend Jessica's community. I
know why you're trying to defend
Jessica's community right telling me
you're NOT TRYING TO COVER just
community. It's very I'm asking the
standard. I'm asking the standard.
>> We can do this next if you want. Next,
if you want. We can do this. We can go
We can go down this road next if you
want. But I'm asking you, okay? Would
this not be a depraved heart type of
thing that Denims is doing by watching a
video
>> days? No.
>> Because because Yeah, I'll tell you why.
Denim is probably thinking somebody
could [__] call CPS on some [__] like
this, right? I'm going to play this. My
audience is primed for it. You don't
think so?
>> I'll I'll tell you why. Because if you
were to ask and take a poll of people at
the time that this uh you know statement
was made of her just like laughing
along, whatever, and you were to say
like, "What are the odds, right? What
are the odds that um someone actually
calls
>> odds
>> because that's re that's absolutely
relevant to the question of whether
we're going to say there's some kind of
constructive malice or constructive
intent given the relative odds. So I
would imagine you would say in response
Wait, let me can I just finish can I
just finish a thought? I would imagine
that you would say with respect to
doxing that you think
>> because you're going to say you're going
to say that if the odds are incredibly
low and she's going to say the odds are
incredibly low then her saying the thing
can't possibly be constructed malice
because she never thought that there
were high odds for this to begin with.
So it's foolish to say that her saying a
particular thing meant that she
not the comparison. The comparison we
made is a relative one. So for instance
she might think that the odds of it are
low but the question isn't do you think
the odds are low? It's not an absolute
risk comparison. It's a relative risk
ratio. You would say, "Are the odds
going to be higher or lower after you do
this?"
>> Oh, no. I don't agree with that.
You're just totally wrong.
>> No, I don't agree with that. I I think
that would obviously you can take an
action that may slightly increase the
result of something happening, but if
it's a negligible increase, then you're
not going to attribute any culpability
for that, right?
Like, you know, it's like getting in
your car and driving increases the
chance you'll hit someone. But just
because you hit someone while in your
car does not necessarily mean that you
were responsible for it. They could have
walked out quickly. They could have, you
know, they could have been crossing on a
corner. They There's many things could
happen, right?
>> Trying to intuit it like a state of
intention intentionality that it's your
conscious object to do something. I
don't think that you merely look at
relative risk. I think you absolutely do
look at absolute risk. I I think that
that is the case. And and I think that
you would you relative
the risk of them having
over 50%. So I so I understand right
like that you would probably drop your
conduct. You think right like it
wouldn't be justified to cause physical
harm to some of the people who have
antagonize you right. It wouldn't be
justified to do that.
>> I don't have to think about who we're
talking about.
>> No but let's be honest like there are
people for whom you think it's justified
to dox them. That's not that's not a
position that you shy away from. Right.
>> Generally speaking. Yeah. And if someone
came to you and said, "Oh, you know, it
turns out that uh one of these people
gets hurt by someone bad because they've
been going after you. They're trying to
defeat, you know, um the next liberal
Joe Rogan, whatever." I think that you
would say, "I couldn't have predicted at
the time I dox these people."
>> No. Why would I say something? No.
That's a peace goes world. That's a
ridiculous argument. As soon as real
life information is thrown out and
doxing and all that [__] comes out,
these are parts of the thing that are
possible. Yeah. Why do you think I hate
this [__] community so much? just cuz
they've engaged this behavior towards
me, towards my girlfriend, towards
anybody in my life for over a year now.
[__] important to me.
>> And and and so when you so when you say
that in response, you know, doxing is
justified, you're not saying therefore
that hurting them is justified
>> physically, you know.
>> Yeah. So, if someone said that in
response to you uh doxing them, what you
take to be a self-defense dox that what
you're doing is grossly reckless and
that you're causing potential um harm to
befall these people. Harm that wouldn't
be justified under the circumstances you
would say wouldn't be justified. I don't
know if I would agree with that.
>> Well, I thought you I thought we just
cleared that C. I don't know if you
heard like I thought we cleared would be
justified. He doesn't he doesn't follow
peace guy hasn't followed any of it but
no he has literally he has justified
violence repeatedly
>> me relentlessly for almost a year
engaged in and up to potential physical
altercations in real life that they're
instigating or encouraging.
>> I thought we just agreed that it
wouldn't be justified to like physically
hurt them.
>> I said I have to think about it, didn't
I?
>> Oh, I mean maybe you'll bite the bullet
that what you're doing there is a kind
of uh constructive intent to physically
hurt them. I don't think you would bite
that bullet. you that you have the
constructive intent to physically hurt
the people you're not as
I think that you would accept that that
is a potential outcome. Sure.
>> No. No. But would you bite the bullet
that that's your constructive intent
that when you
>> I don't really want to I don't like
biting the bullet here cuz none of these
[__] that you hang out with bite the
bullets on any of their behavior. So why
would I give you the line of rationale
so that they can replay this stupid
[__] clip over and over again? You've
already done it, bro. You've already
done it. We just heard it.
>> You don't have to use it explicitly.
You've literally gone to Will videos and
say, "Yeah, these people should be
killed." You've done that. It's over,
bro. We don't need the argument. You're
just like a [__] wretched spaz, bro.
Only a [__] Indian cult think that
anything you're saying is legit.
>> No, I'm not. No, no. Keep the
conversation focused on Dennis. I know
that you want to win brownie points with
your new friends. Okay, that's what I'm
trying to talk about. [__]
[__] [__] [__] Wait. [__] [__]
[__] [__] Wait. Wait. Wait. No. Wait.
Listen. I don't hang out with those
people. Um, I don't hang out with I
don't hang out with men. I'll hang out
in, you know, their servers. I don't go
around talking [__] about you. Do you
hear me doing that? Do you hear me going
out and and saying all the horrible
things that's occasionally I'll disagree
with the political take you give? I'll
I'll cover your [__] in my opinion
fairly.
>> I understand that you don't do that.
You're you're playing the role that the
epic centrist played basically for all
the [__] Nazis back in 2017%.
You think I'm trying to fence ride and
you think I'm I want brownie points from
every side. Is that what you think?
>> Absolutely no. Just from their side. But
yes, that's why dude has donated like
700 [__] times. His [__]
appointment.
>> That's why Beast goes looked into none
of the drama. That's why he never has
any of the facts to actually contest any
of the insane [__] Destiny saying.
That's why because he's just looking for
brownie points from from me and JTalk,
right? That's why he's got none of the
obvious arguments that you would
obviously use here like Destiny
outwardly explicitly calling for
violence against me and JTalk and Mr.
andlav, you know, like
he he has outwardly explicitly said
these things. Where are they? B's not
saying them. Yeah, he's looking for
brownie points from us. Okay, nice one,
[__]
>> Thank you for the $5. You appreciate it.
Thank you.
>> I just reviewed a Doobie conversation
where I talked so much [__] about
Dubbiey's position on the on the
strikes. If if Doobie wants to donate to
me, I wait
a minute. I don't agree with Trump on
everything. I actually super disagree
with that one condominium that he tore
down in New York City in in 1997. I
don't get this conversation is
pointless. You're never convinced me on
this. Listen, I'm I'm admitting I'm
brain broken on it. It's unfalsifiable
to me. It's not no point in arguing.
It's a faith-based position that I hold.
I have special revelation from God for
you doing this. So, it's not even worth
arguing.
>> Like, back to the denim thing.
>> WHY? WELL, YOU KNOW WHAT? ACTUALLY, HERE
I'll drop this here for for you to be so
incredulous and build, oh, you say it's
constructive intent to hurt somebody,
blah blah blah. Most people would say
yes when it comes to doxing. And when it
comes to doxing adjacent behavior, which
is also probably one of the reasons, I
don't know why I don't think Hutch even
brought this up. Um, funny actually,
we're in a we're in an area where you
said we've been bringing attention to a
thing could be bad, right? And I feel
kind of bad bringing it up, but I think
it's important. One of the reasons also
why Hutch might be annoyed by people
like Benata is because Benata literally,
I'm pretty sure, posted his [__]
ducks on a video that [__]
>> Wait a second. I So I agree that that
[__] is [__] up. I agree that not only
that this kind of excuse that people
say, "Well, you have public access to it
and so it doesn't count." I think that's
everyone as [__] though. I think it has
to everyone agrees. No, we're not. No,
no, no. We're not talking about I don't
care about your virtue signaling here.
There is a guy who has engaged in
>> Yes, I agree. I'm Wait, I'm agreeing
with you. Yes. Yes, I know. But then
when Hutch says bad Abanata is a known
guy for doing bad stuff like this and
then videos on and you say, you know,
you say, well, I know he has a
reputation for what I said was hanging
videos. Denims is playing videos of him
on her stream that then possibly leads
to CPS being called on Ethan. You're
like, "Well, is there a direct causal
link? Can we actually logically link all
of these activities to one another?"
Come on. Like that's an absurd set of
arguments.
>> We we just broke this apart. So, with
respect to the bad empanada comment, I
immediately said, he asked me, I'm just
reacting and I say, I know he has a
reputation for being malicious. I've
seen him act in conformity with it. And
so, my answer is yes. That's what I
said. And the reason that you think I'm
giving cover for bad empanada though you
can watch previous streams where I say
is this person like bad empanada. Do
they do the kinds of things that bad
empanada does clearly implying that I
think bad empanada is a malicious actor?
You can try now because of the order
that I did it which was honest. It might
be in your mind autistic that somehow
I'm trying to give cover for bad
empanada. That that is let me be genuine
here. This is my No, it's totally
justified when Hutch when you asked
Hutch um I think it was like why is
Ethan doing this lawsuit and he gave a
reason and then you were like well I
think it's because of this malicious
thing and Ara is like okay sure yeah
yeah it's it's possible he used two
reasons you were very sharp and very
keen to clarify excuse me you bald [__]
you didn't say it was you didn't mean
that it was logically possible that they
could have these two positions cuz when
you say that now it gives you the
ability to weasel out of it later were
like, I need you to say they have two
motivations at least. And you forced him
to take a position. But when you say
when you say when somebody says
>> that I absolutely
>> I'll tell you exactly what happened.
People can compare.
>> I listen to wedd.
>> Okay. I was there too. Like why why do
you think that like I'm not allowed to
contest your your rendition of that
conversation? So he asked me I just
think that it's it's like that he could
have had two motives. And I'm like I'm
just clarifying by that. Do you mean
that there's like some good reason to
believe he had a second motive or do you
just mean the bare um like question that
I wouldn't like disagree with is that he
could have it? And the reason why I'm
doing that is is simply because people
have asked that of me and I've said yeah
of course he could have two motives. And
what they've taken from that is see
Pisco admits that he could have two
motives and therefore why what the [__]
is he talking about? That's what's
happened before in the past. Okay, I'm
going to say this is one of the only
time I'm going to say this is a not mad
thing I guess or I'm going to try to be
when you speak like this. Every single
person, Hutch included, hears an
accusation carried along there that they
are intentionally and maliciously trying
to conceal their true beliefs.
Especially when you started that
conversation off by saying, I want to
make sure that we both agree that this
is an important conversation to have
because I don't want to run through all
the points. Why do you think I did that?
So, so, so what's informing my conduct
in the conversation is what I've uh had
to deal with, which are like I think
very obnoxious. Um,
>> wait, hold on. I don't dis say I'm just
saying that to say all of that and then
to get the bad you think the bad is like
a bad guy, right? And you're like, well,
I understand that he has the reputation
of being a bad guy and I have seen him
do some bad things. You understand that
you've hedged yourself in that case.
You're in like you're Fort Knox. You've
hedged against everything there.
>> He just doesn't do he just doesn't have
perfect information about bad. It's just
like so [__] stupid. The reason I
hedged and qualified in the sense of I
didn't immediately say unamiguously yes
is I was racking my brain to see if
there were moments in time that I'm
specifically recalling such that if
someone were to challenge me in that
moment can I actually like produce these
examples of the accusations that I'm
coming up with. Not all of us are so um
you know reckless as you make these
accusations off the cuff of certain
individuals without having the evidence
prepared like the accusation that you
said that I actually want to protect a
community that's harassing a young
woman. I mean, so as I I'm thinking out
loud, I'm just honestly telling you what
>> most human beings just don't have a clip
reservoir ready to produce a but you
think I don't act like this harass
but but but Stephen I've acted like this
as long as you've known me, right?
People have always said, "Why can't he
just get it out? Why is he so wordy?
This is not something that is out of
character or out of step for me. This is
how I engage. And now are there ways
that I can improve?" For sure. What is
unjustified is to say, "Oh, he's just
scrifting to make money from [__]
doobie. He wants to protect his
community. What the [__]
>> Put together in my head how unbelievably
and insanely aggressive you are with
somebody who is relentlessly golden
retriever levels of good.
>> Dude, Pisco was aggressive with Hutch in
that conversation.
What planet are you living on? What
[__] planet are you living on, dude?
What [__] planet are you living on?
Pisco, the biggest problem with that is
Pisco wasn't aggressive enough. He just
sat there being polite the whole time
when Hutch is going
like this the whole time at him. H is
actually sat there pulling faces at
everything Pisco is saying and Pisco is
trying to calmly explain to him. I don't
know what you're talking about right now
like that the whole [__]
conversation. He should have been more
aggressive.
good faith and charitability to you and
you're trying to crucify condescending
to Hutch. This is condescending to
Hutch, man.
>> It's not condescending.
>> No, thank you for the raid. Aiden,
welcome in. Welcome in. Aiden Raiders,
welcome in. Have a lot of respect for
for people like Hutch and Josiah. As in
when I say this, what I mean is like I
think I think Hutch views you he
respects you. He views you as a friend.
He respects you intellectually. He he
has all these things in in his mind for
you and he's trying his best to get out.
>> Yeah. And you're trying to run these
ridiculous syntactic do this with you?
Wait, wait. Did I do this with you back
in the day?
>> I like that. We enjoy this. This is fun
for us. It's But it's different. Like
with you and Rob Noir. Do you have the
same conversation with your mom that you
do with Rob Noir?
>> You should ask my mom, man.
>> Sometimes. Listen, random.
It depends. No, not a client. No, no,
not no. But like if you ask people in my
personal life like and we are having a
like back and forth, I don't know what
to tell you. Like this is just how I
engaged with in discussions. I've always
done it. Everyone will tell you that
it's in conformity with what I do. And
the reason why I have we have those
exchanges with you and I treat you
because I I don't treat anyone
differently. I don't want to treat
people differently. Now, sometimes if if
they're coming on, it's a different kind
of moment and like I can tell they're
really struggling, but I just like don't
view Hutch that way. I'm going to treat
Hutch Thanksgiving debate. Yes or no?
Yes or no to his mom. Dude,
>> in the debate, right? This is a debate
about the [__] merits. And so, I
treat Hutch the way I would treat you
when we're talking about self-defense,
right? Do you see any big difference
with how I treated Hutch versus how I
treated you in self-defense?
>> You're doing this weird like normative
um you're trying to um equate
normatively these two things, but it's
not like you're saying like well if you
treat them differently uh but you treat
them differently.
>> No, you're acting like I'm treating
Hutch maliciously and cuz I like I don't
like them. You are in this
>> but but it's just totally in line.
>> Go on a whole pant and say Pisco has
lied so much about my past. I was like
really basically everything. I was like
what do you mean? Here's a clip. Pisco
says I was a pro [__] Starcraft
player. What a [__] [__] I barely
played Starcraft like Prof. I never
played Starcraft. I was a Starcraft 2
professional, right? You would look at
that and be like, "What do you mean
Starcraft 2?" Well, Jesus Christ, is
that really that big of a difference
there? I wouldn't expect you to know
that. It's not cuz I think you're
[__] It's not cuz I think you're an
idiot and don't know the difference. I
just don't I wouldn't expect you to
delineate between Starcraft and
Starcraft 2. The same way that I
wouldn't expect any normal human being
outside of the Ask Yourself Discord
server to talk about a logical
possibility, meaning that syntactically
the deductive logic follows that there
is no contradiction between two of the
statements.
Dude, there is obviously a difference
between the concept of possibility
and plausibility. And when someone is
presenting something as a possible
scenario, but it's not plausible, it's
worth pointing that out.
>> Thing that any normal human being.
>> So you you might disagree and you might
think I got like debate aids from uh Avi
and Isaac recently and I have talked to
them recently like the last year, right?
and we've had these different
conversations where in many ways, you
know, I credit a lot of what they've uh
said to like I understand people are
going to take the different view this is
stupid and should never do it, but it's
really helped me think about like where
the disagreements are. I I like when I
think back to the socialism
conversations that we had with
counterpoints with you, with uh economy,
all these other people, it really makes
me think that there's a lot of semantic
uh lack of understanding and that really
opened my eyes and people can see the
conversations I had with Isaac. they can
see where uh you know I'm being
introduced to a lot of these different
ways to analyze conversations by um Avi
who I just had a conversation with and
there's just like a very clear way like
why this is now coming up and why I'm
more thoughtful about um the terms
people are using it's because of that
it's not because I hate Hutch I don't
hate why why would I do a podcast with
someone I hate
>> and maybe you don't maybe you just don't
understand what comes up but what you're
talking about I agree with you when it
comes to Isaac and Abby even if I
disagree on their vegan thing and even
if I think the Azure discord server is
whatever they are very good when when it
comes to their logical statements and
their deduction and there and if you
>> I learned things. Yeah. And I've learned
things in those discord servers in terms
of how to formulate.
>> I'm not trying to No, I understand. But
I'm saying that when you take
propositional logic no education from
college discord servers though lie.
That's where that's where Destiny gets
his smart to an ordinary.
>> No, no, no, but it's not prop logic.
What I'm all I'm doing there that they
have clued me into where I'm like a lot
more thoughtful about it than I used to
be. um is semantics is to make sure that
we that I before I answer something like
what just happened with encouragement,
right? Before I answer something, I just
want to make sure that I know what I'm
committing to and I want to make sure
that we're using the same terms and that
we're not equivocating. Another example
of this is when it um when it came to
the socialism conversation, I just want
to be clear. What do we mean by
socialism then we're going to condemn
it. If what we mean by socialism is um
you know 100% only the means of
production, no avenue for private
enterprise, whatever, then we might have
a different conclusion than socialism
means the government does stuff. And so
I've just I'm a lot more thoughtful
about making sure before I agree to a
proposition to make sure I understand
it.
>> Yeah. I Okay. Like even the example that
you just used, okay, disagreements over
what socialism is, like this is a
there's heavy semantic content in terms
of like you're talking a sub a hugely
substantive difference between these two
definitions. Okay, which it is good to
differentiate on. But when somebody says
like um like is it possible that I could
jump to the moon and you're like I think
you actually use
>> I use that. Yeah. No, I use that to the
reason normal human being. You never in
your life.
>> Dude, look at what Ethan is spazzing out
about now. This is just funny, man. I'm
sorry. This is just funny.
The son has now donated more money to
Candace Owens and Froen, Casey Trron,
and Denims combined.
Candace Owens sold out. Why wasn't the
interview on camera? For your safety and
for our pursuit of truth. That's funny.
That's a funny do to send.
>> And if Hutch tried to get you on that
later on in the conversation where he
was like, "Well, you said that it was uh
earlier. I know that everything you're
saying is [__] cuz you said that it
was impossible to dance to this, but you
also said it was
>> Guys, stop the presses. One millionaire
sent another millionaire $10."
>> Impossible to jump to the moon. And
actually, you can't demonstrate a
logical contradiction involved in
jumping to the moon unless you involve
the laws of physics. Like nobody talks,
NOBODY THINKS LIKE IS IN YOUR MIND, what
are the chances that Hutch is going to
pull a [__] a [__] philosophy
trick on you like that to get you in an
argument?
>> No. No. I suspect that what Hutch means
is it's a decent chance
is cheap, isn't he? Like for all this
talk about like, yo, his just, you know,
spends money on on stupid [__] It's
like he got his car
and like some clothes and he just cheaps
out on everything else, but then the
money doesn't seem to go anywhere. The
money doesn't seem to go anywhere. They
spend it all on ugly Gucci, I'm afraid.
That's awesome. That's awesome, though.
That's awesome.
He buys scents sale, by the way. All of
his weird colored silk shirts, a sale
section.
TJ Maxx, a millionaire.
That's also awesome. That's also based.
That's cool.
If a son shopped in TK Maxx, that'd be
awesome.
That'd be [__] epic.
>> I just wait. But
>> when you say possible, you mean
possible, right? Yeah. And then you move
on and you're done. You don't have to
spend 20 minutes explaining possible
realities and all possible universes and
like just say move on.
>> But when I say why I'm doing it because
like it becomes like a hang-up in the
conversation. The reason I do it is just
to show people like I'm not trying to
[__] with you at all. I just want to
make sure that when the audience sees
this clip, they're not going to be able
to cut out me saying, "Yeah, he could
have had two different motives." And
then people say, "Look, he said like the
only reason I'm doing is not because I
don't suspect Hutch means plausible that
he doesn't mean this." It's and when I
say that, like I I'm just trying to take
this moment to get people to appreciate
why I'm doing it in good faith. you turn
it into I've heard the term that you
used slimy that I'm getting these
opinions from other people that I'm
trying to like uh basically pull the
wool over Hutch's eyes because I guess I
don't know why like I want him to
suffer. I want Hutch to suffer. How is
that in line with the rest of my uh the
rest of the stuff I do? I I don't think
that I've ever like have I shown to be
malicious in it. I don't know if it's
intentional, but I know that like when
you argue with if you argue with me, if
you argue with Rob Noir, these are like
the kinds of combos you engage in. And I
I treat Hutch the same way. Wait, like
and you see uh you see on Live and Learn
when we have conversations about Mom
Donnie, about the the [__] shutdown.
It's the same [__] And in those moments
like, yeah, I treat with I I treat him
the way I would treat other
interlocators in that moment. And
sometimes Hutch is, you know, I love
him. He's my boy. Sometimes he I think
he's sometimes unwilling to answer a
question and I have to push and push and
push and push a little bit. Not unlike
you and not unlike maybe sometimes me,
right? I don't I think I try to answer
questions, but um you know, we all have
our moments. So all I'm just trying to
say is I'm not treating him any
materally worse. Why would I do that?
What what's the incentive that I have to
just [__] on my [__] on him? Like why
why what is the possible justification
that I would to do that? Hutch wanted to
have the conversation. So did I. I
thought it's useful.
>> I want
>> So in the future if you're on stage with
some politician or something else like
do you think it's possible that we could
fund some program with ABCDFJ or
whatever? You're just going to say yes
or no. Well, I think it's likely to say,
well, when you say possible, do you mean
does it entail logically a contradiction
or not?
>> Listen, I think there are contexts where
the meaning the fact that you actually
mean plausible likely, there are
contexts where that's implied like in
that one because they're asking for you
to do something. Now in the case of this
where you're trying to hash out a
philosophical standard it's actually
very important to or like the uh
particular thing that happened in event
say motivation for instance it's uh
actually very important to pass through
like quite what exactly are you saying
here
there is a more clean way you can say it
I I don't know about possibly I do mean
likely or something like that maybe
there's a faster way to say it but that
is an advice like maybe I'll accept in
terms of like saying it in a less I
don't know a less
The thing is it doesn't show I'm
malicious. It doesn't show that I'm
trying to
>> It might not show it, but it it it feels
that way.
>> It feels that way when you when you
[__] say it, dude. It feels that way
when you basically say that everything
I'm doing in that context is to try to
[__] like mind [__] Hutch. It seems
condescending to Hutch. Um,
>> how do you think? I'm curious. I'm
curious. No, stop doing this. It feels
like you're saying that Hutch is stupid.
It's not that. It's a different thing.
We We have different skill sets. We
excel in different areas and we do
different things. It's not like I don't
think that Hutch spends all of his time
doing a [__] hardcore I'm a [__]
debate lord blah blah blah. Like I don't
I I don't think he just does that. I
don't think Josiah does that. I think
both these people are very intelligent
people. I respect their political Hutch
is like the only [__] guy in the
whole gaming world. It's not a [__]
political [__] I have a ton of
respect for him. So it's not don't stop
doing this weird thing where it's like,
"Oh, are you saying I need to treat him
like a [__] retard?"
>> I don't treat him differently. I don't I
treat him like a a smart person with who
I debate. You said you you made the
claim you made the claim that Well, when
you say it is it is that way. How do you
think Hutch felt at the end of your
conversation to
>> I think he felt great. I think he felt
great.
>> It's actually not about the issues
anymore. It's like you're being mean to
Hutch. You're not treating Hutch nice
enough. Hutch is still on my team and
you're not treating him nice enough.
>> Queenman dresses like he just shot 23
over on the front nine and had to take a
breather to nurse some low calorie
seltzers with the gang.
>> I don't even know what that means. Thank
you for the $5 a Thank you.
>> Why would he feel bad?
Okay. But then one of us is super
artistic cuz my takeaway was I think
that there's a feeling that you get
sometimes where you have a very calling
you Jewish blue a brain blue ball
unsatisfied feeling where you're like I
feel like I just argued for 4 hours and
I feel like we didn't actually cover
anything which I actually I don't even
think you guys got to the central point
of
>> I don't think we did. Yeah. No, I I
don't think we I agree with that.
>> 4 hours you barely got through the meta
conversation. I would be surprised and I
could be wrong. I would be surprised if
Hutch came away from that conversation
like man that was a really good
argument. I think it was probably like
[__] that was so unsatisfying. I feel
like we didn't get to talk about
anything.
>> Well, I'm not sure. But did you see us
like do the aftercare there where I'm
like I love him. Nobody attack him.
>> Why would I do that? Is that you think
that that's also performative so that I
don't get like uh the the notion that
I'm just trying to like [__] with
>> it. That's not fair. That's not fair.
>> What is after? That's not fair.
>> Yeah. Oh, come on. That's
>> That is not fair.
>> You're just you're making a joke. You
know what I'm talking about. Yeah. After
you [__] someone. After you [__]
someone. Yeah. No, but No, but but
you're No. No. But that's
God. You're being fast and loose. You're
being fast and loose.
>> You're being like, dude, that you know
someone is on awfully shaky ground when
they start doing this. When they're
screeching going, "You just said the
word. You just said the word. You just
said this one word." Like this is like
the shakiest ground you can be on in a
conversation. It is like the just it's
so cringy. It is so cringy, man.
>> Why so [__] hard?
>> You're being fast and loose. That's not
at all what I [__] meant. What I
meant is I made sure after that, right?
I'm not saying like go [__] yourself.
Oh, he's such a bad fake piece of [__]
What I said was, by the way, guys, I
love Hutch. Hutch is my boy. I'm not
just saying that faciciously. I like
Hutch a lot. I do a [__] podcast with
them. I'm telling you're saying it's but
I'm saying that like the the
conversation was probably deeply
unsatisfying.
>> Well, there are aspects about it that
were unsatisfying to me too, but that I
don't think
>> nothing was unsatisfying.
>> Okay.
>> Nothing of substance was spoken about.
It was like a debate with Rob Noah,
Andrew Wilson where it's like I I don't
know what the [__] I just debated for 4
hours.
>> The way I can tell you my impression
three hours in Hutch was like I think
I'm tired of this go and you're like are
you know what you did? You know what you
did? No, I I can just tell you my
impression if you want to hear it. You
>> said that. Do you think Hutch was
actually like sleepy?
>> I I don't know. I mean, like I think he
was probably like frustrated with the
conversation.
>> Stealing the we love bit. Someone Well,
you know, I felt like I kind of came up
with that, but someone told me that Red
Bar had been doing it for a long time.
So, I don't know if it seeped into my
head. I know Pisco also watches Red Bar,
so it could it could be anything really.
>> But I don't think I don't think that
he's like sad or angry about it. I just
think he's fine after.
>> No, but there are different types of
frustrations. There can be a frustration
like [__] like I didn't have like the
information here or like oh [__] he got
me on this point and then there's a
frustration of like I feel like my
intuitions are being twisted around and
I'm being yked around all these
different topics of discussion. I don't
even really know. But yes,
>> have you ever felt that way talking to
me?
>> Sometimes not.
>> So just because that's a feeling that
exists.
>> Usually though because both of No, no,
no, no, no. Because usually both of us
generally speak. Well, no. I have felt
that way after the [__] rage combo
that we had whatever the time before
last or whatever. But like generally
speaking, we're both collaboratively
trying to build towards some end. And
you're not usually trying to like sneak
away from things like I feel like
actually you kind of have in this
conversation which we'll go back to. But
I do feel that way when I debate with
Andrew Wilson or when I watch every
Jordan Peterson debate. These are never
debates. These are constantly trying to
form a way.
>> Hopefully that people can understand a
difference between me and Andrew Wilson.
The difference is and and I hope that
people remember my conduct when it was
reacting to the insurrection debate that
you had with Andrew Wilson when I felt
that people that for example this is
exactly where I defended you, right? Do
you remember when he said something like
it's not my burden to show whatever
whatever whatever. remember when he said
that and everyone in their uncle was uh
saying, "Oh, it's he's right. You know,
he doesn't have the burden. That's
correct. He doesn't have the burden."
But then partway through the
conversation, um he makes a claim like I
think that the definition you provided
would better fit the term riot as
opposed to insurrection. Of course, once
he made that claim, he is putting into
issue some kind of reference to what
words ought to mean. And so, he needs to
provide Wait, no, no, no. I just want to
finish the [__] Can I finish it,
please? I def No, I defended you on on
No, no, no, no. Not in terms of the the
personalities there. I defended it from
his
>> can literally just thinking about all
like you're not defending me anymore.
You're not defending me on this.
>> Shut up, man.
>> Trying to uh hide his relative burden in
that context. On the same grounds where
I was saying that it actually is Hutch's
burden now with respect to whatever
point he was making about Denim's
intent. I was defending you when you
were correctly stating to Andrew Wilson
and he was being using a a slimy
insincere debate tactic that he didn't
have a burden anymore. So that's
precisely what I'm not trying to do. I'm
open. I have calls to have people come
in so they can they can chat about
stuff.
>> I'm just saying but for I'm just saying
that my guess would be is that Hutch
probably felt like that was an Andrew
Wilson or Rob Nord debate that he had
with you. Not like a debate with a
friend who's collaboratively trying to
build towards some argument.
>> It was a debate, man. I mean I don't
know what to tell you. We were we've had
conversations before. I think that the
fact that I
>> literally like Pisco consents touch
consents. Is there someone you forgot to
ask?
>> From the perspective of like, well, can
we just agree that this matters? It
would it's it's trying to build some set
of like understanding and and and
gerting principles where we can walk
away from it having at least some uh
better sense of a position. And maybe
that kind of style works better with Avi
and these other types of people. I don't
have any problems with those people.
Maybe it's because, you know, they're
also autist. I it is not
>> what you just said is fine. When you
said when you said maybe that style
works better with those other people.
That's what I'm saying. I think it does.
Not because Hutch is stupid and not
because somebody is able or not able,
but just because of how people different
people do.
>> Okay. So then why don't you give me the
benefit of the doubt there instead of
[__] accusing me of trying to grift
to tankies. I mean that's basically
>> because you're doing this because
because where it's the difference
between negligence and recklessness. You
should know better. If this was a
private conversation, I would have a
difference of opinion about it. This was
>> with respect to tankies. With respect to
tankies in what sense am I am I trying
to to grift from like grifting is
something you do I think right unless
you think that there's unintentional
griffining.
>> I feel like grifting is an accusation of
intent. You're doing something insincere
to make money and you've accused me of
>> how many indiv how many individual
donations has dubbie sent in this
stream?
>> That's what I'm accusing you of.
>> How many people in your chat right now
or your discord are also in justical
discord are also in Dubby's discord or
also those are the that's the but that's
really Should they be banned? Should
they be banned? Should they be banned?
Should they be banned?
>> At least that. Yeah.
>> That's not relevant to this.
>> No, but it's not about should they be
banned. YOU'RE DOING IT RIGHT NOW WITH
WITH THE BINARY. OH, WAIT. SO, should
they be banned? Right. Imagine I have a
Nazi in my Imagine I have nothing. You
can't do anything. There's nothing you
can do.
>> No, no. Tell me what Tell me what I
ought do.
>> No, no, no. I'm telling you that there's
either ban or murder.
>> I'm not saying No, I'm being serious.
Wait. I'm I'm What ought I do with
respect to Dub's donations? Should I not
accept them and give it back? I'm asking
what the moral duty that how would I
comply?
>> It's not about accepting or denying the
donation. It's the question of like why
are all of these people super
supportive? That's the question
>> presumably because
>> which I don't even care. That's not even
that important. That's not even the
central part. I think I laid this
criticism out like
>> the moment he's about to he can't even
stop and lay this out for a moment. He
has to like keep moving. He cannot stay
on a point for more than one second cuz
he knows any level of interrogation
makes it all fall apart. It's so [__]
lame, bro.
Five hours. Listen, that's not my
central
wait. So, so can be. So, you don't think
that I'm grifting for tankies, do you?
>> Kind of.
>> Why? How? On virtue of what? You think
I'm a tanky supporter?
>> You're one of the smartest people I've
ever had the pleasure of talking to
online. Some of the things that you were
saying to Hut yesterday were so
unfathomably unbelievable that I cannot
believe that they originated from the
same mind as the person I spoke with and
was president for 2 years. That's just
impossible for me to believe that Hutch
can ask you a question as plainly as if
somebody says that some children are
maybe dying in a house. Do you think
that justifies a CPS call? And you're
like, "Well, does it logically mean that
causally it's length and you have to
necessarily imply that every single
person in the audience is going to be
calling CPS and it would be a
justification for them?" Like that's
impossible to me that a human being
can't say like, "Yeah, of course, sure.
Of course, yes, Hutch. That that would
be reasonable for you to call CPS at
that point."
>> I guess I'm shocked because I feel like
I've always interacted this way. I feel
like it's consistent with my personality
and people for better or worse, it's
been divisive. It's been divisive. There
are people who um have always hated my
contributions, who have always called me
a pedant, who have always said that like
the contributions I have or it's always
like, well, technically, you know, and
they put the [__] everyone put it in
chat right now, the the glasses guy with
the little [__] finger up. That has
always been my reputation for better or
worse. I don't always agree that that
is, you know, in fact the case. I don't
agree with that [__] Um but but that's
my that is my substance. I agree. I
agree. I agree. But the difference is is
that when people were complaining about
you there, they were complaining about
the style but not the substance. Right.
Piece might be right here, but God is so
[__] annoying. Oh, you might be so
[__] right. The main complaint right
now though is on the substance that it
feels like you're writing cover for all
of these people by employing the most
insane arguments, the most majin budded
Vegeta fighter in the history of all of
argumentation.
Ha. Peace goes mind controlled. He's
like He's like He's like Boo Vegeta.
He's like Martian Vegeta. He's like
Martian Vegeta.
Dude, piece goes mind controlled. He's
like Martian Vegeta.
What a man. Honestly, this is a
38-year-old man.
>> Just give me a second.
>> If we go back to the
>> Sorry, I just need to do something real
quick. Hang on. Um you guys cannot um
actually
One second. Uh, chat. Okay, we got it.
No more chat. YouTube chat. Sorry,
you're done. Um, go ahead. Sorry. You're
saying
>> what? Okay, I don't care about YouTube
chat. Okay.
>> No, they were doing to stuff.
Um,
>> what's the point? Like, no. What? Like,
>> wait, wait, wait. I'm so I'm curious.
Going back to everything that we saw
before. Okay.
What? When Denims was watching
all of bad evan stuff, the first video
related to the CPS stuff um where he's
talking about the [__] guard Gargia
or whatever the [__] it is and then the
laughing about when Elen and um Ethan
complain about it and she's like
laughing at in response to
>> I think it's a wrong thing. I think it's
a wrong thing.
>> No. No. And then Okay. And then and then
when she watches the badanata joke,
do you think
>> Yes. That's so soility.
Well, wait. Let's say that a second CPS
call comes happens. We don't know who.
Let's say a second CPS call happens. Do
you think that she would have some
culpability
in that second CPS call occurring?
>> She be partially responsible for it
happening.
>> So, so I understand culpability to refer
to a moral fault, right? So, some kind
of like moral Yes. So, the answer um is
yes with respect to recklessness. Yes.
with respect to negligence, not yes with
respect to intentional malicious uh
phone call.
>> Wait, why is there a moral fault related
to recklessness?
>> Yeah, because you're So that kind of
conduct contains a substantial and
unjustifiable risk.
>> Correct. So it's tied exactly to the
harms that could result.
>> But that doesn't mean that we have the
same moral intuitions with respect to
someone. And we went through the [__]
car example to to show that that it's
and that's what I mean, right? Like,
>> no, no, no. We absolutely have the same
moral intuitions. If somebody drives
drunk and they get home, the person
doesn't say, "Do you drove drunk home?"
And the guy's like, "Yeah, but I didn't
hit anybody." They say, "You could have
killed somebody." You wouldn't say,
"Excuse me, I didn't kill anybody." And
even if I did, that's a separate action
than just driving drunk. So, these two
things are not logically intelled by one
another.
>> Okay. So I agree that we would just
because you didn't cause the death of
another person and um just because you
didn't actually have the results of such
that you could be like charged for I
don't know drunk manslaughter or
whatever the [__] that is. I mean there
are some uh situations in which I mean
the kind of conduct that issue with
drunk driving is so reckless at this
point and everyone knows it that we all
we we understand that. So I'm not trying
to say that the bad act only occurs when
the like the kind of result elements.
I'm very intention pilled when I will
treat very differently someone whose
conscious object is to produce a bad
result as opposed to someone who is
acting really really recklessly or even
negligently um and bad stuff hap happens
to happen or it just happens right um
absolutely agree with that no doubt
about it what all I'm trying to say is
there is a huge significant difference
between those two things and you have to
really be honest with yourself at the
time that uh denims watched that video
>> before you knew Wait real quick real
because we might agree on everything.
Okay. But because I want to disagree one
thing you said it goes back to the
question I asked CFKA to moderate
earlier. You said there is a huge
difference between these two things. I
personally I don't see there is some but
I don't see as much daylight between
like between like depraved heart and
first degree. I don't see
>> that's not what I'm saying. No no no
depraved heart recklessness.
>> That's an area where reckless it's so
reckless. The risk is so great that it's
going to be some kind of uh constructive
intent. So, we're going to treat it
actually the same.
>> I don't think isn't the brave heart used
as a second degree murder justification
generally.
>> No, but like essentially you're you're
fulfilling the malice aspect of murder.
The thing that makes it the worst is you
you're so reckless that we're going to
treat you like you you basically try to
kill them.
>> Yes. Yes.
>> Yeah.
>> That's but that's but when somebody is
watching or I just don't understand how
what Denims is doing is not
>> on that level. This is why I didn't
think it was her response. Why doesn't
it seem like the response indicates that
that is basically what she was doing?
>> So, The reason why I think that I'm not
going to do that kind of constructive
intent is because all else equal. I
think the risk of someone else doing the
CPS call on the basis of that statement,
right? That that statement is a but for
cause relating to some. So that's what
you have to show, right? Like the risk
is related to the thing, right? What is
the thing itself? The thing is her
making that comment, right? Um that her
the additional risk by her making those
comments and having those reactions
>> is essentially small in comparison. No,
I think it's basic.
>> No, you don't. You don't. There. The
butt for doesn't even need to be
demonstrated there. If you go out and
you drunk drive and somebody goes out,
somebody else goes out and somebody
Yeah. Perfect. Perfect. So, so that's an
action that in its tendency has an
incredibly high risk to do the thing,
right? It's just by it's we're so lucky
that it didn't happen.
>> It really doesn't, right? Drunk driving.
I'm sure
>> Yeah, probably. My guess is going to be
less than 1% of drunk drivers actually
get into an accident. Unfortunately, in
the US, a lot of people drunk drive.
>> Okay, maybe I'd agree with that. But
what I'm saying is at least at a bare
minimum, right, I think that you've
shown like a much higher tendency when
it comes to drunk driving and some kind
of related offense, some kind of, you
know, accident, that kind of [__]
>> Yeah. But the reason, okay, the reason
why the percentage so sure is small is
because there are so few accidents in
general.
>> But the point of drink driving is that
if you are in one of those situations
where you could cause an accident or
something happens while you're driving
that could cause an accident, you are
going to be
orders of magnitude way way way way way
higher more likely for it to [__] up.
It's not
they both
cuz the thing I try to distinguish here
is about relative and absolute risk,
right? There is like quite high absolute
risk to drunk driving once you're in
those situations. Like the absolute risk
is high once you're in that situation.
Yes, broadly there aren't that many car
accidents in general. So yes, even drunk
driving broadly, you're not like going
to crash and kill someone the majority
of the time, of course.
But once you're in those situations, the
absolute risk is very high.
>> Can you clarify for me because it feels
like you just stumbled into that
argument I made before, which is it's
not about absolute risk, it's about
relative risk. It's that you're taking
an action that's going to significantly
increase the chance of something
happening, not just that the absolute
risk of it happening is high.
>> No. No. I I don't think that's true. So
like suppose that for for example that
um you have the tiniest little sip or I
won't say that a medium sip of wine.
Okay, you have now just significantly
increased the risk of a crash, right?
But you're just sober, right? You are
sober. And so yeah, it's it's it's a a
significant increase in risk, but by all
account, it's not significant enough
such that you are in any danger
whatsoever of crashing more than
>> Yeah. Just the just the increase in
relative risk alone is not enough to
justify like any increase in relative
risk is not enough to justify
culpability
>> like I don't know you being tired on a
particular day or you having like a bad
fight with a partner on a given day in
that context in that context wait I just
want you to grant it right so in that
context
>> the reason I won't grant it is because I
think there might be a hypothetical I
would but because I don't know if having
a single sip of wine does anything
mentally like your body might just
process
>> no no but assume right that you've
you've taken a sip of alcohol such that
it has significantly increase the risk
similar to the uh the risk of
distraction from a fight similar to the
risk of you know having 2 hours less
sleep than you would have right but
you're still good to drive under every
normal standard in that context right
notwithstanding the increase in relative
risk you are not reckless right you're
not negligent
>> agreed
>> I disagreed
>> you think you're recklessly driving if
you have like if you stay under the
limit drink a drink a small responsible
amount
And then and then drive sober. Drive
legally and for all intents purposes
sober. You are you are negligent and
reck Okay.
>> Two hour sleep diversion equivalent.
>> Somebody who [__] drove tired way too
much in my casino.
>> 2 hours. I'm pretty sure there's
literally
>> a two hour a two hour sleep. You're a
little tired, but but you're good to
drive. And compared to an old fart who
was even on his best day.
>> Well, no. You know what I'm saying?
Maybe not. But at that point, it
probably because we'd be looking at like
um things related to um it wouldn't be
intent. There's another word you would
look here for, but like what is it? Like
for instance, you don't need like we
would view somebody who who drank a
little bit of alcohol differently than
somebody who maybe took an anti-allergy
medication um versus somebody who maybe
just didn't get quite enough sleep. But
I but we could look to the purpose of
not having a lot of sleep, right? So,
for instance, let's say somebody only
got like two hours of sleep and they
went driving the next day and it was
because they were up all night taking
care of their kid who was crying versus
somebody who only got two hours of sleep
because they were grinding the end of
the Arc Raider season. Do you think that
we would hold one of these people more
culpable if an accident happened the
next day?
>> I think all legally no. Yes. I think as
between those two cases, we would hold
the person who has the kind of the
trivial reason for for staying up a
little more like we would treat them a
little differently. All else equal. What
we would do though tied into the example
for like Hutch, right? Like if Hutch
watched the video to debunk it,
>> how about you just finish hashing this
out first before trying to jump into the
other point and desperately force
through your conclusion. It's so lame.
>> A bad thing. And somebody the audience
might have Well, hold on. We would treat
that a lot different than somebody
watching a video and giggling and
laughing along.
>> Right. Right. No, I I agree with that.
But the question isn't um as between
those two cases, which one would we see
is more culpable between two people who
are relatively not culpable, right? The
question is would that situation that is
where you have a minor sleep deficit but
not nearly the you know to the extent to
which it would uh impair your driving to
some kind of normal standard of driving
that we would all accept in that
situation not withstanding the
increasing relative risk you would say
that person they're not being reckless
they're not being negligent they're able
to drive and they've you know you could
even make it more crazy right like you
have a NASCAR driver who under optimal
circumstances would never ever ever uh
drive bad at all and this person has
like a big swing of uh alcohol but he's
not over to the legal limit and um he's
impaired like 30% of his driving skill,
but his normal rate of driving is just
so so far above everyone else. And
you've brought him down you' probably
borrow a word from Abby and and Isaac
you there probably like a threshold that
you would argue for that threshold that
threshold is not that threshold is
absolute risk. You need to have a
threshold of absolute risk just just
decreasing the relative risk if you're
an alien being who's you know optimal.
No, the the threshold I think the
threshold will be relevant when we're
talking about like unintentionality, but
for intentionality, I think the
threshold would basically completely
disappear. So, for instance, if I was
cooking, yeah, so I'm back in the
kitchen, I bring a steak out from the
freezer and I leave it on the counter
for [__] 12 hours before I throw it
on the grill and I serve it and somebody
gets food poisoning or whatever, right?
And and let's say that they it's, you
know, it's it's really bad or whatever,
you know, that's not good. Versus if I
take a steak out, I do everything I'm
supposed to with it, but then I like put
like a little bit of dirt from the floor
on it or I step on it with my shoe or
whatever. Like there's there's no
we would treat someone who intended it
differently.
>> Yes.
That was my whole [__] point in the
[__] stream that you sawed out about
and said I WAS A GRIFTER. THAT WAS MY
WHOLE [__] POINT. YOU JUST RESTATED
IT.
>> What was your whole point? My whole
point is we treat so differently the
intentional [__] acts of someone than
the acts that even if they uh you know
impose an unjustifiable risk and they're
culpable for that we treat them so so
differently. That was my point.
>> Yes, of course. But the question is
whether or not denims should have known
that this behavior was going to result
from this. any reasonable. Of course,
you would know this obviously and you
can tell that by reading into how they
>> he's just restating the the like
reckless or negligent standard.
The distinction they've just drawn is
about malice versus recklessness, right?
That's what they've just hashed out. And
now this is reiterating that Denim is
actually only negligent, which is
basically his position.
React to the situation. I I I mean I I
don't know that you can Does Denim
strike you as a person who is like
conscious of uh does she strike you as a
bright person who is going to be able to
know all the entailments of the kind of
risky behavior she does? I'm not sure,
but maybe she is.
>> [__] No, you're right. Dennis doesn't
know every single possible thing that
could result in behavior.
>> What I mean they raped me. Oh my god.
That's not what I said. So so
performative and lame.
>> Let me rephrase this. Let me rephrase
this in a more reasonable human way. No,
your statement was ridiculous. Does
Denims know that if she watches a video
saying that Ethan's children are
potentially dying from diseases of
negligence?
>> Is she aware that someone was is going
to call CPS? Is is the question, right?
>> Do you think that she's Do you think
that she knows that that's like on the
table that she could be pushing people
in that direction?
>> I don't know. Do you know what's on the
table that when you dox people, they
might get [__] killed and hurt?
>> Kill possible. I think it's very very Is
it is it on the table in the same way?
Is it on the table in the same way?
>> In the Yeah, I would say I would say in
a way, but the intent the respon I'm
doing this as a response and um what
Cathy I believe.
>> Okay. Are we talking about recklessness
or negligence? Because it's not a
question of if she knows. It's a
question of if she should know.
>> All right. Reck recklessness is about if
you should know that what you were doing
is wrong and it happened. That's it. We
don't need to show that she knew it or
that she had had knowledge of it. True.
You know what? You're right. You're
right. Should she have known that if you
do stuff like Well, this is this is what
I was hinting at earlier when I said we
should agree then that she should have a
full-time caretaker and shouldn't be
allowed to stream anymore if she because
if you don't have certain levels of
agency, then you don't get certain
rights and responsibilities, right? Or
privileges.
>> So, should Dennis have known that this
is a possibility?
>> That that it's a possibility. That is to
say, it's that it's likely that as a
result of her watching this video,
someone will um you know, do the actual
CPS call.
>> Yeah. or that she's at least increasing
significantly the odds that somebody
will do this.
>> I think that she should know that she's
given the size of her stream that she is
significantly increasing the risk. The
problem is I do think it's a small risk
and unfortunately um you're going to
>> it might be a small risk like just like
stepping on a steak would be before
serving it to a customer.
>> Yeah. It's not a significant increase
but it's a small risk of something bad.
It's not they're probably they're not
gonna
Well, hang on.
>> But this is a malicious so let's do it.
Let's let's let's use that example. Step
on a steak. Right. I agree. Not good.
Right. The person, so it's a prank and
they're stepping on the steak because
these they're like rude to the service
or whatever. Step on the steak.
>> They get a parasite and die. Okay. Holy
[__] And and all of the [__] servers
are looking around themselves and
they're like, "What the fuck?" And the
guy who did the stepping raises his hand
and he's like,
>> "Hi." And then the question is in that
moment, you agree low risk of really,
really, really, really bad event. It
happened. All right.
>> Mhm. How do you assess that person their
culpability right now? It was absolutely
the culpable for them to do that conduct
but in reality the risk of the result
happening was in absolute terms low.
That's the comparison I'm trying to
make.
>> Yes. But the thing you keep missing is
that the we tie our moral culpability
that you have for failing your moral
responsibilities, your moral
obligations, your professional
obligations. We tie the harm that
results from the worst cases of people
not following these responsibilities to
the failure to follow the
responsibility. That's why when you get
a DUI, you're getting it's a big charge.
But why anybody you can drive home from
wherever and not hurt a single soul? Why
you get a DUI? You might not even break
any traffic laws.
>> I I I totally agree that we should be
like that there are certain reckless
conduct that are felonies, right?
Manslaughter is not like a minor thing.
Manslaughter is a felony. All right. So
there are absolutely states of mind that
are reckless that um we there are some
things that you could do that are
reckless that are worse than other
things you could do that are
intentional. Right? I would say that in
intentionally trying to pickpocket
someone is um better than drunk driving.
Right? Now in the case of the
intentional
>> action real quick funnily enough those
things tie into where you have the
greatest level of obligation, where you
have the greatest level of
responsibility. the greater the
responsibility, the greater the
obligation, probably the greater moral
uh fault by not following set.
>> So, so then maybe maybe you would maybe
you would understand why when I'm
talking to Hutch, I'm bringing up things
like risk. Is this a significant risk?
Is this an insignificant risk?
>> Oh [__] guys. Goal is about to end.
Goal is about to end. Now's a great time
to chill. 380 people here right now.
110 likes on stream. So there's 270
people. Please move us a thumbs up and
click it or pressing thumbs up on the
mobile device. That would be
appreciated. If you want to take your
support one step further, you can donate
directly through a stream on link in the
pin chat message. You can also buy a
membership the channel gift to
membership the channel. Gift or a bunch
of memberships only chat. Buy a super
chat which highlight your message and
read on TTS or buy a super sticker which
YouTube image or gift. There'll be high
in chat that'll describe it to you. You
can go to
discord.gg/creamingman.com/squeman.
Thank you. Thank you. Thank you.
Wrong. When you get a DUI, you don't
sentence someone for murder. You mean
manslaughter, I think. But we specific
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. We don't specifically
don't hold people responsible for its
Yes,
that's correct. Yes. That's Pisco's
point. Destiny is saying
we have strong sentences for DUIs
because the worst case scenario is so
bad. That's correct.
But just because the worst case scenario
is so bad, that doesn't mean that when
you commit the failure of
responsibilities, you are held
responsible for the worst possible
outcome. The worst possible outcome is
like a man's sort of charge, right?
That's the worst possible outcome. But
you aren't given a man sort of charge.
You aren't given the equivalent of a
man's sort of charge. You were given a
DUI charge. And the DUI charge is strong
because we are aware of the potential
negative outcomes. But you are not held
responsible for manslaughter.
>> But instead of you saying, "Huh?" and
trying to think maybe maybe Pisco is
getting at something here. Maybe it's
actually relevant to talk about the
amount of risk and that will play into
how we factor about the ethical
obligations. You took that as yet
another slimy debate tactic. But of
course, the amount of risk bears on the
ethical question.
>> It's not about the It's not about the
amount of risk. It's about the amount of
unnecessary risk and especially the
intentionality of the violation of the
obligation. Even if you know like I
could right now give like orders to my
chat to go and kill some [__] person
and chances are of anybody following
through is probably less than 0.00001%.
But just the fact that you could issue
the order like that really because
that's a huge failure of a massive
obligation HAS A SHE HAS OBLIGATION to
the chat to not be engaging behavior is
going to get people swattered or CPS
call. Let let me give you a perfect
example. I think sandwich thrower, you
know the sandwich thrower, he got let
off. All right, whatever. But the
sandwich thrower, he threw something at
ICE or National Guard or whatever. And
let's say that he's throwing that
sandwich with the intent to kill the
[__] guy. All right, and you can
prove that he threw that. Now, he's like
a diluted [__] or he is like so
incompetent that he has no comprehension
that his sandwich has exactly zero
chance of killing this person. He does
it anyway. I'm going to treat that
person as like an attempted murderer.
Okay. So, and or at a bare minimum, it's
going to be some significant significant
penalty. Yeah, you didn't have a gun
there, but the only reason you didn't
weren't successful in killing them is
because you're a stupid person that
tried to use a a sandwich because you
had like some notion that they might be
allergic to something or whatever. So, I
absolutely take the view that
intentional conduct I am an intention
cuck. I I I've said it always that
intention to me is the most important
thing. That is why that is why I was
making this point. So absolutely, if you
could show that Denim's conscious object
was to make the CPS call happen, I think
that that's a lot easier case than the
kind of statements that have been shown.
Those statements absolutely downplaying
those statements absolutely
unjustifiable. Those in the same way, by
the way, I think that some of your jokes
and other people's jokes sometimes are
unjustified. I'm not saying that they're
the same thing. I'm not saying they're
the exact same thing, but I will take
issue with
>> the outright cause for violence, which
outright does call for violence. certain
things, but like I don't think when
you're calling uh you know making
certain jokes about Cory Compatur,
making certain jokes about victims, I
don't think that you want them to die,
right?
>> Okay. There are other cases where he
literally says he does. So
>> would defend you and I have defended
people like uh who Rob Moore who have
accused you of saying that you want
Republicans to die, right? You don't
want Republicans to die, do you?
>> Hello.
>> No, but what's the difference?
>> The the difference is it's not your
conscious object to make them die. Now,
someone might look at your conduct and
say,
>> "No, no,
We're also not if if somebody called CPS
on
>> and like Denims and Casey and all them.
It's hard to separate cuz these
communities are so [__] toxic. But if
they just laughed at that fact,
>> then it would be gross, disgusting, or
whatever.
>> But let's say that again to make the the
reason why your analogies are so mind
[__] the dad and the daughter one was
a good example too, is because you're
you're erasing the part where they are
watching something that is driving the
behavior. If I was watching video after
video, if I was talking about like this
is one reason why I don't do even though
I like guns, I don't tell people guys we
need to get armed, we need to start
training. I think somebody asked me this
two weeks ago like should we start
arming and training? Like that increases
the risk of a whole bunch of bad [__] I
don't I usually don't push I don't think
I ever push people in this direction.
But like if we were watching videos on
like best ways to assassinate
conservatives, best ways to um intervene
so 911 can't get to people. I was
watching and then a conservative got
shot and killed and then I started
laughing and making jokes about it. Like
would you not look at me and go like are
you like hoping that somebody in your
comm would you not look at me and even
if I
>> I would treat you different listen I I
would treat you differently if that
versus current facts all right so I'm
just giving you what you want I
absolutely I would I would treat
I think the Hutch I think yeah but I
think Hutch would also do differently as
well right so Hutch is somebody who's
very critical of my jokes and all this
[__] because he's a soy [__] liberal
whatever that's fine okay he's critical
but I think I could be wrong but I think
that Hutch would have a much more
negative view of me if I was in my chat
saying like Okay guys, how are we
getting the next conservative? Like
let's theory craft like what are some s
what are the best guns, the best
loadouts,
it would be way way way way worse. But
the thing is like I I agree that to the
extent that um there's no faciciousness
there um because there's there's edgy
jokes and there's kind of like ambiguous
things, right? He literally did he not
literally
>> when he was fighting with Ethan, he went
into his chat and started linking either
scopes or silences while talking about
it.
He literally so he literally did do like
the exact thing he's describing here. We
want to avoid the situation where it's
just like obvious conspiracy or obvious
attempt, right? And so we're putting out
that window. So you're giving a kind of
example where it's on the margin and
it's unclear whether it's a joke, right?
Cuz if it's very clearly a joke, then
even the pre-jo conduct, you're not
really going to you're not going to say
that there's like major culpability
there, right? In in the sense of moral
fault. Maybe it's reckless to do those
jokes, but I mean, you'd be on no
different terms than what the
Republicans are accusing you of. Now, I
disagree with their assessments of
>> No, I disagree. I would say there is
major moral fault. Yes. And when we talk
when we talk about
>> Yes. When we talk about like negligence
or or rather I'm sorry when you talk
about recklessness that's why there was
that clip I sent you earlier. That's why
when I see my chat saying some [__] up
[__] I don't wait I don't just stop
talking about it or I don't just like
change a little bit the way I talk about
it. I will very clearly say hey don't
[__] kill people even Nazis even
fascist women.
>> Oh yeah. Yeah. He's always Yeah. He's
always saying that like when he said you
could just fight Assan in real life or
when he was saying you should me and Mr.
and Jen. Oh, when he said, you know,
that he was getting a silence or a scope
for Ethan. Yeah, right. That's that's
He's always just like, that's destiny,
guys. Calm down the language. Calm down
language. Killing's not okay. That's
destiny, guys.
>> Kill people for differences of political
opinion in the United States. We don't
do that here, right? It's not There's no
[__] guess work there. Unless you
say, there's no guesswork.
>> No, I I mean, like I understand that
there are distinctions between different
kinds of conduct that could be an issue.
and the examples that you're providing
again these are uh distinctions that I
think do matter in terms of how we
assess the the relative risk of them.
The only thing I'm saying is that
someone pointing to an increase in risk,
an awareness of risk, right? You would
grant that like you calling these people
fascists, you calling these people, you
know, uh, [__] crazy people who want
to take over the country that does
increase the risk, right? It's mitigated
by some of the things that you're
saying, right? But you're not
>> It can't increase the risk. I accept all
the increase of risk as long as my
analysis is accurate and my positions
have been have been made clear. If it's
the and if and if it's the case if it's
the case that um for example you made
everything you said but you didn't have
the condemnations of violence let's say
and someone ends up you know killing
someone else you're going to perhaps
take responsibility culpability for
failure to moderate maybe if there's
enough of a like of a showing that
there's a causal connection between you
and what actually occurred in terms of
they came from your community and maybe
they're directly linking uh what you say
to why they did it. Maybe you would
imply even some like negligent or
reckless culpability um with respect to
the completed act itself or that result.
But
>> I guess but I I want to break just real
quick because you keep getting really
hung up on this causal chain. I don't
care about necessarily the causal chain.
I care about the factors and if there
would be like if they would transfer or
not. So for instance, let's say somebody
killed somebody and like you said, they
mentioned things you said, but let's say
they didn't. But let's say that all of
them they killed somebody and let's say
that they did a whole manifesto and they
pointed out a whole bunch of stuff that
Josiah said, right? I think that we're
pretty in alignment on a lot of things,
right? And I say that I say a lot of
similar things. I would start to I would
Well, I mean, it's hard because I don't
think me or necessarily encourage
violence. Um, but
>> that's the Republicans characterization.
Now, I again, I'm not adopting that
character.
>> Sure. No, no, hold on. I'm not Well, I'm
not because that characterization is
just not true. The facts are different.
But like, let's say that me and Josiah
were really on this like Merlin needs to
go like actually somebody's got to find
this guy and take him out and blah And
then let's say that I kind of say it and
Josiah says it and then somebody does
this manifesto and they said this thing
even though they didn't they weren't
from my community and me they might have
even said like I've never I'm not
subscribed to anybody but Josiah I would
feel a level of like okay guys we don't
do this right cuz I see how it
contributes to that but that would be
like an outcome that I cuz I don't want
people killing people for their for just
a difference of political opinions. I
want to make that known but that's not
going to prevent me from doing an
accurate political analysis. People
might kill people because they're trans
or because they're fascists or because
they're whatever else.
>> If if they've got a difference in
political opinion and they say really
mean things about Destiny online, that
is enough actually. That is enough.
>> I got to stop doing an accurate
analysis. Make sure people know where I
stand. Yes.
>> And and if there's a person who keeps on
promoting antivaxism by talking about
his personal situation and keeps on, you
know, uh you know, talking about how
he's been um [__] over by CPS calls,
unfortunate CPS calls. You might
continue to say, "Don't call CPS." But
you're going to continue covering his
content and saying, "Hey, like this is
dangerous. Like the antivaxer is wrong."
And all the examples of his own kid's
health, they're not right. You're going
to see the risk.
>> A prolonged bingo bango at the top of
his lungs as he's busting and heaving on
top of Joanna.
>> Can you just not say insane [__] like
that, please? What the [__] MAN?
>> RIGHT. IT'S ALREADY HAPPENED. The CPS
call for the the vaccines in my
hypothetical, they've already happened.
You put out a statement that says, "I
don't want you to call CPS. I would
never call CPS. Don't do it." But you're
not going to stop doing the thing that
will increase the risk in that context.
Fair
>> that you're going to keep calling out
the antivaxer even though they have the
CPS call and it already happened. It's
been
>> demonstrated donation.
>> I mean like
it's going to vary from example to but
like there
>> there are worlds where I will moderate
the unfortunately
Really? There's no way. There's no way.
No. No. Don't buy this.
>> Absolutely is. No, I absolutely do
because especially because my community
is 9010 men and a lot of the communities
that for politicals are 9010 men. There
are a lot of criticisms that I don't
necessarily lean into as hard on when it
comes to certain dating things or women
things or whatever the [__] because I
know that the community will take it a
certain way. Or back back in the gaming
days, I think there was a lot of really
cringe like booby streamer whatever
[__] And but like if I make any of
these comments known publicly, there's
90 million [__] incels in my comments
that are like alongside me. no matter
how much I hedge and no matter how much
I try to like cut that [__] off, they're
always going to show up and weaponize
those arguments. So, at some point I'm
like, "Fuck it. I don't I don't think I
will." Unfortunately, I I think even in
that sense, but I but I would I would
say that maybe that's going too far or I
just for whatever reason, I don't
necessarily need to do that. But you
acknowledge we're like levels and levels
and levels away from Denim's behavior.
>> Well, I I mean like I don't know, man. I
think that it's not a big risk. These
kinds of like reactions to all else
equal, they don't seem very risky. And
you can show me evidence.
>> It's not about risk. It's about intent.
Is there a single time? I'm just
curious. Is there a single time where
Denim says, "Seriously, guys, the CPS
stuff, we don't do this. This is not
cool."
>> Yeah, she has said that. Yeah,
>> I that's what was that's what I thought
I that's what I remember seeing. So, I'm
just saying I remember seeing something
like that. I just don't And this isn't
me being Weasly. I don't have instant
recall of this the condemnation that was
there. I thought I remember seeing that.
>> Earlier you were saying things like,
"Well, you need to be able to justify
your assertions." No, no, no, but my
assertion isn't my assertion isn't that
I know her conduct to uh you know to be
a thing or not. I I'm just saying what
I've been seeing so far doesn't justify
the lawsuits. That's a separate we
haven't even reached that. But all I'm
trying to say is regardless of your
thoughts about this and you seem to take
a view which I mean I guess is like more
protective of your or sorry more
responsible for your community. And in
some ways I think that's in line with
stuff you said before. In some ways I
think people could argue that it's maybe
inconsistent, but I'm not going to get
into that right now. Regardless of your
thoughts about who's right here, do you
actually get the cold bill in the way
that, you know, Stephen says or in the
way I say this is an honest
disagreement. It's not that I want to
promote Hassan.
>> Apology and retraction.
>> Or at least
>> maybe she should think about issuing an
apology and retraction.
>> Or at least saying calling CPS is
[__] crazy. Don't do it.
>> Is it that hard? Oh, no. What she she
does kind of she goes
>> after being like Ethan's the worst
person in the world and like yeah, his
kid watching bad. I'll be like, "Yeah,
his kids crawl around and eat shit." And
her whole entire chat being like, "Call
CPS." But she like, "Obviously, don't
call CPS." It's like, "Yeah, right."
>> So, even
Ethan acknowledges
>> and he had said this.
>> Oh, it seems like you're in love with
your dog.
>> Showing up to your house at night, going
through all your things, accusing you of
crimes,
>> be cleaning your hand. After I put him
down, I watched him again.
>> Four is the cut off.
>> Showing up to your house at night, going
through all your things, accusing you of
crimes you didn't do. No one should be
subjected to such treatment.
>> Sure, but we're talking about not cops
showing up at your house. We're talking
about CPS, which anyways, to begin with,
one I don't condone. I've never two I've
never condoneed it and you will not be
able to find a clip of me saying yes, we
should do this because it doesn't exist.
I think CPS should be exclusively used
for family vloggers who are total
[__] pieces of [__] that use their
kids as content. I've literally given
Ethan Klein credit on multiple times or
multiple instances and I will do it
again right now for not showing photos
of his kids. I think it is actually very
cool of him to try his best to not have
his kids in photos in videos. I respect
that a lot. I I think he's he's a piece
of [__] and I think he's going insane
and he's crazy, but I respect a lot that
he doesn't bring his kids on camera and
use them for content
>> is on her platform right now.
>> Curious, huh? Curious. Interesting.
on it's your thoughts about this and you
seem to take a view which I mean I guess
all call of this the kinds of like
reactions to all else equal they don't
seem very risky and you can show me
evidence of
>> it's not about risk it's about intent is
there a single time I'm just curious and
maybe is there a single time where denim
says seriously guys the CPS stuff we
don't do this it's not cool here
>> I that's what was that's what I thought
I that's what I remember seeing so I'm
just saying I remember seeing something
like that I just don't and this isn't me
being weasly I don't have instant recall
of this the condemnation that was there.
I thought I remember seeing that
>> earlier you were saying things like well
you
>> so that that was totally there. So
Denims did say she didn't condone it.
She was very clear. She didn't condone
it. She actually thinks that broadly
compared to a lot of parents online
Ethan's more responsible than a lot of
them in terms of how he engaged with the
internet.
So she condemned it. Said she would
never condone it. Never has condoned it.
You'll never find her condoning it.
She actually respects Ethan slightly as
apparent for some of the way you handle
stuff.
What's your problem? What's the [__]
problem?
>> Be able to justify your assertions about
No, but my assertion isn't my assertion
isn't that I know her conduct to uh you
know to be a thing or not. I I'm just
saying what I've been seeing so far
doesn't justify the lawsuits. That's a
separate we haven't even reached that.
But all I'm trying to say is regardless
of your thoughts about this and you seem
to take a view which I mean I guess is
like more protective of your or sorry
more responsible for your community and
in some ways I think that's in line with
stuff you said before. In some ways I
think people could argue that it's maybe
inconsistent but I'm not going to get
into that right now. Regardless of your
thoughts about who's right here, do you
actually get the culability in the way
that you know Stephen says or in the way
I say this is an honest disagreement.
It's not that I want to promote Hassan.
It's not that I want to [__] uh
support snarkers. It's not that I want
to support just still community
statements. Sure. There were statements
that you said yesterday and maybe I
don't know you should you should ask
actually cuz maybe I'm just maybe I
missed this. It truly felt to me like
you said Denims had absolutely zero
culpability for the CPS call. She might
have small culpability just for not
moderating her chat for some weird
reason that was never articulated that
well to me. I didn't feel like denims
like you felt that denims or Casey
Turner or any of these people that they
had any moral culpability for the
>> replacing the call what I meant by that
>> for the call happening for the call
happening.
>> Okay. So if if I said that that isn't
what I meant to say if I said that I
promise you that's not what I meant to
say. I of course would never deny the
notion of um ethical responsibilities
with respect to non-intentional conduct.
I of course think that you have a
responsibility to moderate your
community. That's why I establish rules.
You know that those rules that I'm
establishing aren't just for to
compliance though. But why do you have
the rules or why do you have that? Yeah.
>> But one aspect and that's why I'm not
like joking when I say this is for
self-p protection that I was just being
honest when I say like
I know but when but so you would
acknowledge like the one of the first
rational why I do it is to protect
myself to make sure that no one can make
the accusation that I'm not doing
anything because and then I
We're asking for the morals.
>> No, but but hang on a second. I think
that pro protecting yourself from things
that where you don't intend it. That
actually is an ethical obligation you
have to yourself. I think you can have
ethical obligations to themselves.
>> Nobody thinks like this.
>> Okay. Nobody. I [__] do. But my point
is my point is that that is not
indication of bad faith.
>> Just to be clear, just to be clear, you
do not think like this. If somebody were
to ask you why or maybe you can buy the
bonus. If somebody say why shouldn't you
rape somebody would you say as part of
the first thing you say well you don't
want to get arrested right
>> okay in that example no I wouldn't in
that example I would lead with the harm
done to others that okay but I can't
explain to you why my mind in one
situation comes up with the rationale
for something first or another and I'm
asking you please don't think what she
did have no no so you're saying that
because the first thing that comes in my
head
>> the thing is it's very easy then because
in the It's like moderating your
community. It's like how much action are
you going to take to prevent other
people from doing crazy [__] that could
bounce back onto you?
And so that's not immediately obvious.
Like you Yeah, there there is a self
protection rationale. Obviously, when
you're talking about raping someone,
you're like suggesting someone takes an
affirmative like aggressive act action.
Just obviously the first thing jumps to
your mind is like, well, what's this
going to do? Yeah. Legit. It's just
immediate rape analogies with this guy.
It's all just rape or anal sex analogies
with with this guy.
>> Reading into that to say that I'm trying
to protect Denims from her.
>> Okay. And the evidence is that because
if I didn't, I would have brought up the
other the harm and potential risk to
others even though I acknowledge that
before that statement is made. I
acknowledge the risk factor. That's
what's so absurd about this whole thing
is the notion that I was ever uh
establishing the the or my view that
like somehow there are no norms in
moderation. that there are no such
things as obligations with respect to uh
negligent or reckless conduct. It's just
bizarre that you think that I would have
thought that and that you didn't hear me
making this point. Maybe I didn't do it
as clearly, whatever. But I'm asking
people to have some amount of grace in
when I'm making these arguments and I'm
not going out there to say the only
thing that's ever bad are things that
are intentional. I mean, do you really
think I thought that?
>> No. That's why
I felt like that was the only answer you
gave.
Okay.
>> Can somebody link me the clip? I really
want to I wish I could remember the
exact word you used. It was like when
there's a when there's like a
non-trivial hurdle to moderation.
>> So, this is what I recall. So, what I
recall was uh Hutch asked a question
like, "Do you have a duty to moderate uh
when people basically say um to call
CPS, right?" And I I thought about it
for a little bit. I'm like, I think that
you should moderate calls for CPS. I do
agree with that. But I'll ask you, do
you think you should moderate when
>> No, no, hold on. I just want to be
clear. We can say this, but I just want
to be clear. That's not what I was
referring to. who gave an answer that
was the most
>> syntactically crafty answer I've ever
heard to avoid committing yourself to
any sort of moral obligation that was
essentially just saying that like as
long as it's not a big deal or not too
difficult, you should moderate bad [__]
so that you don't get banned. That was
that was the the substance of your
answer. I if somebody finds a clip of it
later, but we move on to the next thing.
Go ahead.
>> Okay. I I mean like what I'm trying to
do is essentially these accusations are
made that I'm adopting arguments that I
don't really believe that I'm being
influenced into becoming um you know one
thing or the other that I'm specifically
with bad intent trying to do one thing
and listen you all can have the opinion
that you want. What I want to say though
is it's totally unjustified. I have been
a lib capitalist through and through.
I'm on a show called No because you say
that I'm appealing to tanky audiences.
That's what you say to your audience. So
where's where's the responsibility for
that? Where's the responsibility for
that?
>> Your statement here, your statement here
doesn't do anything to vindicate you,
right? Of course you're going to say
that you don't do these things. It
doesn't mean anything, right?
>> But no, but what's but but do you
believe that I'm trying to appeal to
starters? You believe it?
>> Yes.
>> Okay. And that's based on your on your
divine revelation.
>> Well, it's based on the unfathomable
logic that you employ.
>> I just explained it. But I just
explained it. Do you not believe the my
explanation? I mean, this doesn't seem
like what I
>> Well, wait. I'm curious. Well, can you
tell me because I didn't remember
hearing an answer at all yesterday. It
was low cost of compliance. That was the
phrase you
>> Yes, dude. Alex Neville's video out.
>> Wait, dude. Alex Neville's video is out.
>> Look, guys. He used it in his his video,
I think.
That's funny, man.
>> Why is it bad? Yeah. Why do you have a
duty to moderate your channel?
>> So, a duty of reasonable care, which is
what negligence is is um sort of
>> we'll do the Alex No video as a main
segment tomorrow. I think
>> the reasonleness relates both to the
sense of the risk and the cost of
mitigation. All right. So, there are
things that you can always do to reduce
risk. All right? you could uh pad
yourself up in a million different
pillows and walk through and like make
sure
when I said cost when I said cost of
compliance when I say compliance cost
there you might not believe me but
explicitly what I'm invoking is the
notion that part of the assessment of
what constitutes reasonable risk relates
to how much it costs for a person like
you would never say that denim's at the
start of a stream say I condemn this I
condemn that I condemn Hassan I condemn
uh banana I can like you would never say
that she has to run through a thousand
trillion throat clearers and it's an
infinite amount of things, right?
>> Well, here wait. Can you I'm just
curious. Can you watch somebody like
this? This is where you get this answer.
Okay. Just see if it's
>> Is Kafka still in here?
>> I am. Yes.
>> Okay. Here. Pass this along.
>> What is the point of moderation then?
>> I can hear it. So, I just want to make
sure.
>> Can you answer that question?
>> I will.
>> Yes, I heard you. Yes, I heard you.
What's the point of what's the point of
moderation? mo there's self-standing
obligations to moderate uh to reduce
risk that you know a streamer I think
has it's where it's there's a low cost
of compliance and where there are
obvious potential uh you know benefits
to a lowcost compliance incident the
fact that you have a self-standing
obligation to mitigate risk I'm going to
repeat it and make sure you hear it so
I'm going to say it twice that you
violated your duty to moderate
>> does not mean you are culpable for
actions that underly
Yeah, that's very consistent with what I
just said.
>> Okay. So, you said that
something about like if a stream if the
action has a um the risk a streamer
faces has a low cost of compliance and
there's an obvious benefit to the low
cost of compliance, there's a
self-standing obligation to mitigate
risk.
>> Yeah. What risk are you talking about?
>> So, so the risk relates to the uh
likelihood that some crazy person is
going to do something crazy.
>> Okay. Wait, if there if you why would
you have an obligation to mitigate that
risk but then not be culpable for the
actions that happen if you fail to
moderate that risk if there's no
culpability because right afterwards you
said you're not cable for any of the
actions that underly the risk.
>> It depends what you mean by culpable. So
when I use copable in that sense it
relates to an ethical violation not to
the result independent of itself. If you
say
>> it is an ethical violation though,
right? If you fail,
you obligation to moderate if a bad
thing happens.
>> What I'm referencing though is when it
comes to culpability isn't the result in
and of itself. It's uh the act by which
I mean the intentional voluitional
malicious act. That's what you're not
culpable for. When I'm talking about
culpability, it isn't a kind of naked
result. It's culpable with respect to
not just an outcome, but the state of
mind and the improper moral fault.
That's what I'm talking about with
respect to culpability.
>> Okay. I just want to ask okay then I
just want to ask for this okay when
Hutch said that you are culpable for
what a person does do you think that
Hutch literally meant let's say that you
say something and a person goes on
first-degree murder somebody do you
think that Hutch means in actuality that
a transubstantiation occurred and your
body morphed into place other person you
also are guilty of the crime of
first-degree murder that you did the
exact same thing do you think that's
what
>> I think he means I think he means moral
fault right
>> correct that is proportional to the
potential bad outcome have an obl
obligation to prevent the risk.
>> Hang on, hang on. M moral fault with
respect to a moral obligation. Correct.
>> Yes. But the moral obligation is tied to
the potential risk.
>> Sure. No, no, no, no. But but it doesn't
exist independent of the mindset. That's
what I'm saying. The moral obligation
exists not just in the result, but in
the actual it must by necessity include
the state of mind. Otherwise, it might
not even be a moral obligation. Right.
You don't have a moral obligation
independent of the state of mind. Right.
So So that's what I meant. That's what I
meant.
>> You said it might. Sure. But you said it
might exist out there somewhere. I'm
glad you clarified. You said it might
exist out there somewhere. But can you
honestly recall off the top of your
head, I'm not gonna push you for clips
like you did. Okay.
>> Like you did for me earlier. Can you
honestly recall a time where Denims was
sincerely and act and and deliberately
talking to her chat and intentionally
saying like, "Guys, we don't engage in
this type of behavior. Like we're not
doing this here."
>> Um I don't I remember the one time where
she after it happened where she said um
you know, I never called it and it's not
good. That's what I recall. I don't
remember the exact word she used. I
don't remember
>> called it and it's not good.
>> I don't remember. I'm telling you right
now that I remember she I thought that
she condemned it and I thought I saw
that clip. It's possible that it's more
Weasly language. I'm not saying that
that's not true. That's what I
>> Wait. And you know what? I'll grant
Let's tell Grant all that. Okay. If that
clip didn't exist or if it only came
after a ton of public backlash or
lawsuit threat or whatever else, if it
came like two months ago. Okay.
>> Not enough for intentional militias. No.
>> Sure. Would that Wait, wait. Would it
change your mind for the um
recklessness?
>> No, because I've already granted that.
>> Oh, wait. So, you've granted that her
behavior is you agree that it was
already the reckless thing.
>> Yeah.
>> Does Okay, then I won't even bother to
argue higher higher standard. Why
doesn't recklessness grant some moral
culpability to the person who engaged in
the reckless behavior?
>> Yes. I That was our whole conversation.
You missed
over the same points again and again. It
feels like
>> she's culpable for the things she
actually did
>> without the things she didn't do.
>> Do not for see that when I said that
>> for the things that result from those
things.
>> But you just you're just not
understanding what I mean by culpable.
What I mean by culpable isn't indexed to
just the result by itself. When I say
culpable, it includes some notion of
moral fault which is indexed to a state
of mind. You don't have I'll just say
it. You don't have
>> But the moral fault is also indexed to
the potential harms that result from the
failure to the obligation.
>> No, no, no. I agree. I no I I agree that
it it's related to the relative risk and
the harm. That's why I was bringing up
those concepts with Hutch and that's why
it shows that I'm good faith because I'm
I'm aware of the different issues when
it comes to issues of causality. I
brought up proximate causation in the
context of uh where things break the
causal chain. So yes, I'm I'm aware of
these concepts. I'm deploying them in
the conversation. Maybe I'm not as clear
as possible, but it is like if a person
but this is what this is why Okay, I'm
going to explain this with a doctor
thing and tell me if I'm not
understanding or if I'm stating it
accurately. And I'll just say nobody
understands what you send me this. Okay.
A doctor decides to never wash his hands
or do anything and he goes in to perform
surgery on a person. Okay, we all I
believe I don't know the [__] rules.
My guess is doctors probably have to
scrub in before they go into a O
operating room, whatever. Right? Doctor
doesn't do this. Patient ends up dying
because of a secondary infection. Okay?
Or because of some primary infection,
whatever. Right? If that would happen,
we would say that the doctor, he had a
moral and professional oblig and legal
obligation to scrub in. He failed that
obligation. When you fail that
obligation, the moral failing is seen as
accepting the consequences of all the
things potential that could result in
the failure to adhere to that
obligation. In the specific scenario
where a patient died, he has some moral
obligation there where the of the for
the death of the patient just like
Dennis would have a moral obligation
there
>> to the extent of state of mind to the
extent of the moral violation. That's
what she would say. The recklessness
state of mind is enough to say that she
didn't adhere to her her obligations,
her professional obligations to her chat
that she should have.
>> But I'm telling you now for the maybe
the 10th time I grant that and did in
the conversation.
>> Do you understand that?
>> Okay. Then the final thing I guess so
then what do you disagree? Do you think
your biggest disagreement with Hutch is
on this particular topic?
>> The disagreement is people are
conflating the degree of her desire. In
other words, they are overstating the
evidence. They are stating that it it
was Denim's conscious object to bring
about the result of the CPS call and
that is not the evidence that I have
seen has not shown that it is weak on
that. And so what I am addressing is
this notion because there's one thing
you could say if oh the community was
reckless they didn't moderate and this
is a risk that they should have
mitigated by just by by signaling that
this is not okay by pushing back when
possible. Absolutely. People will say
that that's at fault. We have we didn't
>> they use this so they fudge this. They
try and fudge the evidence to make it
sound like it was intentional malice as
opposed to like a negligent moderation
standard or something because they can
justify in their minds they see it that
they can more easily justify the
lawsuits if it was intentional malice
but they can't just they would feel
absurd justifying it if it was simply
Denims was negligent and there are a
couple of crazy people in the chat.
Obviously that could apply to many many
many many streamers many of which they
like but they feel that is a tighter
standard and narrower standard
to apply it to the intentional malice.
The idea that Dennos had this objective
of causing a CPS interaction
because that then justifies what they
want
that against the the lawsuits and if
there's anything bad
>> way do you think that Hutch do you think
that Hutch was doing that?
I'm I'm not I'm not sure.
>> What was your main disagreement with
Hutch? You had a 7 hour conversation
about what was your main disagreement
with Hutch?
>> I'm not sure. We were trying We spent
most of it trying to to get him to
understand this concept that I was
trying to to show that like I'm not sure
that that what he would say in response
to
>> understand what concept
>> the concept that one's ethical oblig
that multiple ethical obligations exist
and each one of them has an index state
of mind and one's violation of one does
not entail the other. That was anyone
who watches that fairly knows that I was
struggling for hours to come to that and
to suggest that there are different um
you know different implications from
that and yet you could say for example
>> well because the struggle was because it
took you a long time to get to the point
that culpability wasn't a binary yes or
no there are contributo negligence or
there are other factors
>> golly [__] and yeah you could say for
example
>> well because the struggle was because it
took you a long time to get to the point
that culpability wasn't a binary yes or
no
so so frustrated at this point. tributo
negligences or there are other factors
at play that um the foreseeability of
certain actions and responsibilities and
other things and Hutch kept saying
things like that like sometimes Hutch
would even say a phrase I don't even
know if he realized this but he was
intuiting when he was saying things like
well didn't he would say like didn't
this contribute to and then you would
switch immediately to like well she's
not culpable for and it took you like
two hours to get to that likeility
isn't the better inference instead that
I think that there's no moral obligation
to ever moderate your chat under any
circumstance that maybe maybe what I'm
saying is for the thing that she's being
accused of by everyone who's who's
saying is that she bears responsibility
not for the the being reckless but for
essentially wanting this to occur
wanting the CPS stuff to occur
>> true because I think that I think there
is plenty of evidence to say that you
would say this is like a depraved heart
constructive intent thing for sure
>> you're going to have to show some I mean
if that's the case then I'm sorry but
like you're going to fall under that
rubric big time and not just for the doc
stuff and I don't think that you deserve
it on that stuff
>> hold on if somebody from my community
showed up because of the docs that I
post in my chat on some of it basically
clarified at the end there on some of it
>> come out and say oh he has absolutely no
has no responsibility for that
>> whatever so I don't think that you would
be so I think that you would have a
fault with respect to recklessly
endangering the health and security of
uh um Jilk but I don't think that anyone
could say that you were culpable for the
intentional assault of Distilk unless
they could prove prove you wanted it.
You
>> I want to preface this video by stating
that I was the only one that reached out
to everyone involved in this story and
that the victims weren't just used by
Destiny, but by YouTubers trying to
frame themselves as heroes. One of them
is still lying about what he did. Now,
I'm not going to pretend that I
personally care about the victims
either. I don't know them. However, I do
have the basic human decency to not try
and sabotage them. I pride myself on
doing
Since my last Destiny video, a lot has
changed. We have a court document from
Pixie's legal team alleging that he was
deleting evidence, specifically messages
with multiple women who have claimed
that he shared sex videos with them
without the participants consent. So he
wasn't just sharing videos with Rose, he
was sending it to who then told Pix
>> would have said like even if that
wouldn't have been sent to I do feel
>> much of his feel like manifesto for the
pedo allegations as well as converse
with people from his past. This is the
Destiny manifesto for those DMs about
you saying like, "Hey, I wish this
person has this person been doxed yet."
>> Yeah. I um for Anna, that's [__]
For just like Queen, I'd kill him if I
could. I'd choke the house into it, bro.
I swear to God, if I quit streaming, I'm
going to go on an assassination mission.
Okay. People are going to start
disappearing one at a time. Okay.
>> That's why this video is sponsored by
>> agree with that, don't you?
>> How do you like we like we pro if we
could prove it like that? Like if you
made statements like that,
tons circumstantial evidence.
Circumstantial evidence. Any kind of
evidence that you that any kind of
evidence of of you guys planning for it.
Any kind of evidence of you guys
>> That's not circumstant. That's like
you're talking about direct evidence.
You're talking about a confession
argument. Yeah. What would be
>> No, no, no, no. That's not the case.
What I'm saying is not that you only
need confessions to get to intent. All
right. That is not at all the case. Um,
for example, if you drew a map to his
particular address, right? Do you think
that that would show that would tend to
show more intent? Wait, if you show
frustration
>> if you say something like, "Oh, it
doesn't look like uh, you know, guns are
allowed in wherever he is, right? If if
you said that, if you that's not a
direct confession, but it's the kind of
conduct that shows that you don't really
care about the hell."
>> Unfortunat for Fortunately, we have a a
direct confession. Has this person been
doxed yet?
>> Yeah, I um for Anna that's [__] For
just Queenman, I'd kill him if I could.
I'd choke the house into it. Bro, I
swear to God if I quit streaming, I'm
going to go on an assassination mission.
Okay, people are going to start
disappearing one at a time. Okay,
>> that's why this video was health or
safety. Maybe if you uh if you started
saying things like um they should be
killed.
>> Okay,
>> I won't play again.
>> Well, that seems basically a direct
confession is almost what you're saying.
But like what if you were to say
statements like well under four years
old children don't even form memories.
Or what if you were saying statements
like well if you're getting diseases as
a child that you get as an adult that's
basically life-threatening.
Well, one one I kind of view as uh as
downplaying, right? The first one is
like, "Oh, this not a big deal, right?"
And I understand they're different, but
if like Tim P got mad that someone So,
let me give you an example, right? So,
there have been people where you have
justified a docs because someone put
your location, right? Someone put your
location live on Twitter and you b your
response. I I recall this. You remember
this?
>> Justified a doc and said, "You should
contact our school." Yep.
>> Basically like you're asking for me to
be killed, right? You're asking for me
to be hurt. People get killed, right?
remember that whole
>> depending on depending on how you do
people. Yeah. Sure.
>> All right. And so um I I think it really
does depend on so in that instance um I
think that you could make a case right
you could make a case that if your
intention is a particular thing or the
kinds of evidence that we would bring to
bear in those situations might be
different.
>> Can I ask
can I ask something please? Do you
accept evidence of an admission by
omission? Like
>> there are things where she is in a
position where she could make a
statement, where she could get in the
way of potential CPS calls, of people
making these plans in her chat. She has
the ability to see it, has the ability
to get in the way and say, "Guys, we
don't do it." Because right now, I've
only seen a disavow from her after
everything has happened, right?
>> What was the disavowel? I there was
there was some video that someone shared
that showed her saying like, "Guys, I
never condoned the CPS thing." Uh, which
again is like after all wait a vowel
though. That's not a disavow, though.
>> Well, isn't it? I'm being
>> What would it be? What else would it be?
>> That's a It's a It's a It's an It's an
attempt to avoid like direct like to
responsibility,
>> right?
>> So, you think she should have said I
did? Wait, she should have said I did
condone it. Or what would you say? Are
you saying I They shouldn't do this.
It's not they shouldn't do this. It's
saying I didn't do it. Right.
>> You should make a more positive
statement of like I don't want this
behavior in my community. We are
>> She already said she literally said what
they're asking for, dude. She gave the
the condemnation. We played it. We're
>> not doing this in my community.
>> Think we're going to have like a strong
stance against like
>> also to be clear the correct statement
was I did not condone it, nor did I do
anything to get in the way of it. If
we're because she's just speaking
descriptively at a at this point and
it's like okay, maybe there's no
Did she say that? I didn't hear that
when I just played that clip.
>> Explicit statement of condoning it, but
there's also probably an equal amount of
evidence of you trying to stop it from
happening.
>> I mean, is that the full quote? I mean,
what did she say?
>> Yeah.
I don't know how long this is going to
take, but I'm just I'm linking it to
CFKA. You can send it. I'll just I'm
going to listen to this for
>> I'm 30 seconds. Sometimes doing it.
>> Your house at night going through all
your things, accusing you of crimes you
didn't do.
>> No one should be subjected to such
treatment.
>> Sure, but we're talking about not cops
showing up your house. We're talking
about CPS which anyways to begin with
one I don't condone. I've never I've
never condoned it and you will not be
able to find a clip of me saying yes, we
should do this because it doesn't exist.
I think CPS should be exclusively used
for family vloggers who are total
[__] pieces of [__] that use their
kids as content. I've literally give
Ethan Klein credit on multiple times or
multiple instances and I will do it
again right now for not showing photos
of his kids. I think it is actually very
cool of him to try his best to not have
his kids in photos in videos. I respect
that a lot. I think he's he's a piece of
[__] I think he's going insane and he's
crazy, but I respect a lot that he
doesn't bring his kids on.
>> So unamiguous condemnation, right? Wait,
wait, wait. So is you would agree that's
an unambiguous condemnation?
No, it is literally not I do not
condone.
>> That's not condemnation. What do you
think condemnation? If you were going to
push me, Hold on. Wait, wait, wait,
wait. Just to be clear, I just want to
point out cuz you're doing this again.
It's funny. Okay. Is that earlier
somebody like giggling along and
laughing show? Man, that is seriously
just so [__] embarrassing, bro. Dude,
I'm losing it. I can't take it.
No, that's not ambiguous. I don't
condone that. I've never condoned that.
You will never find a clip of me
condoning that. And actually, one thing
that I really respect about Ethan is the
way he handles his kids online.
No, that's actually really ambiguous. I
can't even tell what she's saying here.
I've got no idea what she's saying here.
She could be saying that you should go
and steal his children from his house
right now.
>> Okay.
>> Didn't count as celebration to you.
Okay. Yeah,
>> it counted as whatever. But now somebody
saying, well, I didn't condone this
behavior.
>> I didn't condone. I don't condone
>> condemnation.
>> It is expressing more. So I understand
condemnation to be um expressing moral
disapproval of an action. Okay, that's
what I understand a condemnation to be.
Do you agree with that?
>> Yeah, but I don't feel like this was I
don't think that's felt like more like,
well, I didn't tell anybody to do it.
So, so you don't think that if someone
says I do not condone assassination or
murder that is not expressing moral
disapproval of a thing?
>> I think it would be in that
circumstance. I think the way that she
uses condone here it sounds like she's
saying I didn't tell anybody to do it.
>> No, one thing would be I didn't say it.
She said I do not presently I do not
condone such things. That is a that is a
way of saying I don't support it. Right.
Isn't that a synonym for saying I do not
support this
>> you didn't do? No one should be
subjected to such.
>> Sure. We're talking about not cops
showing up your house. We're talking
about CPS, which anyways, to begin with,
one I don't condone. I've never
condoneed it. And you will not be able
to find a clip of me saying, "Yes, we
should do this because it doesn't
exist." I think CPS should be
exclusively used for family vloggers who
are total [__] pieces of
>> I I think that when when you're digging
into the whole like, well, I there's no
clip of me saying this and blah blah
blah. It sounds like she's just saying
she didn't tell people to do it.
>> Well, no, but she does say I do not
condone whether you believe it or not,
that is a condemnation.
>> But but I would look to like But I would
it
sure I'll grant that it is it's a
convers. It's a condemnation in in
statement. But then again, the thing
that I would look to is where was the
reaction then to it happening to Chad
doing it? Why does that seem so
inongruent with her statement now?
>> Wait, wait, wait, wait, wait. To chat
doing it, because maybe it's your case
to show that she actually didn't live up
to her standard of care in that either a
um a reasonable person would have seen
those comments and moderated and that
she failed to do so. Um, and that's why
I was [__] going after Hutch in the
sense of asking him, "Well, how do you
know that she disregarded those comments
and saw them?" Because in order to show
moral,
>> a reasonable person wouldn't have seen
any of the Did you pass along the
picture, Kak whatever?
>> Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Yeah. Wait, wait,
wait. So, I I just want you to know. So,
for the first like 10 minutes of this
conversation when I was like uh looking
and thinking and and doing stuff, there
was a bunch of toos potential to
violations of people saying the nword
constantly in kick. Okay. I had to turn
off the chat.
He just
what a menace. What a [__] menace.
Oh man.
Do you think that I condoned and was uh
was like okay with those messages? I
didn't see them. I didn't see them,
right? I didn't see them. And if I had
seen them earlier, I would have done
something. But in order to show that I
endorsed the message, you would have to
show that I saw it, right?
You would have to
>> Yeah, you have to show that I actually
>> Hold on. Hold on. Yeah, but you keep you
you I can't tell if you're doing this
intentionally if you're just that are
leaving this key crucial.
>> No, it's not that's not a hypothetical
that just happened.
>> Wait, wait. You just Wait, no, no, no.
But what you say is like if there are
nwords in your chat and you miss them
for a while and then you um close your
chat, does that mean that you condone
the nwords? Right.
>> Yeah. Well, no, no, no, no. Sorry.
Imagine that I never found out, right?
And I just uh it stopped because
someone, you know, they just stopped,
right?
>> Correct.
>> And someone someone comes up and said,
you know, Pisco is a racist, you know.
Yeah. He he left those. I would say
that's not fair. Yes. Correct. I would
say that's not fair. But what if you
were watching a video beforehand that
was a 10-minute video on why it's so
cool to spam the n-word in YouTube chats
>> and you wanted to look at your chat, you
didn't moderate it. Do you think that
there would be a difference of opinion?
>> Yeah, I think people would have a
difference of opinion, but there
wouldn't be a a problem with moderation.
Be like uh the fact that they're putting
it up there in the first place. It would
be the the kind of the act watching the
video.
>> No, but but but hang on a second. The
problem there is not like that she is
that there's a call for CPS. I
understand that people could justify
calling CPS on the basis of what's said
there, but I don't think that you can do
a onetoone there.
>> Yes, Joe Mack was in East Coast chat
spamming Steven Boner wants to lynch pen
hard as you know.
>> I mean the the active reviewing I think
it's culpable for its own reasons. I've
already said that there's culpability
there and what they did. So, so we don't
need to get there. But like all I'm
saying is the with respect to the
intentionality, that's what's missing
and that's what like maybe you could
make the case a little bit better with
circumstantial evidence if she knows
about it and chooses to disregard it and
chooses not to.
>> Let me Okay, I'm going to do a I'm going
to do a 30,000 foot view of this issue
then. Okay, because here's like the huge
issue and honestly this is the biggest
problem that I have with a lot of these
communities. Do you are you worried at
all that you've set up an environment
where none of these people will ever be
held accountable for basically
encouraging the behavior that they know
exists and that they know is actively
happening as long as they themselves are
smart enough to like never actually come
out and explicitly condone it or
explicitly Yeah. explicitly condone it.
>> Am I worried about that?
>> Yeah.
>> I don't I don't think that I'm respons
so many of these communities are like
snarker adjacent or Kiwi Farms adjacent
and they do this and they know this.
They've got the interflow exchange of
information back and forth. But
obviously the streamers themselves will
never come out and say like I am doxing
this person or I am harassing this
person. We But so like in your mind is
it literally impossible to ever get past
just recklessness basically.
>> No no no no. I I think that there's
there's you can definitely imply
culpability by which I mean moral fault.
I definitely can can can agree to that
and and say that there is a moral fault
there 100%. But and and I will always
like I'm not a literalist. Okay. if
there's enough wink wink nudge nudge
wink wink nudge nudge that I get the
sense that it is their intent like if I
got the sense from the video of um of
Denim's reacting to either e either of
these different things that she actually
wanted the CPS call to occur I would be
treating her as though that was her
conscious object initially and I would
be saying you know high degrees of moral
fault and condemnation I'm just telling
you and maybe that is I'm naive maybe
I'm a grifter whatever you want to say I
do not get that impression I get the
impression someone who is downplaying a
risk. I have the impression of someone
who's culpable for other things.
>> Then I'm curious just looking at example
we both know well. Okay. So then how do
you get to the idea that Donald Trump
wanted people to do an insurrection?
>> Yeah. Uh so circumstantial evidence is
how you get
>> bro it should be so obvious. The Eastman
memo literally everything leading up to
what the [__]
>> to intent. So So uh Trump brought them
all there. brought them all there for a
particular purpose, right? And just to
be clear, intent is needed for
incitement.
>> There is literally every step of the way
he has like this whole set of plans.
It's like, we're going to figure out how
to do this thing. How do I do this
thing? All right. That's how I would do
it. Okay. Well, I'm going to put the
process in place and I'm going to get a
bunch of people in one place and we're
going to go and talk about fighting and
marching. You can draw a [__]
straight line, bro. It's like not hard.
Where is that for denims? you have not
even begin like begun to show that
remotely
>> and for insurrection engaging in an
insurrection. So you need to show
intent. Um it was his conscious object
to steal the election from Joe Biden. So
we know that intent as a at a bare
minimum. No one even really disputes
that intent. He um was failing on all
his other operations uh to try to steal
the election. He sent them over to the
capital knowing that their presence
there was going to result in either
interim uh intimidation by which we mean
uh threats of physical force or um and
and we all agree that they're very
knowing there very conscious and aware
that that he had the mag uh that the
people were armed and he said he didn't
care. Right. We have the evidence from
all of the different reports.
>> Why did he know that?
>> Right. No. Yeah. Yeah. because there's a
substantial and unjustifiable risk with
respect to sending them there. But we
are intuiting his intent based on all
this huge amount of circumstance
evidence. Look what we have here. We
have his knowledge level that they're
armed, his knowledge level that they're
angry, his knowledge level that they're
uh it's the anger is particularized to a
group. The presence there, their
immediate presence right there, the the
clear purpose, a clear objective um to
stop the steel, a clear objective to
prevent the certification, one that's
been explicit and stated that that's the
clear objective. Not just an
observation, not just disposition, but
one where it's their goal, right? The
goal is to stop. And then in addition to
all of that, when it actually happens,
when the violence actually occurs and
when he's told he's told he's he's
updated about the fact that they've
breached the capital, the fact that
they're minutes away from the lawmakers,
this is all in the reports. Um he tweets
out what he does about Mike Pence
condoning what's happening with his
moral support. And so there's a ton of
circumstantial evidence that Trump's
conscious object was to cause the
stopping of the
>> but there's a lot else Well, there's at
least some to say that he wasn't, right?
I know you'll be so what I'm telling you
is that yeah on balance and the mere um
self- serving statements I'm not going
to try to be fooled by those I I I
really won't if I really got the
impression that the apology was you say
like would you say that we're all the
way up to like it's not even like depra
part we're at like 100% intentional
>> intentional 100% intentional
>> okay you have to believe that yeah
otherwise it's like yeah
>> so but then the parallels I'm obviously
drawing here are that like Denims has a
chat gathered they obviously all super
[__] hate Ethan and Ela um you've got
them watching videos claiming that
Ethan's children are basically being
negligently abused and are potentially
dying of these horrible [__] diseases
that Denims goes out of her way to say
could be lethal to children. They
downplay the calling of CPS just like
how MAGA downplays, you know, the actual
ride itself. Like she's doing all of
these things that seem to have easy
parallels. I'm not even asking for like
a first degree 100% intended. I just
don't know how you're not at like at the
very least like this like basically
whatever this whatever another word
would be for the depraved heart thing
that like is playing into this as much
as she possibly can without basically
calling for it.
>> So So let me let me let me give you an
example right in that specific context.
Rob No. All right. Rob Nor absolutely
was reckless. I think in in the
statements that he was making regarding
election theft in uh pre2020. He wasn't
saying that the the election was
explicitly stolen, right? He was saying
that he didn't he didn't say or sorry he
did say that it was stolen but that was
because of like the Hunter Biden Twitter
file stuff. Okay. So he he did say that
um and he was supporting in in practice
a lot of the efforts made by um by Trump
in the legal cases and he was trying to
um so in other words in other words he
didn't support violence. I'm never going
to say that he directly said that he
supported violence, but I do think that
his kinds of statements contributed to
an air of like um feeling that things
were unfair, feeling like uh they were
getting [__] over and he literally did
take the view that the election was
stolen. So in that context, you're not
but immediately when the insurrection
happened, he condemned the violence
immediately. Okay. So that's a case
where you'll also say a difference too.
As much as I hate [__] Rob No, I feel
like I've heard I don't watch I don't
think I watch any of that. I feel like
I've heard Rob Nor say a billion times
political violence is like an
unambiguous position. I don't think I'm
going to channel.
>> I know that. Yeah. So, I'm trying to
give you an easy case of someone who
definitely, I think you could say,
contributed to risk of people feeling
disenfranchised. But there's no world in
which this guy's going to be you're
going to say that he is um directly
intending what's happening in January 6,
right? Take someone like Ted Cruz. All
right. Ted Cruz was launching objections
in the Senate, right, to slice of
electors. All right? Ted Cruz before
January 6, um he was basically lockep.
He supported the Trump versus or the
Pennsylvania versus Texas case that went
all the way to or that went to the
Supreme Court on the original
jurisdiction that per Do you hold Ted
Cruz that that he intended the
insurrection to happen. That was his
intent for the insurrection happened.
Not not to steal in the sense of the
procedural coup in the sense of the
insurrection. Did did you have evidence
that you think that you could prove Ted
Cruz wanted the insurrection?
>> Probably not. I don't think
>> I agree. I think it's it's hard because
I knew
>> it would change if I knew because
technically the lieutions I don't know
what Ted Cruz knew in so far as the
whole Eastman plot and the whole fake
bull
>> Tucker Carlson spread lies he knew to be
lies right he knew they were lies and we
have that from
I have to know about the ECA violations
and the fake elector
we're going to hold Tucker Carson
accountable for some stuff we're going
to hold that crew accountable for some
stuff but I don't think it's fair to say
that we're going to charge that cruise
of interaction that we're going to say
that he actually did as his conscious
object have for the specific interaction
to happen. Now you again this is just a
way to demonstrate what I'm talking
about here and I mean good things but
the problem I have with this is that
like this is a once in a life well I
guess no war so twice whatever um this
is incredibly rare event that what like
we have to talk about the foreseability
aspect here right like does tech cru
think that if you're seeable he's
engaged in actions that's increasing the
risk of an actual violent insurrection
happening like if Tru would have been um
there are other actions I would have to
see to like push so do you think that
Hassan with his coverage of stuff that
he is um intentional if there's some
kind of communist violence that occurs
would you apply like Hassan to that
violence
>> yes
>> and that's because you think that his
rhetoric has degree of connection
between potential violence
>> that because I think more less call for
it and lays out all the justifications
and anytime violence happens it seems
like every single time I feel like he
calls a false flag he const when it's
pretty obviously yeah
>> yeah so so maybe that I'm like the
whatever maybe you guys think
differently
>> I don't know I would like the depraved
heart level like this is a much so Hutch
said this thing kind of like well this
is much broader thing when you talk
about like Donald Trump I think that the
culpability when it's more diffused in
population it's going to be harder to
ascribe a higher percentage to go
>> so Lauren Southern the Christ Church
>> yes
>> she's culpable in the sense of shees is
she reckless with her rhetoric in the
sense of uh with respect to the there
>> at least. Yeah. Her whole thing was
basically that um white people are
literally being violently replaced by
immigrating people. Didn't question
literally manifest or making that up.
>> They did. Yeah, they did.
>> She actions violating international law.
>> This standard is going to apply to
basically all of
>> the standard uh of holding accountable
by which we mean in the degree of risk.
Um
>> I mean I almost am there for almost
every elected person. Yes. That's why I
half jokingly say that like all of all
them should be bar holding future
official right now. Yes.
>> Okay. That's a different in terms of how
I think we see the balance of evidence
in terms of what goes into 10. I think
that some people um like want these
attacks to happen. Like I don't think
someone like lock in or Kelly when there
like we think they're all right.
>> This is like superans.
>> Come on. Finish the drama.
>> Trickier because you're bogged down in
more procedural stuff that's not such a
literally stealing all if I would tell
you if I genuinely believe that in the
next room John is killing Sam. Okay. And
you run clown and it kills you. Right in
that situation the lie right doesn't
bear on my fair. I lied to you for sure.
I lied to you in the other room. But it
just happens to be the case that I have
no intent to do the bad thing for which
we're all criticizing which is the cler.
>> But it ties back this ties back to the
other thing where my question was well
you expect people to be told that
children are dying because of parental
negligence.
>> Yeah. I think the average person I think
the average person would just be like
let them like I actually be honest with
you I think and the average person would
watch No. I think the average person
sees would expect that their audience
would do the same thing they see when
they say a bunch of [__] up [__] in
the news right which is to take no
action at all. That is the expectation
when you when that is always like let's
test the intuition in the other
direction. Let's say that CPS was called
and then let's say that they showed up
and they actually found out the children
were being severely neglected. Do you
think in that case Dennis would be
taking credit for bringing light to the
issue and that everybody would be
celebrating all these people for
publicizing the issue as much as they
did and all of them would feel some
moral like credit, goodness,
responsibility, virtue for bringing such
a horrible situation to light?
>> I think it's possible that she that
she's not beneath that. No, but I I'm
not saying that.
>> You don't think she'd be worried?
>> I don't think that would happen. I don't
think that would I think people would be
like lar like the reaction would be kind
of horrified that that's actually true.
They'd be like, "Yo, what the fuck?"
Like I thought I I got there with some
like weird stuff about [__] around his
his office and stuff, but holy like it
was actually that bad. His kids are
getting taken away. They' be like, "Holy
fuck."
>> Like giving a little too like you were
calling her.
>> Yeah. So, so I think that she would like
raise her eyebrow and she would
certainly be like this is really bad and
she might even take credit. I'm not
saying that she'd be on that. I don't
know perfectly that she would do that,
but I think that there's a decent chance
that she would do that. The question is
doesn't really bear on the conduct. It
doesn't bear on the conduct. But I'm
going to say this even if I grant it
doesn't bear on whether or not the
action itself reaches the threshold of
uh you know conscious object of the CPS
call. Even if they would have in bad
faith afterwards taking credit for
something that in retrospect the call
was unjustified but the claims are true
doesn't mean that the the conduct here
is is the same level of capability as
one who whose conscious object is to do
a certain thing right like Trump
probably didn't intend for some things
to happen. Uh you know he probably
didn't intend for the bipartisan
infrastructure bill to get passed but he
bet his bottom ass he's going to take
credit for a lot of these projects and
there's nothing inconsistent with that.
>> Sure. I just I know that like when
people lie about a thing, it it lets you
read into their intent a lot more than
if they just tell you.
>> That's why I said it's relevant to the
evidentiary case, but not just positive.
That's what I'm saying. But either way,
this is all everything we're saying is
like reasonable discourse. People, you
know, one mind can go one way, one mind
can go the other. What it's not is, and
this is what I want I want an
acknowledgement on is, oh my god, this
is so crazy. What happened to him? He
[__] lost his marbles. All of a
sudden, he went into just uh [__]
penumbra and all of a sudden he's coming
out and saying all crazy [__] that he
would never ever believe. That [__]
pisses me off. And you know, you might
say like, "Who cares?" But whatever.
>> This is this is you and maybe I play 20
against my mind is rotted, but right now
our disagreement seems to be I'm pushing
for depraved heart and you're content
with recklessness. And in my mind,
there's not very much daylight between
those two positions. My feeling is,
okay, that's fine. My feeling is that
Hutch and other people seem like they're
pushing for at least a brave heart and
you're at zero moral capability
whatsoever. That's what I think most
people's perception of you is that. And
that was my perception of combo. I
basically, if I'm being honest, I think
that she has moral fault, but I I
because I I view the risk, right? What
you have to show, right, in terms of
this being a paper of heart murder is
that her reacting in the way her
reacting in the way that she did that
that significantly increased the
likelihood of the CPL CPS call happened.
And I'm just like,
>> you don't why do you keep repeating
this?
>> You do. In order to have for you to sub
like uh consciously disregard a
substantial unjustifiable risk, you have
to say at the time the action was taken,
it was reasonably foreseeable that the
action you took would have induced some
like significant risk of this occurring.
And I just view it as low risk. I think
maybe that maybe there might be low risk
with regards to a CPS call, but there's
a high risk of harassment altogether.
And that's what
no it's not different because the CPS
call or getting skulls at your house or
whatever else they're all subsets of
harassment. you can't foresee the
particular type of harassment when all
you do is sit here and engage in insane
personal attacks that are digging into a
person's family and you're trying to out
these crazy things where the only remedy
is basically some law enforcement
intervention or somebody else
intervening in a physical manner. Yeah,
I think you're in a hugely contributo
intentionally contributo environment
where you're all doing things to push
people in this direction these crazy
things. Ethan got on his podcast and
said his whole family had Jardia. What
do you mean
>> playing [__] and laughing along with it?
You're doing it too. Not you, but
Denim's in this case.
>> Okay, I that's a disagreement. I think
honest minds reasonable minds can
disagree about that. But I think it's a
low-risisk thing. Um, and I I think that
there's this kind of explosion of the
word harassment where it means like any
kind of negative criticism. I mean, by
that view, like I'm being harassed right
now, but I don't think I'm being
harassed really. Harassment has to do
with like, you know, your your privacy.
>> Why are you talking about this right
now? Hold on. When Ethan talked about
harassment, is it people saying mean
things about him online?
>> No. No. No. I'm not saying that.
>> When I say contributing to
>> broadly, yes. Yes, that is what Ethan's
talking about broadly. Are there some
instances he talks about that are not
that? Yes. So obviously the CPS and the
skulls are more than people simply
saying mean things to him online. But
the lion share the broad
majority of his complaints can be boiled
down to people saying mean things about
him online. Yes. Yes.
>> I I agree that's harassment. I I'm not
guys. I am only saying what I'm saying.
I'm not saying what I'm not I don't know
why you're explaining I don't know why
you're explaining this to other random
people. You need to show her tendency to
uh with those statements as opposed to
just her presence in the community in
the general sense to contribute to
specifically the harassing incidents,
not just the criticism that is part of
like our discourse, right? Which could
be unfair, which could be lies, but that
we all accept as part of being part of
like the the marketplace of ideas.
>> Do you think if you were part of the if
you were part of the clan and you didn't
directly participate in a lynching of
black persons, do you think you share
some culpability for being part of the
organization? and say you pay your dues
and you help in other ways. You weren't
directly involved.
>> Yeah. I think you could be culpable with
respect to your your participation in
the community for sure. But what you're
not necessarily Yeah. Yeah. So like her
participation in the community I think
um bears on her you know increasing risk
in the ways that we've talked about for
sure at some level of abstraction. Um
and absolutely like I I would I can
grant that you know just like for you
would grant right being a part of the
Destiny community you think there's any
risk involved in there and there's some
culpability for what Destiny DGD does?
Do you grant that for yourself and for
your community members being part of the
Destiny community?
For for what actions?
>> For the kinds of actions which um
Listen, you agree your community doxes,
right?
>> No, usually it's just me. Unfortunately,
my community sucks at doxing, so I have
to do it myself. But that's usually
because I've hardcore like [__]
edited most of the [__] out of my
community. No, I had TO [__] POST
EVERYTHING MYSELF. WHAT DO YOU MEAN? MY
COMMUNITY DOESN'T EVEN DO THIS [__]
anymore. Where's my Where's my community
actively doxing people?
>> Oh, sorry. I thought that that So,
you're saying you to the extent that
their doc doc is coming from you, it's
you doing it?
>> Yeah, it's me. Yeah. What the [__] My
community doesn't even do this [__]
anymore.
>> So, Dan doesn't do it, right?
>> I don't know. Dan is not my Dan is on
his own [__] thing against Ethan and
or with Ethan and all that.
>> Do you know whether Dan has a question?
Do you know whether Dan has docked
anybody? Yes or no?
>> No.
>> You don't know?
>> Okay.
>> I think nobody will believe me on this,
but that's fine because you probably
heard differently from school server. Um
me and I don't talk about his [__] I I
think it's cringe. We [__] we argued
about this basically every [__]
anything else episode.
>> I mean legit. I don't know if Jay will
say this. I I know I say I can speak for
myself and say I have said many times
Dan and Destiny are not as tightly in
sync as people pretend as the outside
may may assume. There is not that that
close in sync. They're reporting
everything to each other they're doing.
No, Dan Dan's out. Dan wants to be a
[__] you know, Twitter hero. Dan's
out doing his thing. That's just pretty
pretty true from everything I can tell.
So I don't know where this Oh, all the
other communities just say this. No, no
[__] mud and Dan doing things. I
don't give a [__] His [__] that's his
[__] That's his thing. Doing
whatever. I have basically nothing to do
with it. I think I've exchanged all of
two text messages with or not DMs with
Ethan in my entire [__] life. Uh I
have not he does his own [__] I have
nothing to do with any of that.
>> Well, I'm glad that he's not part of the
community because
>> I say he's not part of the community.
That was tricky. I think that whatever
behavior he's engaged, that's not part
of my community. Dan posting ducks.
>> Okay. No, this is [__] No, it is
obviously part of the community. It's
just you're not both directly in sync,
but obviously Dan is part of DGG and
uses DGG. That's obviously true.
>> Whatever. Am I [__]
>> I'm not sure. I'm asking the question.
I'm asking the question. That's all I'm
saying. It's people people talk, you
know, that sometimes people say that
that Dan has contributed to this, you
know.
>> Do you think I don't know?
>> He might have. So, I don't think it's
bad faith for me to ask the question,
but if you're just going to take
acceptance like responsibility for all
the docs and events, you know, maybe you
don't think that your your community has
done they're just innocent little angels
>> in my in my community. In my community,
I know Dan is in other communities.
That's mine. I don't take it. I don't
He's not my child. I don't take [__]
responsibility for every single [__]
thing that he does.
>> Would you accept that responsibility?
Would you accept that like response from
like one of these lefties? I don't know
[__] about [__] bad Abanada. He's not
part of the [__] thing. I don't know
what [__] Assan is doing. I just do
my own thing. You would never accept
that.
>> I would take a look at the behavior of
the people. There have been times where
Dan wanted to call people out or get
into weird personal attacks or whatever.
He might have even [__] done it
against you. And I told Danny, "No, I
don't do that. I don't give a [__] about
this type of [__] I don't do these
arguments here. I don't care about this
or whatever." And I don't know. And my
community knows my stance on it. There's
a very clear stance on it. the community
doesn't engage in it because they know
this get banned for it.
>> I know but like it does seem like we are
applying. So if Dan can't be held
respons you can't be held respons
responsible for Dan. Uh talk to me about
how denims can be responsible for bad
panata
>> because it's not Denim's being held
responsible just for bada. It's her
entire community and all of the other
communities that she interacts with
engaging with the same type of behavior
and all engaging in the same type of
behavior. If denim is watching her whole
community like not a good look for bad
this isn't cool. My god, I would give
this.
>> Yeah, he's he's complaining that OP, how
could you possibly say that bad empanada
has got a reputation for doing bad
things, not immediately jump in saying
that bad empanada is literally the worst
[__] doxing, child rapist, murderer,
[__] international criminal? How can
you not immediately jump in saying that?
Oh, I've got no idea what Dan does. I've
got no idea what Dan gets up to.
>> Okay. Well, I at least we can agree that
>> that's Wait, that's a valid difference,
right?
>> These are completely different things. I
don't play videos of Dan doxing people
or say like Dan D's guy. [__] good
for him. [__] him. Yeah. Hell yeah. I
don't do any of this [__] in my
community. And half the people in my
community when they see Dan talk about a
song, they all [__] type yes, honey.
And he gets [__] triggered. Like I
don't
I'm accepting your representation. Um
you know, maybe he is, you know, you're
generally unaware of what's going on
that you don't really interact with it.
And I would uh I would hope that you
would accept that.
>> Wait, hold on. Wait, wait, wait.
>> I'm accepting what you're saying. I'm
accept. Yeah. Continue so I can call
you. So I'm I'm accepting what you're
saying that you don't have knowledge of
what Dan has done or not done and that
therefore you you and your community
can't be held responsible because that's
like out of community activities. That's
okay.
>> Extend that same charity. Go ahead.
>> Extend that same charity to people who
fit that test. In other words, if we
can't show
>> not Denim, not Pyron, not Frogen.
>> Got it. Okay.
>> Because if Dan was doing this in my
community, you would have a good
argument. I'm not Do you think I'm
responsible for every single thing that
Dan or M does? Of course not. But if it
was happening in my community, I think I
would have some responsibility. Dan was
posting this [__] in my community. I
think I would have some responsibility
for it.
>> But sometimes it can be hard to
disentangle, right? It can be hard.
>> No, it's not. I think it's super easy.
How is it hard?
>> Because Because like
it's very easy because whenever whenever
happens on Destiny's side, it's totally
unrelated to him and whatever whenever
it happens on his enemy's side,
>> it's all connected and they're all
they're all talking to each other.
>> Yeah. So the spaces kind of intersect.
People have conversations from one thing
that is, you know, technically distinct,
you know, one server to another. People,
you know, these are not these like
hermetically sealed communities. Uh and
and and people, you know, have
friendships across them different.
>> They are. No, they are sealed. They are
sealed. I think I if you want to board,
you should go back and reread your chat
like today. They're very sealed and it's
a very intentional thing. It's very
intentionally done that way. Um they're
they're very distinct. They're very
sealed. When Hutch's docs and everybody
else's [__] was getting posted, people
in my chat were like, "Oh, I don't know
how to talk about this cuz I don't want
to post like the dogs and blah blah
blah. I don't want to do this." And now,
especially since I've done mostly
politics for the past three two years,
it's hard to even talk about [__] like
[__] Kiwi because a lot of people
don't [__] know what this [__] is at
the moment. Besides people are like the
more hardcore follower types. I agree
with you. There might be edge case
examples. There might be edge case
examples where some people are making
weird like I would agree. I would say
that like misogyny is a weird thing that
gets happens in my community and [__]
especially because of the [__] male
female but it's the thing I try to pay a
lot of attention to but whatever we're
talking about for like the harassment I
mean that in the literal sense of the
word not the same thing the harassment
that Casey Tron Frogan Denims and the
Stark all these people engage in it's
whatever the the ambiguities they're way
the [__] over the line way the [__] over
the line
>> okay so so if that's the case and listen
maybe I don't know enough about these
communities to make that representations
you would at least extend that courtesy
to me right because I am I going to be
held responsible for just for
for any of these other people. So the
standard that you just applied to
yourself, how come I don't get the
benefit of that eegis? Why don't I get
the benefit of the doubt?
>> I don't hold you responsible. What did I
say? What did I say an hour ago? I said
you're like the 2018 centrist that
provides cover for the Nazis. I didn't
say that you're doing it or that you're
necessarily doing it. You're a community
is doing. I'm saying that like all these
other people have infected your [__]
community. Duby's donated almost 12
months of [__] welfare checks to you
in chat to try to [__] own me or
whatever. Yeah, these people are are
>> Should I ban them? Should What do you
want to do? I'm asking, is there any
that you want me to have with respect to
Dubie? With respect to
>> It's not a matter of whether you should
or shouldn't. It's a matter of do you
engage in a type of behavior that seems
to attract these types of people? They
set their eyes for a particular crime.
>> I'm asking by by by your standard, by
DGG standard, what ought I do with
Dubbie? Can we just get concrete on
Dubbie? What what should I do with him?
Should I ban him? Should I stop
accepting money? What should I do?
>> My issues my issues with you rise to and
are capped at extreme and intense
annoyance. But that's it. I'm not going
to say you have to. I'm just saying it's
not the same as the issues that I have
with Dubbie or Queen or just those
communities. Those are the level of
hatred and and I think there's Mal. My
issue with you is is annoyance and
irritation. That's it. There wouldn't be
a stronger prescription there.
>> So, but like Okay. So I can continue
accepting doobie money. Why do you
expect? Clearly you think there is some
[__] issue here, dude.
>> Say that that's bad. You won't say
that's bad to accept dubie bucks, right?
>> Is it bad or not?
>> No, but wait. It's annoying
not accept the money.
>> It's not about you accepting.
>> Dubious is going to Why would he say
that? Why would he say that? That's like
Dubius just committed a third of his
income for the next year to donating to
Pecope purely because Destiny said it
really annoys me when Doobie donates to
you.
attracting it. If I was debating with
you and I had a whole and I had the anti
[__] I forget Peruvian or whatever
the [__] your back is the anti whatever
South American people were all showing
up and they're like oh you need to get
this [__] I don't know what they call
I don't know what slurs are for people
in South America they start donating all
this [__] my question would be why the
[__] are these people but isn't isn't
isn't the answer like obvious answer is
because I've taken some kind of takes on
two issues exactly two issues um where
people think that like where we disagree
with EG issue number one Hassan Global
Entry Detainment and issue number two
Ethan
But if I were but but if I were to never
address that and were to become
bedfellows of all these people, I think
people start to look at me and I think
they would rightly say, "Well, hold on.
Are you do you like support everything
these communities do?"
>> I talk [__] to Dubie. I talk [__] to
these other people in in in the chat
when I see them when they when I
disagree with them on the same grounds
that agree on something.
>> No, no, but like if you think that
there's something else I ought because
Do you want me to withhold my genuine
opinions on the Ethan Klein lawsuit? No,
>> I don't understand how you're I don't
understand. You keep saying thing.
Sorry. Go ahead.
If I found out that kick was owned by
Israel and I was getting paid money by
them because Israel so strongly agreed
with my position on things that they
were like we need to funnel this guy a
[__] ton of money.
>> Yeah.
>> You don't think that I would stop and
think like how is it that I'm so aligned
with Israeli interest that they don't
even have to give marching orders and
they find it like prudent to pay me. You
don't think that I would think like
that's kind of weird?
>> I I would maybe think about it and I
have thought about it. I'm like am I
being used in part of a proxy war with
respect to snark? And what I did in
response to that was to edit the rules
of my community to specifically uh say
that like excessive drama baiting that
kind of stuff is not allowed. And that
was I thought a reasonable response to
some of the quote unquote turf wars that
were happening in my discord and in my
community to to make it clear that hey I
don't want to talk about this lawsuit
for reasons I've already stated the one
that uh that you're involved in. And I
don't want this to be a turf war where
that happens. And by the way there
there's a lot of criticisms from both
sides on that. I think I've taken a
reasonable position. There are a lot of
reasons that you guys will never know
about about that position. And I I it is
not because of what some people think.
Although I have stated some actual
public reasons why I do it, but that was
the actions I took so that to make sure
that my community, which has a lot of
destiny supporters in it, which I have
never said is not okay, which I have
continued to when there are public
issues that are of like national
importance or where you do a good
debate, I have signaled that I'm willing
to praise you. That is not something
consistent with one of these snarky like
are these snarker people like uh taking
opportunities?
>> No, I don't understand. You're like
you're missing I just don't understand
substantively how you're missing the
point. my community were to start we're
full of a bunch of people and they were
like spamming all these crazy slurs at
you and everything and I said my
response is okay guys you guys are like
super racist spam all the slurs we're
going to ban racial slurs now for my
chat would that be adequate to address
that behavior do you think
>> so you know I remember gave his
statement when the Destiny [__] happened
where he's like borderline crying
I said that was a totally fine statement
totally reasonable statement I think
Jason said about the same I can't
remember who who was I think Jason maybe
even was slightly mad about it. I can't
remember. I remember Dan talking [__] on
Pisco
and then no one no one was like around
Pisco saying like, "Oh, you've got to
cover Destiny stuff. Oh, don't don't you
care about this thing that's happening?"
Wasn't happening.
You know, occasionally tune in to Pisco
if he's talking to like counterpoints
about some political [__] and then when
he starts talking about the Ethan [__]
Yeah, people are tuning in. That's not
because of Destiny. That's because of
the Ethan [__] is cuz the biggest drama
on the internet right now and Pisco is
taking a controversial position that I
agree with
and phrasing it in a good way, arguing,
you know, um,
forcefully
with with some of the most awful
offenders of of this [__] like Hajj, you
know, and his fans, his [__] fans.
So this it's just like this total
narcissistic delusion that Destiny lives
in that at all points everything is
actually just about him. It's all just
telling peace go against him. No dude,
no one gives a [__] It's about this
Ethan stuff. Okay. I actually would
rather Destiny just disappeared from
this Ethan stuff, frankly.
I don't like having to cover Destiny
content because I find him quite a
repulsive individual. But it is good.
It's good content and uh it gets a view.
think
>> using the racial slurs um so banning the
slurs themselves.
>> Sorry, I want to make sure you're
understand as opposed to banning the
people who are saying the slurs, right?
>> No, no, I'm not. I'm just Yeah, I'm
saying I would be banned slurs. No more
slurs in chat.
>> So, it depends, right? If the people
are, you know, the problematic people
are indicating like a a future tendency
in my uh spaces, both my chat and my
discord to violate the rules, then the
mere fact of like the rule change
wouldn't be enough, right? I would have
to remove the members. Correct. But but
you you have stopped you've stopped sort
of saying that that would be justified.
I think that it's not. Go ahead. It's
not so much I'm removing the members,
it's like why are the members why are
these particular people attracted?
>> Because first of all, I have known
Dubbie for years, right? So Dubbie and I
even though like I don't know him
personally, right? Like
>> just personalizing this so much. It's
not like I me and Ethan hate each other
now. Okay. Cuz I think he did weird [__]
and I encountered him. So [__] it. Okay,
that being said, my never turned into an
Ethan Starker community, okay? He's
[__] That's it.
>> And my community
was attract. I wouldn't just say we're
going to ban this type of conversation.
Like well [__] what kind of content am
I doing? What am I engaging in that's
like fostering this type of community? I
think that Frogan Denims and Caseyron
maybe you should have asked that
question way before it got to all the
miss CPS calls. I think you're way over
the [__] line at that point.
>> Okay, so I
>> Let me kind real quick. Let me I'm
sorry. Real quick, guys. Um I do have to
I have a family that uh wants to see me
today. So I'm not leaving.
>> Leave. Say it loudly. Maybe there's an
ego thing where I'm like myopic or maybe
I'm arrogant or whatever. But what I'm
not doing is being insincere. You can
guarantee I'm being sincere and I'm not
[__] griing because if I was trying
to grift, I would read the room and say,
"Fuck Denims. [__] Assan. These lawsuits
are based." Haha. and do what everyone
else is doing and do it better than
them. But I'm not doing that because I
don't think it's right and I think that
there's, you know, additional insight I
can provide and it's not my view. And so
I'm not doing the thing that would get
me the most money. Whenever I do one of
these videos, one of the reasons I don't
I don't post anymore, they get [__]
review bombed because everyone in my
community hates them. So I I I think
that I'm aware of that. Um, but I'm not
stopping because of money and I'm
certainly not going on this crusade to
the extent it is based on like uh, you
know, trying to be a grifter. And I'll
say one other thing, right? Ethan made a
malicious lie about me, right? Ethan
said that I LAR as an attorney. I'm like
Mike from PA. basically suggesting that
I don't have any uh that I was never
admitted to practice in any state.
That's what he suggested. Never taken
that back. So on this entire thing,
>> Wait, wait, wait. Did Ethan really No,
[__] Ethan because he's recorded half
the time. Wait, wait, wait.
>> Yes.
>> What did Ethan say?
>> Yes, he So I'll I'll bring up the quote.
>> Do you know what I'm about to ask?
>> No, I don't know what you're about to
ask.
>> Okay. Well, I just want to see that
thing. Bring up the quote.
>> He said, "Peace Lararss is there's a
quote, direct quote. Piscolarps is an
attorney when he's about as qualified as
Mike from PA." What do you mean by that?
I'm doing a little bit of mind reading
here, but my guess is is he just thinks
that Mike from PA is [__] and he
thinks that you're [__] I don't
know if I don't know. Maybe Ethan does,
but also this because I think Ethan's
[__] I don't know if Ethan knows
the difference between like an attorney
and a lawyer. I have no idea if he knows
that.
>> That is an insane amount of charity. He
has lawyers ass.
>> So what he he says [__] you know this.
He says [__] [__] about legal stuff
all the [__] time.
>> Okay.
>> Now, but listen, maybe Ethan no
standards. You could show me you could
show me one of a million quotes or
whatever and I'd be like, "Okay, yeah,
he knew that. That's probably what he
was implying, I guess. But I I actually,
if I had to put money on it, one to one
odds, my guess is Ethan probably doesn't
know the difference between an attorney
and a lawyer. That'd be my guess.
>> I don't even think there is. I people
say lawyer versus attorney. I don't
think that that's like a consistent
distinction. But the the what people
know about Mike from is who never
admitted to practice. That's what people
know for Mike from PA. He's talking
about qualification. Qualification as
Mike from PA. What is Mike Pier known
for?
>> Is that is that is that what he's known
for? I feel like he's known for being
with legal stuff with legal stuff. No,
no, with respect to legal opinions.
People the whole thing about it, you
know, is that he was never admitted to
practice.
>> Okay. Okay, we have we're I don't know
people, but we're just in so separate
communities.
>> You don't think it's reasonable for
people to take that interpretation?
Bisco lars as an attorney when he's
about as qualified as Mike from PA.
>> I think you could. Sure. I think it's
reasonable. You could I could see how
you say I but from all of the totality
I've seen, it wouldn't surprise me if if
Ethan was just saying that you're
[__] because I don't know if Ethan
actually knows the drama because most of
the drama around Mike that other people
fall into all the bad bunny stuff and
him punching a couch and all that [__]
and then he got kicked out of an
election for some reason. I don't know
how many people know that you can like
get your JD and not pass the bar if he's
>> he got kicked out of an election for
some reason. For some reason, why was he
kicked out of the election, Destiny? Why
is it that Mike from PA being Mike from
Pennsylvania, Mike from PA where he ran
Mike from PA meaning like he's a
candidate from state, right? That's the
point. The election, that's what he's
known for. Mike from PA. That's where
his name come cames from comes from. Why
was he kicked off for that election?
Destiny. Oh, because he put his
occupation as lawyer when he hadn't
passed the bar.
That's why, isn't it? That's why,
dude.
>> Maybe when we're doing the mental
states, I think that um let's just be
honest on the table. I haven't seen
every Sorry. I haven't seen tons of or a
significant amount of denim straight
streams like unconnected to what's going
on. And I'm taking oftentimes a negative
inference against these people on good
faith sometimes based when it comes to
Adam Pan on stuff I know. Um but people
will give maximal charity to Ethan's
position and will say that I'm being
hypocritical by covering this lawsuit
and by their own lights, right? If it's
justified for Ethan to do these kinds of
things and to cover people and to go
after people who have maliciously lied
about him, I think at a bare minimum, I
want to see if you agree that it's
justified for me.
>> People do
jeez, I can't talk today. People do know
Mike from PA is the couch punch guy. But
if you're stating about as qualified as
Mike from PA, you are displaying some
knowledge idea that he's lacking
qualifications.
You are that's what that's what you're
saying. You're saying I I know about the
You're saying you you have some
knowledge that there was a lack of a
lack of qualifications.
I was I was smoking before I spoke and I
my throat [__] up
>> to scrutinize Ethan's lies.
>> Yeah. But I the issue I have is that
like people say [__] [__] on some
side of a thing and then it feels like
you feel like you have to say [__]
[__] like the negative opposite of it.
The opposite [__] [__] That's what
it feels like. Like when I say like
these people are saying this
>> like we are justification. So like
earlier you were saying like oh I think
there's a lot of malice in him watching
these lawsuits and it was really
personal. My guess is going to be like
90% of civil lawsuit like there it's a
civil lawsuit. These are almost always
going to be done militia friends against
each other. That's a
>> given. But but you do think given the
communication that you just heard it's
justified. You wouldn't have a problem
with me going after Ethan's motivations,
right? Given what's what I just shared
with you. No problem.
>> You can share what you feel his true
motivations are. But it's weird to be
like he's lying about the wait.
When you say it's weird, is it weird for
him to to say what he said about me?
>> What he said about What do you mean
weird? So, so you don't have a problem
scrutinizing motivations.
>> Do you?
>> The double standard.
>> Sweet. I think
>> but it feels like you commit yourself to
positions that are just so much on the
opposite end.
>> I I don't like when somebody brings up
the whole like Ethan is bringing this up
to save. He's literally [__] Jesus
Christ for fair use or whatever. I'm
like I'm sure you probably some some and
there are people that say this there.
Trust me, Dan has never [__] Ethan
dick suck in my [__] life. Okay. And
I we talk about this [__] all the time
and I was like I'm sure that Ethan
carries up to some extent about free use
for sure. But these lawsuits are
obviously heavily personally motivated.
But like the but then you see people
making the Jesus argument and you're out
here like every single civil lawsuit
should only come from the purest of
[__] intentions. And like 90% of of
civil lawsuits that are involving like
corporations are going to be [__]
spite personally motivated. You didn't
quite get there on Hutch's lawuit but
you or the when you're talking to Hutch.
But it sounded like you're saying people
are launching lawsuits for personal
motivations and not the actual
underlying civil cause of action. That's
probably not a good
>> No, I have I have an opinion about what
I have opinion about what when lawsuits
are justified and when they're not that
might differ from like what's legally
acceptable or what's you know acceptable
under the rules of ethics. And just
because a lawsuit is legal to file,
you're never going to be in favor,
right? Like, for example, an easy case
is, I'm not saying this is like Ethan's
law, okay? I'm not saying they're
exactly the same, but I'm I'm just
saying that you do apply an ethical
standard bringing lawsuits. For example,
Trump bringing his lawsuits against the
[__] pollster. He's legally allowed
to do it. Trump bringing a lawsuit
against uh, you know, to try to steal
the election. We are going to apply a
standard to whether or not we think that
that's justified, even if it's motivated
by a bunch of a spike. And I'm
grappling, I think, honestly, in front
of everybody with what are the factors
that go into whether or not I'm going to
like think that a lawsuit is okay. And
there's nothing wrong with that.
>> I don't like Hold on. I I don't like
that comparison because the biggest
issue with Trump bringing the lawsuit I
would argue is is quasi procedural. It's
the fact that he is the chief executive
and he is the president of the United
States. Like like nobody has a problem
with Mcronone filing a lawsuit I don't
think against like Candace Owens, right?
>> Um I don't have filing a lawsuit against
Candace Owens.
>> No, but like you can think of unhinged
lawsuits between private people that you
would be like this is a bad lawsuit. I'm
sure you can think of such lawsuits,
can't you?
>> I mean like
>> Yes. Right. You mean by it depends on
what you mean by bad lawsuits. ones that
you think are ethically wrong to bring.
>> You don't think that there are some
lawsuits out there that are ethically
wrong to bring?
>> I I guess we have to define what we even
mean by
>> what we ought.
>> I'm sure I'm sure we could No. Well, no.
No, but like what makes it like
>> if you got into a personal fight with a
friend and you knew that like his mom
was dying of cancer and he's paying for
it out of pocket, you know that he'll
kill his mom or something. Like I maybe
theoretically, possibly just that,
right?
So, so for example, if you thought that
a lawsuit was like totally baseless and
not worth the court's time and was just
done for an improper purpose, you would
probably be against it, right?
>> Yeah. But that's not a question to the
motivation. That's a question to the the
actual facts of the case.
>> If if you knew for if you knew, for
example, that someone was filing a
lawsuit only to [__] with you, to take
your time, take your money, and [__] and
basically uh do things out of malice.
You wouldn't think that would bear on
the ethics of the lawsuit.
>> It would be personally annoying. But if
they have a valid cause of action and
they're not lying about any of the
underlying evidence, people have a right
to [__] file lawsuits,
>> right? Right. But but that's what I
mean. Like you're going to apply an
ethical standard. No one's questioning
your
>> right ethical standard is annoying. But
I wouldn't say it's necessarily wrong.
Are you going to a moral wrong to do it?
They ought not file it. Right.
>> My issue my issue related to Pixie is
that I she lied out of a lot of the
evidence. That's my issue there. But
does she have a right to follow the law?
I literally told her the [__] sue me
right to do it. I'm not saying they
don't.
>> Without getting to the merits, should
she have sued you?
>> Sure.
>> You think she should have sued you?
If she if she genuinely believed that
the evidence that she had in the
beginning was correct and true, then
yeah, I think she'd right. I think she
should have if she felt like I'm not
saying should have is weird. But like
she wouldn't be the moral wrong for
doing it.
>> So So another another way of saying that
is she ought sued you given that that is
her belief if you assume it is.
>> It's when you say ought, you're implying
like a moral compulsion. I don't know if
I would use ought here.
>> By which I mean it is morally good.
>> It's it's fine. It's not morally bad.
>> Okay. I I have a I think we can be
scrutinizing towards uh lawsuits, their
motivations, why they're being brought,
the purposes behind them. It might not
it might be some area where we think
that like there's reasonable minds to
disagree on a particular thing. And I'm
honestly trying to grapple with our
intuitions that some lawsuits we don't
agree with. And so I I don't I'm
curious. Sure. I'm curious because this
is my issue. I don't know what you
scream over this. Like my issue is that
the standard that you're using I feel
like there might be I feel like 90% of
certain types of lawsuits are almost
exclusively going to be motivated by
personal spite. So like um contract law
maybe not um maybe certain tors or
whatever maybe not but like when you get
into things like defamation or um
intentional infliction emotional stress
or whatever I feel like almost cuz what
do we what are we saying
>> what if they don't care about the
property right underneath it like I'm
giving you a styized example which is a
simplified example. What if it's the
case that we know for certain it's it's
a hypothetical that they're suing they
don't give a [__] about the property
infringement at issue. They don't care
about it. In fact they like that it was
infringed and they're suing over that.
Do you would you support such a lawsuit
absent some overriding social concern? I
can imagine where impact litigation
mattered where so absent those kinds of
or where you know it's um it's kind of
futile no matter what the lawsuit's
going to happen. So absent those
question there might be a world so long
maybe where if I could maybe perfectly
ascertain it I would say no that would
be unethical but I think this would get
really I think it would be on the border
of like should you deny people who are
not vaccinated access to medical
treatment um related to the disease that
they didn't vaccinated. It's easy. Yes.
People say, but as soon as you start to
pull a little bit like, but what about
if you're fat and you have an obesity or
like heart related disease? What if you
smoke cigarettes and you got lung
cancer? What if your parent smokes?
Right. Then it's like, okay, [__]
Actually, there's no way to draw a line
here. You agree that like the vast
majority of certain types of civil
litigation is it's it's motivated by
spite. Otherwise, they would just solve
it out of court. Right.
>> I basically think that you're correct. I
I just want to say that you are correct
that in litigation almost always there
is some human story of emotion, spite,
anger, betrayal. These these stories are
often times lost by the legal formalism.
And I should never have no one should
interpret me as to say that I think that
legal, you know, lawsuits are all
formalistic. All I'm saying is there are
certain purposes that I think are
proper, certain that I think are
improper. So the mere presence of malice
or a spite to me isn't going to be
sufficient to say I don't care about a
lawsuit. I just want to be clear about
that. So the presence of spite I've
never represented that that's sufficient
for me to say a lawsuit's not justified.
I have a view about when lawsuits are
justified and it's not that. But I'm
just saying like we all are trying to
honestly grapple with when
>> all bis saying is that you have to
genuinely care about the tort like you
have to have a genuine interest in the
tort that you were using to go after the
person like if you are if you're just
like to like in this case where like
Ethan wants them to sue Ethan wants them
to infringe so that he can sue
you you do not genuinely care about the
underlying wrong that supports the the
tor you're using to go after this
person. So therefore, you shouldn't use
her.
What Ethan really cares about is some
kind of like defamation or something
>> is the case and when it's not the case.
And that's what I'm trying to do. I you
might disagree. This is my
>> I don't Okay, I don't like when you keep
saying it's honest agreement. I agree
with you. You do this thing where there
are a particularized touch was running
this. there's a particularized example
where it feels like you're so far beyond
the pale and then you back it up to like
well aren't there times where like for
instance we could say that like aren't
there times where like consent is hazy
when two people have had maybe a little
bit too much to drink but they like have
had sex before and they had sex and
you're like okay sure but the particular
case you're talking about is like a guy
who roofed some girl and [__] ran a
train on her with his entire [__]
family. It's like I don't know why we're
bringing up that like reasonable minds
can like we're so far beyond the pale of
this point. I feel like with regards to
the Ethan lawsuits we have like very
clear and obvious copyright
infringement. It was so obvious that he
literally set it up in advance of this
happening. Copyright infringement was
being used to further the other harms
that were being done to Ethan. I think
that it feels like I could be wrong, but
it feels like sometimes civil litigation
is used to recoup or attack somebody for
other harms. Like for instance, if
people don't get a criminal conviction,
there might be civil litigation that
follows somebody's trying to be made
whole again. Um, so I like I feel like
in terms of like a vehicle for spite,
this copyright related lawsuit is kind
of the perfect vehicle.
>> Yeah, I don't agree with that. And for
reasons that I've stated in those other
situations, I think I can give you an
example where I I think your intention
would be flipped. And the one I keep
going back to is uh the Tim Pool
example. Let's say that, you know, same
facts. You know, Tim Pool sets a trap
for me because I had said something
about him taking Russian money which he
didn't find uh totally good or whatever.
And he doesn't he actually wants me to
infringe that copyright and um he sets
the plan and then I do and what I say
and then we have the intentional state
of malice and he sues me even though he
he even says I don't really give a [__]
about the the copyrighted issue. And
later on he extracts concessions from me
like also I apologize for not
apologizing about um Charlie Kirk
Carter. I'm sorry for what I said about
um Tim Pool, you know, being part of a
Russian aligned [__] I'm sorry for
whatever like all this other stuff. I
think you'd be on my side
>> if the underlying fact pattern was the
same. I don't think so. I think
especially once you start to make
malicious statements like even I
recognize people I don't like. Like like
I mean I'm technically watching their
content. I'm kind of surprised that like
hasn't tried probably just don't want to
go with the lawsuit [__] They try to
like sue me for watching a [__]
stream or whatever. Um, I would probably
try to find most of this on fair use
grounds, but like I that would like a
huge [__] around. Like if I know that
I'm fighting hardcore like if I was
like, "All right, today I know Han's
streaming in [__] China and I know
he's mad about his love."
>> Literally everyone would rally around
Destiny if Hassan tried to [__] sue
him like that. It would be so [__]
obscene.
>> So we're going to [__] take as many
viewers from this [__] as
possible. So you're saying if that
happened to Conor, I can't believe what
>> if if that happened to Connor and Tim
Pool sued Connor because Tim Yeah,
Connor was malicious to Tim P and Tim
Pool sued him and basically was trying
to financially [__] with Connor who has
his family or whatever.
>> Well, I'm saying I'm saying I'm saying
>> No, I'm saying if Connor was literally
like I'm watching this to take as many
viewers from this guy as possible.
>> He says that
>> it's pool you' be like [__] themool.
[__] him. That's what you would say. No,
>> you would say
>> not only would I not say that I've never
No, I'll respect somebody's [__]
copyright and the rights that they have
for their [__] like that. No, I wouldn't
say [__] What do you mean [__] him
doesn't mean you can do anything else
that you want to or whatever else? What
do you mean?
>> So, so you really care about copyright
infringement.
>> Um, do I really care about
>> This guy used to say that he didn't
think like IP law should be a thing
basically.
>> And that's like principally, but like I
respect the legal aspect of it. Sure.
>> Yeah. So like if for example some [__]
happened with movies and people were
doing that consistently that would be
something where you know if they get
sued by the thing you would you would be
like yeah that's based or you yourself
if you got sued by a right holder you'd
be like that's good. And if you knew the
right movies, but if I knew that like if
somebody was engaged in that behavior or
whatever, I'd be like, "Oh yeah, if you
get fucked." I mean, of course, who were
I don't know how old you were. I'm 37.
We all got [__] emails from the RIA
or whatever when we were on Kaza or the
Pirate Bay or whatever else and there
was a [__] FBI honey pot or whatever
else where they were [__] shooting
out um copyrighted [__] You'd get a
letter for it or the MPA. Yeah.
>> Okay. I didn't know that DJ respected
copyright so much. Maybe they do. And I
I've just been wrong about that. It it
it seems like this is not what's
motivated people. It seems like people
think that copyright is kind of like
yoink and they just do whatever.
>> There's Wait, hold on just real quick
cuz you've tried to do this like three
or four times. Okay, let me show you the
difference. I don't know if you're
getting this or not. Okay. The thing
that I hate more than anything else are
[__] crybullies. Okay.
>> Oh yeah. Is it? Oh yeah. Oh yeah.
Uh-huh.
This is a guy This is a guy who goes
around screaming. He wants to kill
people. All this [__] But if you if you
make one joke about him being gay, if
you make one joke about his uh
I don't know, [__] you know, terrible
parenting or some [__] it's the end of
the world. Why isn't this person banned?
Why haven't they been banned already?
It's crazy. It's obscene, bro. This guy
is the most delusional
narcissistic
[__]
crybaby [__] on the whole internet.
It's insufferable.
>> Like a [__] cuz I know you're trying
to [__] do all these memes to
reference my do I get like a tort
interference letter or some [__] and
they're like your website facilitates
blah blah blah blah blah. I'm going to
sit there and cry about it. Yeah,
obviously fine. Maybe it does. Yeah, I
don't know if I should say this. Yeah,
I'm so glad that's like, you know, I'm
never going to sue him, but holy [__]
I'm so glad that if someone ever sues
him, he just admitted, "Oh yeah, my
website probably doesn't interfere with
people's businesses." Awesome. Thank
you.
>> If a company comedy will hear this and
use this at admission for court, this is
all memes and blah blah blah, but like
yeah, I'm not going to say like, I can't
believe that somebody's coming after me
just because I'm [__] hosting. No, I
feel like, oh, [__] yeah. I guess you
got me, right? Sure. Yeah.
>> Okay. But if if you had a sense,
>> you own it. You own your action, own
your behavior. If somebody earlier you
tried to do the pick the dots thing,
what if somebody harassed blah blah
blah, you know? I was like, I don't want
people to try to do this. Think about
pearl clutch. I never intend for anybody
to be mean or harass anybody. Blah. No,
of course I'm not going to pearl clutch
like that. This is serious [__] I'm
doing in response to serious [__]
though. Just don't pearl clutch like
these other communities are doing. Own
the responsibility. Own the outcomes of
your actions.
>> Serious [__] like correctly identifying
him as someone who non-consentially
shared explicit images of one of his
friends.
Explicit images and videos.
It's really horrible stuff.
>> You're going to be like based. I I
deserve to be
>> under.
>> Well, no, because I think all my stuff
for honest use. That's why I said
pattern is
>> assuming you just play. Okay. But if but
if you assume you play it and so do you
actually believe this line about
intentional state malice? That should be
the line. That should be the standard.
You don't believe that. XC fine
>> should be the line.
>> Yeah. It shouldn't be the line. So
you're not going to hold that line.
That's like a made up thing. That's like
made up.
>> It's Hold on. It's absolutely not a
madeup thing. Okay.
>> It's not a line that people care about.
>> It's absolutely a line that people care
about. Attorneys and judges would
probably care about it. Intentionally
stated if you're literally saying like
I'm doing this cuz [__] the other
person.
>> No. for copyright as a line. No, as a
line for copyright is that one
>> copyright. I think people are going to
care that he say
>> do you want that to be the threshold
that beyond anything before that good to
go?
>> No, I don't think I don't think that's a
threshold question. I don't think it's
just positive one way or another. But
I'm saying that like I definitely
wouldn't complain at that point. Like
Jesus Christ like how could you, right?
Like you're expecting it. Like like if
I'm watching I'm coming or whatever,
that's fine. But if I watch it, I'm like
this is possibly stupid to me. How am I
gonna say like I can't believe you? I
think if this if if your community got
the impression that one of the motives
of the uh you know the people who were
suing you was because you had said
something about Russia or other
political grievance they would harp on
that and they would call it improper
purpose if you they got the sense
>> yeah they probably they might yeah I
wouldn't I agree with you they probably
would sure but
>> and I think you would say you know what
that's a good point
>> good point
>> that's fine but you the thing is you can
say that because you're intuiting it
maybe because of the things we just will
tell you but I no I am the number one
[__] around and find a person on the
internet where if something happens
always say, "What did the other person
do? What did they do first? Why did this
person do that?" That's I'm I'm like,
"No, you are not for other people, not
for yourself, though. You literally are
the biggest crybaby [__] victim
whenever anything happens to you."
>> Reputation in the entire [__] world
for asking that question. When it comes
to the guy, always ask another question.
>> Okay. Hey,
you made me tired. And I I do want to
say I um I I think that we can have
people in communities have their
disagreements. Y'all can say whatever
you want. Uh, but I am going to defend
myself in terms of my ethics and I think
that what I've done is nothing but say
true to like my sincere opinions and and
if that pisses people off and that
causes people to think that like I'm
taking a side with um with the lefties,
so be it. I'm going to keep saying what
I want to say and what I actually
believe. I'm not a tanky. I'm not a
socialist. I don't I'm not trying to
withhold opinions for one reason or
another. But if if people take that
impression from me, that's their
impression to take. I will try to rebut
it. I will try to defend myself, but
it's not the case that I'm stealing
talking points or opinions from someone
else and that I don't genuinely hold
them. To the extent that people have
presented information to me and I find
it convincing, it's because it's on the
grounds that I find it convincing. And
I'm not like in these, you know, private
DMs or private groups with um snarker
communities whose whole intention is to
destroy you or your community. That's
not what I'm doing. I'm trying uh to to
keep it to um to stuff that I that I'm
interested in and and that's all I can
do.
>> Well, to be clear, that's not what you
do. That's the bare minimum.
>> What else do you want me to do? Do you
want me to ban him?
Yeah, I want you to ban every single
anti-destiny fan. I need you to pull
people. I want you to go pisco cash
patell, okay? And I need you to do a
loyalty test and if anybody was involved
in any of you [__] talking me, okay, if
there's some actual ought that some that
people think that I should do, present
it to me. Send it to me in a DM. Say it
when it's all I'll say. Listen, my whole
chat, I've been watching the whole time,
okay, are blowing up. They are super
pissed at you. They think your position
is disingenuous. They think you're lying
about this thing or whatever. They think
your argument is blah blah blah blah.
Your chat the entire time has been
saying, "I'm a pedophile. I have child
porn. I [__] kids. I do this." That's
the difference in terms of you guys like
should I person that? No, but like why
is there a difference there? I don't
know. Why is it between my community
either?
>> No, it's probably it's probably because
there aren't any credible alocations
against peace code of him interacting
sexually with miners. I think that's
probably got something to do with it.
That's probably I'd say the most
explanatory factor
and Casey Tron Frogan and um the other
[__] community whatever. Right. I
think at the end of the day it's good to
ask questions like this and not pretend
like all of it is a random chance an
accident and a big bang and who knows
how good anything could happen and if
you want to disingenuously pre like well
who should I [__] ban on who should
Trump have arrested to make it so he's
not guilty for J6 it's not a simple
matter at that point right like you
quoting soayor in the warhole case where
just because you say a thing is a thing
doesn't make the thing itself the thing
you know so there you go
>> you think I was disingenuous with my
citations of the warhole
>> probably but I have to read it because
the way you decided to make me think it
was disingenuous the citation sounded
like you were making it sound like she
said that just because something just
because
>> yeah but it sounded like you for
implying you were you were using that
quote and it sound like you were trying
to say what sort of am I was saying was
just because somebody says a thing um is
stealing content doesn't mean that
they're stealing content when my guess
is she was probably using it in the
opposite which is different because he
was probably using that as a defense for
his copyright infringement whereas um in
this case uh Dennis is using it as an
excuse for copyright infringement I
don't think the quote would necessarily
apply but
>> I mean you can just go look at Warhol
and see if you think I'm misrepresented
>> okay later yeah okay
wow
I got to go folks hope everyone is doing
well. All right, my guys stay cool.
I had some content, but I think you've
made me tired. I am genuinely tired. And
that conversation went on for like four
hours before. So, I know I made some
kind of agreement with where I said that
I would be available for this guy Hobbit
follower. Um, yeah, I know how to follow
follower. Hobbit follower. Why don't
you, you know, if you're still around
later tonight or something, you know, we
can have a conversation or whatever. Um,
I don't know. I can't, but definitely if
you're
I don't know what the um what the result
will be, but um you can make me normal
if I haven't been normal made normal
already. Also, we might actually have
cashell's interview with uh Katie
Miller, which you know, there's a killer
on the loose, folks. Let's not forget
that. Let's never forget that. Um, they
might have filmed before, but like still
horrible optics. I love you guys very
much. Appreciate your support. And even
if you know what my motto is, I love
haters. Keep hate. Keep hating and uh
and stay cool. Peace out.
Wow.